A GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE AND I
LIKE TO START OUT BY WELCOMING
ALL OF YOU TO THE INFORMATIONAL
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE. ON PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND ALSO THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES. AND INNOVATION. I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE PANELISTS.
FOR YOUR ATTENDANCE HERE TODAY.
ANDUP THIS PATIENT I ALSO WANT
TO THANK GOD THE AUDIENCE.
FOR JOINING US. AS WELL AS MY
COLLEAGUES AND NOW THEY WILL BE
MORE COMING.
HAS SO WE PROGRESS.
WHEN IT COMES TO EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF INNOVATION. BECAUSE
IT IS HOME TO SOME OF THE
WORLD'S LARGEST TECHNOLOGY
CORPORATIONS.
THESE TECHNOLOGIES HAVE
TRANSFORM OUR LIVES
FROM THE WAY WE WORK TO HOW WE
COMMUNICATE.
AND THEY CONTINUE TO DO SO WITH
EACH PASSING DAY.
BUT THE VERY PROMISES OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES HAVE ALSO
CHALLENGED US.
TO FOCUS ON THE LONG TERM IMPACT
THEY CAN HAVE ON SOCIETY.
AND WHAT THESE POLICIES ARE
NEEDED TO SAFEGUARD AGAINST
THEIR UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
AS A RESULT OUR APPROACH TO
TECHNOLOGY POLICY IN THE STATE.
HOUSE THE POTENTIAL OF NOT ONLY
INFORMING THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY.
BUT THE REST OF THE WORLD AS
WELL.
ONE TECHNOLOGICAL DEVELOPMENT
THAT WILL UNDOUBTEDLY. GLOBAL
IMPLICATIONS IS ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE OR A AYE.
A I IS AN EMERGING TECHNOLOGY
THAT IS A LINE AROUND THE
CONCEPT OF CREATING COMPUTER
PROGRAMS OR MACHINES CAPABLE OF
INTELLIGENT BEHAVIOR.
SIMILAR TO THAT EXHIBITED BY
HUMANS.
AS NOTED IN THE BACKGROUND PAPER
A AYE HOUSE IN INCREDIBLE
ABILITY.
CREATE A GLOBAL PARADIGM SHIFT.
THAT MAY PROPEL SOCIETY INTO AN
AUTOMATION AGE.
AND PROPOSED UNIQUE SOLUTIONS TO
SOME OF THE WORLD'S GREATEST
PROBLEMS.
BUT IT ALSO COMES WITH ITS OWN
WRISTS.
INCLUDING DISPLACING WORKERS
BIAS ALL LOSS OF PRIVACY AMONG
OTHER THINGS.
AS A RESULT A I WILL POST LEGAL
AND ETHICAL CONCERNS THAT WILL
REQUIRE INVOLVEMENT. FROM ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS.
WE AS LEGISLATORS MUST
FACILITATE DOT DIALOGUE.
FIND A BALANCE BETWEEN.
PROTECTING OUR STATE POPULATION
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY DRIVING
INNOVATION AND PRODUCTIVITY.
AS A LEADER IN THE GLOBAL
MARKETPLACE.
THIS HEARING IS INTENDED TO DO
JUST THAT.
IT WILL EXAMINE THE PROMISES AND
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH A
AYE.
HOW OVERALL ENDEAVOR IS TO
PROVIDE THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEES?
STAFF AND THE PUBLIC.
WITH THE GENERAL AND BALANCE
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT A AYE IS.
HOW IT WILL SHIFT CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC?
LABOR SOCIAL LANDSCAPE OVER THE
NEXT FIVE TO TEN YEARS.
AND ALSO HOW THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD BEGIN.
PAIR TO THINK ABOUT AND ADDRESS.
OR NOT ADDRESS ISSUES THAT MAY
ARISE AS A RESULT OF A AYE
APPLICATIONS.
IN DETERMINING HOW WE OPPOSE
THIS COMPLEX AND EMERGING ISSUE
WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TODAY
TO HEAR FROM. KEY ACADEMICS
INDUSTRIAL EXPERTS GOVERNMENTAL
LIAISONS AND ALSO CONSUMER
REPRESENTATIVES.
I LOOK FOR TO A ROBUST AND
INFORMATIVE DISCUSSION THAT
STRIKES THE RIGHT BALANCE AND
CREATES GREATER AWARENESS AND
UNDERSTANDING ON THE ISSUE OF A
AYE. NOW AND INTO THE FUTURE.
WITH THAT I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
YOU AGAIN FOR BEING HERE.
AND THE ARE ATTHIS TIME I LIKE
TO OPEN UP FOR MEMBERS TO. ON
MAKE OPENING REMARKS SO WOULD
ANYONE LIKE TO MAKE SOME OPENING
REMARKS.
A MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
SO MAY I ON THIS MICROPHONE.
BUT HARD TAKE YOU FOR CAN
ACTUALLY HEARING.
I THINK THIS IS A TREMENDOUSLY
IMPORTANT TOPIC AND IT'S BECAUSE
I BELIEVE THAT WE ARE AT AN
INFLECTION POINT. WHERE THESE
EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES ARE GOING
TO HAVE A TRANSFER MORE A
TRANSFORMATIVE IMPACT ON OUR
SOCIETY AND OUR GOVERNMENT AND
THEIR CATALYZED BY RECENT
ADVANCEMENTS IN A AYE? IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT A AYE IS JUST NOW
GETTING TO THE POINT WHERE IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S AFFECTING OUR
DAILY LIVES ONE WHEN I WAS DOING
RESEARCH IT ON A AYE AT CALTECH
IN YOU LEADER UCLA.
A I WAS SOMETHING THAT COULD
SOLVE A SIMPLE PROBLEM OVERNIGHT
RUNNING ON A ROOM SIZED COMPUTER
AND NOW. WE ALL CARRY AROUND IN
OUR POCKET DEVICES.
THAT WE CAN SAY HEY SEERY PLACE
SOME BEATLES AND IF YOU THINK
ABOUT THE THE TECHNOLOGY THAT
GOES INTO FOR FILLING THAT
REQUEST.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WOULD HAVE
JUST BOGGLES THE MIND EVEN
THIRTY YEARS AGO SO.
THOSE COULD HAVE SOME VERY
POSITIVE IMPACTS ON OUR
GOVERNMENT AND OUR SOCIETY BUT
ALSO I THINK IT'S FRAUGHT WITH
PERIL IN CHALLENGES FOR US. AS
WE EXAMINE THE WAYS IN WHICH
THESE EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES
IMPACT PRIVACY OTHER WAYS IMPACT
GOVERNANCE AND.
THE WAYS THAT IMPACT MORALITY
IN OUR SOCIETY SO I THINK IT'S A
VERY. IMPORTANT TOPIC FOR US TO
BE STRESSING THE LEGISLATURE AND
I AM LOOKING FORWARD TO BEING
PART OF THAT DISCUSSION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
ACCARDO THEY DON'T WANT TO THINK
THE CHAIR AND.
VICE CHAIR FOR BRINGING US
TOGETHER TALK ABOUT THIS ISSUE
AT LEAST I TRY TO UNDERSTAND A
LITTLE BIT BETTER I MEAN I THINK
APPROACHING THIS FROM A
STANDPOINT OF WORKFORCE AND WHAT
THIS MEANS IN TERMS OF.
IMPLEMENTATION OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND WHAT THAT MEANS
OFF FOR OUR ECONOMY MOVING
FORWARD IN THAT STATE OF THAT AS
CALIFORNIA AND AS A LEGISLATIVE
BODY WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO
PROMOTE.
AND HAVE AN INDUSTRY THAT
FOSTERS CREATIVITY AND
INNOVATION.
BUT THERE'S ALSO REAL
CHALLENGES WHEN IT COMES TO.
THESE NEW TECHNOLOGIES ARE
TAKING THE ROLE THAT WAS ONCE
FILLED BY AN INDIVIDUAL AND WHEN
YOU HAVE SO MANY OTHER
CHALLENGES ARE THAT WE'RE FACING
AS A STATE.
WHAT DOES THAT DO?
YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF.
EITHER HELPING OR OR
EXACERBATING THIS PROBLEM. AND
WHAT YOU KNOW IS BEING DONE OR
COULD CAN BE DONE TO USE
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE.
TO TO TRY TO HELP US SOLVE
THESE ISSUES ARE AND AND MAKE
THINGS A LITTLE BIT BETTER FOR
FOLKS.
YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT ASPECTS TO THIS ISSUE
I MEAN THAT AND I THINK THAT
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT.
DIFFERENTIATION BETWEEN THE I A
I THAT YOU KNOW HOW MY COLLEAGUE
WAS TALKING ABOUT WHETHER IT'S
IN OUR PHONE WHICH IS MORE. I TO
ME PROGRAMS AND PREDICTIVE AS
OPPOSED TO SOMETHING THAT'S
LITERALLY THINKING ON ITS OWN
AND AND AND AND THE AT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THAT.
AND THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
CONTAIN A CONTROL THAT.
AS A PUT IT AS IT COMES TO
PRIVACY IN DIFFERENT.
NOT PROTECTIONS ARE THAT WE
WOULD ALL WANT TO HAVE SO THESE
REALLY INTERESTING CONVERSATION
OBVIOUSLY IS A STATE ONE
CONTINUE TO BE A LEADER IN THIS
ISSUE.
BUT THIS IS DEFINITELY
SOMETHING THAT.
YOU KNOW IT IT IT IS IS GONNA
CONTINUE TO BE A MORE AND MORE
SIGNIFICANT CONVERSATION HAVE A
MORE SIGNIFICANT FOOTPRINT. UP
HERE WHAT DAY AND I THINK
EVERYBODY WHO'S
I SHOW UP IN.
PARTICIPATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF THERE ARE
NO FURTHER OPENING REMARKS I
LIKE TO. WELCOME OUR FIRST PANEL
SPEAKER WHO WILL PROVIDE US WITH
SOME BACKGROUND AND SPEAK TO THE
APPLICATIONS OF A AYE TECHNOLOGY
NOW. AND INTO THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE SO YEAH PLEASE HELP ME
WELCOME PROFESSOR ALL OF GRAFF
PHD AT HOLD INTERNATIONAL
BUSINESS SCHOOL. AT UC BERKELEY
A BRICK AND WAITS AND DAHLE
CAMBRIAN A AYE.
WELCOME PROFESSOR.
MUCH.
ANYTIME YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
DEAR.
CHAIRMAN CHAO YOUR MEMBERS OF
BOTH COMMITTEES THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY IS BOTH A
PLEASURE.
AND THE PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE
AND HELP IN THIS.
VERY IMPORTANT EXPLORATION OF
THEIRS OF VERY IMPORTANT PROBLEM
THAT WERE THAT WERE FACING.
AND I CALLED A PROBLEM.
BECAUSE WE DO WANT TO HARNESS
THE POWER OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE WHILE. ABOUNDING IN
SHAPING.
THE CHALLENGES THAT IT OFFERS.
TO WE ARE INDEED AT THE
THRESHOLD AT THE MOMENT.
BETWEEN.
A AYE BEING.
A.
NEW DEVELOPMENT THAT PROMISES
SIGNIFICANT GROWTH IN THE
ECONOMY AND THE I ALSO CAUSING
SIGNIFICANT DISRUPTIONS IN
SOCIETY.
WE ARE TORN BETWEEN.
THE HUMILITY OF SCIENTISTS
WHO ARE TRYING TO KEEP
PERSPECTIVE ON RECENT
BREAKTHROUGHS AND ADVANCES AND
THE BRAZEN RESOLVE OF
ENTREPRENEURS THAT HAVE MADE TO
STATE GREAT.
AND.
REALLY THE MIDDLE GROUND FOR A.
CONSTRUCTIVE PRODUCTIVE SOCIETY
LIES IN THE MIDDLE BETWEEN BOTH.
SO I'M GRATEFUL TO BE ASKED
TODAY TO OPINE ON THIS AND WOULD
LIKE TO GIVE YOU MY PERSPECTIVE.
AND THEN ALSO DRAW SOME
CONCLUSIONS ON WHAT I THINK
CALIFORNIA CAN DO AND WHY
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE SHOULD BE
CONCERNED AND VERY MUCH INVOLVED
IN THIS.
I WAS ASKED TO LAY THE
GROUNDWORK A BIT AND GIVE A FEW
DEFINITIONS ABOUT ONE A I MEAN
SO BEAR WITH ME WHILE I DO THAT.
I'M GOING TO TRY TO BE AS BASIC
ON THIS.
AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE IT IS
CONFUSING THERE IS A LOT OF
NOISE OUT THERE.
BETWEEN.
THE SKEPTICS.
BETWEEN THOSE THAT.
DEPICT AN ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE IN MOVIES.
THERE'S A LOT OF NOISE THAT'S
VERY ENTERTAINING BUT
UNFORTUNATELY NOT VERY
CONSTRUCTIVE.
CLEARLY DETERMINES OVERHYPED
WHAT IT IS SENSUALLY ENTAILS IS
AN ARRAY OF TECHNOLOGIES MAINLY
COMPUTING TECHNOLOGIES.
THAT SIMULATE FUNCTIONS THAT ARE
NORMALLY PERFORMED BY THE HUMAN
BRAIN COGNITIVE FUNCTIONS.
SO AMONGST THOSE ARE THINGS LIKE
SPEECH RECOGNITION LANGUAGE
TRANSLATION IMAGE RECOGNITION.
ABOUT ALSO THINGS AS BASIC AS
ADVANCED STATISTICAL.
METHODOLOGIES AND PREDICTIVE
ANALYTICS.
SO WHO WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THAT.
STATISTICS AT SOME POINT COULD
BECOME SO SEXY.
RIGHT NOW SO IT IS DEFINITELY
PART OF THE PICTURE.
WE NEED TO DISTINGUISH HERE.
THESE TECHNOLOGIES BETWEEN
WHAT'S CALLED A GENERAL
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
AND NO ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE.
MOST OF THE PUBLIC ATTENTION
HAS BEEN CAPTURED BY THE GENERAL
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE WHICH IS
OFTEN PREDICTED BY HOLLYWOOD AS
SUPER HUMAN INTELLIGENCE.
THIS IS THE KIND OF INTELLIGENCE
THAT ONLY HUMANS AND ANIMALS TO
DATE POSSESS.
TO VARYING DEGREES OF COURSE
AND IT IS ABLE TO.
LEARN.
WASTES A CERTAIN DATA SETS HOW
TO PERFORM CERTAIN FUNCTIONS AND
THEN TAKE THAT LEARNING AND
TRANSPOSE IT OVER INTO OTHER
FUNCTIONS.
IT IS ABLE TO LEARN FROM UP TO
TO MEMORIZE PREVIEWS LEARNING
AND THEN APPLY LESSONS FROM THE
PAST TO FUTURE AND FORWARD
LOOKING PROBLEMS AGAIN THAT IS.
USUALLY.
USUALLY THE HUMAN DOMAIN.
A AND COMPUTER SCIENTISTS ARE
SAYING THAT GENERAL ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE MIGHT AT SOME POINT
BE POSSIBLE. BUT THIS IS DECADES
IN THE FUTURE SO EIGHT OUT OF
TEN SCIENTISTS TELL ME THAT
GENERAL ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
IS AT LEAST TWO TO THREE DECADES
AWAY AND THAT'S USUALLY THE
OPTIMISTIC SIDE OF THINGS.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU CONSIDER
THAT IT HAS TAKEN US SEVENTY
YEARS TO GET TO THE CURRENT
POINT IN ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
OF COURSE BREAKTHROUGHS IN LEAPS
ARE POSSIBLE. NOW WE SHOULD
KNOWLEDGE THAT.
A NARROW ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
IS MOST OF THE ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE THAT WE SEE TODAY
IT IS VERY MUCH FOCUSED ON VERY
DISCREET FUNCTIONS.
SO WHEN YOU SEE.
IBM'S DEEP BLUE BEATING SOMEBODY
A CHESS OR WHEN YOU SEE OF
GOOGLE DEEP MIND ALPHA GO BEAT
THE WORLD'S RATING GO CHAMPION
THOSE OR OF CAR COURSE
IMPRESSIVE FEATS.
BUT THEY'RE VERY NARROW IN
FUNCTION.
IN OTHER WORDS.
THE TASK FOR THE COMPUTER IS TO
BEAT THEIR HUMAN CHESS CHAMPION.
BUT.
AS THE MACHINE THE I CANNOT
TELL YOU WHY IT IS MOVING.
A.
CERTAIN OF FIGURE ON THE CHESS
BOARD IN A CERTAIN WAY. OR WHY
IT IS PROTECTING THE KING.
IT CAN EQUALLY NOT TELL YOU
WHICH GAME TO PLAY TO SOLVE A
CERTAIN PROBLEM A CANNOT CHOOSE
BETWEEN CHESS AND GO ANOTHER.
OTHER GAMES
SO IT IS VERY LIMITED IN ITS
SCOPE AND IN THE TASK THAT IT IS
DESIGNED TO ACHIEVE.
SO WITH THAT SAID THEN.
SOME OF THESE TECHNOLOGIES THAT
YOU HEAR MENTIONED ARE.
.
DEEP NEURAL NETWORKS AND MACHINE
LEARNING THOSE ARE.
REALLY IS A MOST RECENT
BREAKTHROUGHS IN COMPUTER
SCIENCE WHEN IT COMES TO
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE.
THEY ARE SIGNIFICANT NOT JUST
BECAUSE THEY SOLVE COGNITIVE
PROBLEMS.
FOR US.
FOR HADES BUT ALSO BECAUSE THEY
HAVE PHYSICAL INSTANTIATIONS.
SO WE ARE INCREASINGLY SEEING
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE DRIVING
THINGS LIKE ROBOTS.
AUTOMATION AND FACTORIES
AUTONOMOUS FUNCTIONS IN VEHICLES
AND DRONES.
EVEN YOUR THERMOSTAT IN YOUR
HOME.
RIGHT SO I IN THIS IS MORE THAN
JUST A COMPUTER PROGRAM THAT IS
WELL CONTAINED IN A BOX OR IN A
NETWORK IT IS INCREASINGLY
DEFINING OUR PHYSICAL
ENVIRONMENT AS WELL.
THAT HAS DIFFERENT IMPACTS ON
OUR SOCIETY IF THE FIRST ONE IS
OF COURSE ECONOMIC.
YOU HAVE ALREADY MENTIONED THIS
CHAIRMAN CHAO.
THE IMPACT ON TIED JOBS.
YEAH.
WE ARE ALREADY SEEING
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE.
AT FORCE IN ENTERPRISE
SOLUTIONS.
WE ARE SEEING BASIC TASKS THAT
SEEM VERY HUMAN FOR US PERFORMED
BY MACHINES SUCH AS SECRETARIAL.
SERVICES PERFORMED BY A ME.
AND ELLIE AND OTHERS OF VIRTUAL
SECRETARIES THAT.
WHEN IT COMES TO PURE EMAIL
DIALOGUE BETWEEN YOU AND THEM
YOU WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
DISTINGUISH THE COMPUTER FROM
THE HUMAN.
THERE ARE SOCIETAL IMPLICATIONS
HERE.
THAT HAVE TO DO WITH CHANGING
THE WAYS IN WHICH WE RELATE AND
INTERACT.
AND HOW WE COMMUNICATE TRUST
FOR INSTANCE VERY IMPORTANT. AND
THEN THEY ARE PURELY
PSYCHOLOGICAL ONES THAT.
ENABLE THAT HAVE A I HAD
CHANGED THE WAY IN IN WHICH WE
LOOK UPON OURSELVES.
AND IN WHICH WE CONCEIVE OF US
AS OF OURSELVES AS.
PERSONS OF HAVING PERSONHOOD.
VERY IMPORTANT AS WELL.
WHY SHOULD WE CARE?
AS CITIZENS AS POLICY MAKERS.
IN YOUR ROLE.
A AYE CHANGES.
THE WAY WE ACT OUT INTIMACY.
SO.
THE COMPUTER AND THE
CORPORATION THAT OWNS THE
COMPUTER HAS A MUCH MORE
INTIMATE UNDERSTANDING OF WHO WE
ARE.
AND WE ACCEPT THAT BECAUSE WE
GET SOMETHING IN RETURN
BUT WE DON'T NECESSARILY
ACCEPTED AT IN FULL CONSCIOUS
CONSCIENCE OF CONSCIOUSNESS
ASKED WHAT THAT ACTUALLY MEANS
FOR US.
SO THE DEGREE OF INTIMACY
BETWEEN US IN THE MACHINE IS
CHANGING.
WE ARE TODAY IN A HYPER
CONNECTED WORLD.
SO THIS DEGREE OF CHANGE IS
SPREADING THROUGH NETWORKS AND
THROUGH OUR SOCIETAL FABRIC VERY
FAST.
IF WE I HAD HAPPENED IN THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES WE WOULDN'T
HAVE THE SAME PHENOMENON SIMPLY
BECAUSE THE CONNECTIVITY THE
NETWORKS WERE IN THERE.
OUR THIRD.
A ICE CONNECTED WITH THE THINGS
THAT WE REALLY WANT ON MANY OF
THESE INTERNET PLATFORMS WE GET
SERVICES WE GET PRODUCTS WE GET
RELATIONSHIPS THAT WE ERCEIVE
AS ENRICHING OF OUR LIVES.
SO THAT'S A GOOD THING.
BUT IT COMES AT A COST.
AND THEN LASTLY ALL OF THIS
HAPPENS AT INCREDIBLE SPEED.
THAT IS IN PART BECAUSE WE NOW
HAVE.
OUR MACHINES COMPUTERS
ALGORITHMS TALK TO OTHER
MACHINES
AND DEVELOP CHO WOOD.
BY THEMSELVES.
THAT IS IN IT'S VERY EARLY
STAGES NOT EVERY QUARTER IS
GOING TO BE DISPLACED.
BUT THERE IS A SPEED ELEMENT IN
THIS THAT WE NEED TO RECKON
WITH.
SECONDLY I'LL A LOT OF.
THESE NEW A AYE PLATFORMS.
ARE OPEN SOURCE.
SO WITH THE DEVELOPER COMMUNITY
AROUND THE WORLD CAN NOW DEVELOP
THEIR OWN APPLICATIONS.
PRETTY MUCH FREELY.
S. SO YOU CAN IMAGINE MILLIONS
OF CODERS NOW TAKING TO THE SAY
I APPLICATIONS.
WITH WITH NO THINKING NO
CONSIDERATION AS TO WHAT THE
SECOND AND THIRD ORDER EFFECTS
OF THIS ARE. SO IT'S VERY FAST
AND YEAH I'M GONNA QUOTE LARRY
DOWNES LOFT DISRUPTION HERE THAT
SAYS THAT.
TECHNOLOGY ALWAYS CHANGES
EXPONENTIALLY.
BUT SOCIETY AND POLICY CHANGE
INCREMENTALLY.
SO SPEED IS REALLY OF THE
ESSENCE HERE SPEED OF
UNDERSTANDING AND SPEED OF A
SHAPING.
.
WHY DO I BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA
CAN PLAY A A DISTINCT ROLE IN
THIS A BECAUSE WE ARE ONE OF
THE?
HUBS OF INNOVATION AROUND
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE WE
BENEFIT FORM IT'S GROSS.
BUT COMMENSURATE WITH THAT
BENEFIT NEEDS TO BE A SENSE OF
RESPONSIBILITY.
SECONDLY WE HAVE A LEGACY AND
WE HAVE A TRACK RECORD
OF.
BEING HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL ON THE
TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION SIDE.
BEING A GROWTH ENGINE FOR THE
NATION AND INDEED FOR THE REST
OF THE WORLD AND YET BEING VERY
INNOVATIVE WHEN IT COMES TO
SOCIAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
SO THERE'S REALLY NO REASON. FOR
WHY WE SHOULD SHY AWAY FROM THIS
CURRENT CHALLENGE.
YEAH AND OF COURSE WE ARE THE
SIXTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD TO DATE SO WHAT WE DO SETS
TRENDS.
INTERNATIONALLY AND IT'S NOT
JUST ECONOMICS IT'S ALSO
CALIFORNIA CULTURE THAT.
THAT CATCHES ON A GLOBALLY SO
WE HAVE A SIGNALLING EFFECT.
I WANT TO WRAP THIS INTO GLOBAL
CONTEXT THOUGH AND THIS IN THIS
VEIN.
WE ARE.
ALONGSIDE CHINA I THINK THE
NUMBER ONE INNOVATION HOTSPOT
FOR ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
THERE ARE OTHER.
U. S. LOCATIONS THAT ARE VERY
IMPORTANT BOSTON OF COURSE.
PITTSBURGH SEATTLE.
VERY IMPORTANT TYPES AS WELL
INTERNATIONALLY THERE ARE OTHER
HUBS ISRAEL.
CANADA AND THE UK GERMANY
RUSSIA.
BUT CHINA IS REALLY THE BIG KID
ON THE BLOCK WHITE MOD
HIGHLIGHTING THIS I BY NO MEANS
ONE TO FALL INTO THE PATTERN OF
DESCRIBING CHINA AS AN ENEMY.
BUT THEY ARE VERY SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCES IN OUR VALUE SETS
AND WE ARE SEEING THIS ACTED OUT
AND LIVED OUT AS WE SPEAK.
AND I THINK WE DO NEED TO AT
LEAST UNDERSTAND THOSE BETTER
AND COME TO GRIPS WITH THEM.
CHINA IS INVESTING VERY HEAVILY
ON THE PUBLIC SIDE.
IT IS HARD TO SAY WHETHER THEY
HAVE ALREADY.
OUTSPEND US.
THEY ARE SPENDING TO CREATE A
HUNDRED FIFTY BILLION DOLLAR A
AYE INDUSTRY BY TWENTY THIRTY.
AND THEY'RE DOING SO VERY
OVERTLY AND FOSTERING A PUBLIC
SECTOR A PRIVATE SECTOR.
R. AND D. AND PRODUCT IS ASIAN.
THEY ARE REQUIRING THAT STUDENTS
IN HIGH SCHOOL.
AND IN FACT IN PRIMARY SCHOOL
ARE LEARNING HOW TO CODE IN HOW
TO DEAL WITH ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENT NATIONWIDE THAT'S
ACROSS ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
CHINESE.
AND.
ARE AND THEY'RE ALSO SETTING UP
INNOVATION HUBS.
TO THE TUNES OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AT A TIME REGIONALLY.
IT IS HARD TO SAY HOW WE STACK
UP BECAUSE A LOT OF THE SPENDING
ON THE UNITED STATES ASIDE IS.
CLASSIFIED. AND IT IS DEFENSE
SPENDING.
I SHOULD HOWEVER NOTE AS YOU'RE
ALL AWARE THAT WE ARE
DRAMATICALLYCUTTING BACK ON
SCIENCE FUNDING ON A FEDERAL
LEVEL.
AND OUR SCIENCE REPRESENTATION.
GLOBALLY AS WELL AT A MOMENT
WHEN CHINA IS INCREASING BOTH.
ON THE DEFENSE SIDE WE HAVE
FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT SPENDING.
ABOUT SEVEN POINT FOUR BILLION.
MOST OF WHICH.
IS REAL A SPENT ON.
ON.
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE OR
RELATED SMART COMPUTING AND.
BIG DATA AND CLOUD TECHNOLOGIES.
SO ABOUT A THIRD OF THAT I
BELIEVE IS ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND OF COURSE
THERE'S NO TELLING WHAT ELSE IS
IN THAT A DEFENSE BUDGET BECAUSE
IT'S NOT PUBLIC.
SO THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
SPENDING THEIR ON THE.
PRIVATE SECTOR SIDE WE ARE
STILL AHEAD.
WE HAVE.
SOME OF THE LEADING INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS INTERNET
COMPANIES I DON'T REALLY NEED TO
MENTION THEM GOOGLE FACEBOOK. OF
MICROSOFT OR APPLE.
AND OTHERS.
BUT THE CHINESE ARE.
CLOSING RANKS PRETTY QUICKLY BY
DO ALI BABA TENSE AND.
ARE CHINESE LEADERS AT THIS
POINT BUT ARE BEING PROMOTED TO
GO GLOBAL FAIRLY QUICKLY NOW AND
WITH CHINA'S INVESTMENT AROUND
THE WORLD AND INFRASTRUCTURE A
LOT OF THE INTERNET TECHNOLOGIES
WILL RIDE ON THE BACK. OF THOSE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
TECHNOLOGIES.
CHINA HAS SOME OTHER ADVANTAGES
SUCH AS VERY HEAVY MOBILE
PENETRATION ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION MOBILE DATA USERS. THAT
ARE FRANKLY.
SOMEWHAT MORE PROFICIENT.
AND.
MORE EXPERIENCE IN DEALING WITH
DIGITAL TECHNOLOGIES ON THE
MOBILE HANDSETS IN EVERY SINGLE
ASPECT OF THEIR LIVES WECHAT IS
ONLY ONE EXAMPLE OF THAT.
AND THEY'RE VERY ACCEPTING OF
THAT PENETRATION IN THEIR LIVES.
.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST CHINESE
RESEARCHERS HAVE RECENTLY
OVERTAKING U. S. RESEARCHERS
WHEN IT COMES TO THE NUMBER OF.
OF ARTICLES AND PAPERS
PUBLISHED.
SO.
WE ARE DEALING WITH A
FORMIDABLE.
FORMIDABLE PARTNER AND
COMPETITOR ON A GLOBAL SCALE.
CHINA IS ALSO INVESTING CO
INVESTING WITH US I SHOULD SAY
YEAH I'M HERE AND I THINGS LIKE
THE NEW DOMMEL ACADEMY AT STANDS
FOR DISCOVERY ADVENTURE MOMENTUM
IN OUTLOOK.
ALI BABA I SPENDING FIFTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS ON PARTNERSHIPS
THAT.
ENCOMPASS ALSO.
A. S. U. S. YOU VARIOUS U. S..
INSTITUTIONS AND ACTORS.
THAT.
THAT ALSO INCLUDE CALIFORNIANS
TO XIN SUCH AS A UC BERKELEY IN
ORDER TO DEVELOP TALENT.
SO THERE IS A THERE ARE A LOT
OF ASPECTS IN THIS WHERE WE ARE
TIED BY THE HIP AND TALENT IS
ONE OF THEM.
SO THE KEY QUESTIONS ARE WILL
THE FUTURE OF AMERICAN GLOBALLY
I DEVELOPMENT CONTINUE TO EMERGE
FROM CALIFORNIA.
WILL IT EMERGE FROM CHINA
PRIMARILY OR WILL IT BE A
PARTNERSHIP.
I LIKE TO LOOK AT THIS THROUGH
THREE LENSES THE FIRST ONE IS
POWER THE SECOND THIS PURPOSE
AND THE THIRD IS POSITION.
I GUESS WE'RE GOING TO DEAL WITH
POSITION LAST. A BECAUSE
POSITION IS REALLY STRATEGY AND
POLICY AND THAT'S FOR THE LAST
PANEL.
POWERS MOSTLY ARTICULATED
THROUGH ECONOMICS.
AND THERE OF COURSE WE HAVE
SEEN MANY STUDIES HOW.
A AYE OR AND ROBOTICS
AUTOMATION READ LARGE WILL
REPLACE DISPLACED LABOR.
WE HAVE SEEN DIFFERENT FIGURES
OUT THERE RANGING FROM SIXTEEN
PERCENT TO FORTY SIX PERCENT.
I BELIEVE WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM MCKINSEY LATER ON IN THE
DAY.
.
WE HAD BERKELEY WHICH BELIEVES
THAT THE PICTURE IS A BIT MORE
DIFFERENTIATED WE NEED TO LOOK
AT THIS ON A TASK AND JOB
SPECIFIC BASIS.
A I WILL BE PERVASIVE THROUGHOUT
ALMOST EVERY JOB THE QUESTION IS
WHAT PART OF A GIVEN JOB AT THE
MOMENT WILL IT DISPLACE OR
CHANGING HOW DISRUPTIVE WILL
THAT BE.
THEY ARE OPTIMISTIC.
QUOTES HERE THAT SAY THAT WE
COULD BE LOOKING AT SOMETHING
LIKE THIRTY EIGHT PERCENT OF
REVENUE INCREASE FOR GLOBAL
CORPORATIONS THAT'S.
MULTI TRILLION DOLLAR OF REVENUE
INCREASES IN TOTAL AROUND THE
WORLD AND THAT WE MIGHT SEE AS
MUCH AS A TEN PERCENT INCREASE
IN FACT IN EMPLOYMENT.
RIGHT SO THERE'S THERE'S A LOT
OF UPSIDE HERE THAT WE ALSO
SHOULD NOT IGNORE.
.
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES LOOK AT THIS
VERY DIFFERENTLY AROUND THE
WORLD.
JAPAN IS NOT AFRAID OF THIS
BECAUSE JAPAN IS IN FACT A DYING
NATION.
THE.
THE BIRTH RATETHAT DOES NOT
SUSTAIN THE ECONOMY THEIR OUT OF
WORKERS AND SO THEY WELL VERY
MUCH WELCOME ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND ROBOTS AND IN
FACT VERY HUMANOID ROBOTS.
GERMANY FOR INSTANCE IN THE
NORDIC COUNTRIES ARE LOOKING AT
THIS IN A VERY INTEGRATED.
WAY. OF.
USING A AYE TO FACILITATE LABOR
A VERY COLLABORATIVE STANCE WITH
LABOR UNIONS.
AND I THINK A BIT OF A ROLE
MODEL FOR US IF YOU DON'T MIND
MY SAYING SO.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE FOUND OUT
THAT THE JOIN PRODUCTIVITY
BETWEEN A AYE INCREASES THE
PRODUCTIVITY AND HUMAN
PRODUCTIVITY INCREASES IS EVEN
HIGHER WHEN SEEN JOINTLY.
SO THESE ARE JUST A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES OF THE SPECTRUM
GLOBALLY WE'RE ALSO SEEING VERY
PROMISING INNOVATION AROUND THE
WORLD IN SPACES WHERE YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE.
EXPECTED THEM SUCH AS.
IT AS SUCH AS.
NIGERIA INDONESIA OF RUSSIA.
AND WE CAN DIVE INTO THAT SOME
MORE IN CUBA NAY IF YOU LIKE.
THERE ARE RISKS AND.
CHANGES TO SOCIETY WE CAN'T
IGNORE.
AND.
YOU KNOW I WANT TO JUST
OUTLINED A FEW PRIVACY OF COURSE
IS ONE OF THEM.
WE HAVE LEADING IN OF
INNOVATORS IN CALIFORNIA.
SUCH AS WE BOUGHT FOR INSTANCE
FOR PSYCHOTHERAPY.
VERY SUCCESSFULLY USING.
DIGITAL CBT.
COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL
TRANSFORMATION AS PART OF
FACEBOOK FOR INSTANCE AND
THEY'RE GOING TO GREAT LENGTHS.
GUY TRYING TO PROTECT THEIR
DATA.
WE WILL HAVE TO SEE WHETHER
THAT GOES FOR EVERYBODY IN THIS
FIELD BUT I THINK THAT IS A.
THAT IS A GOOD EXAMPLE OF WHAT
IT SHOULD BE LIKE.
I TRANSPARENCY.
WHEN FACEBOOK TELLS US THAT FROM
NOW ON THE USING FACIAL
RECOGNITION SOFTWARE.
TO ENHANCE OUR EXPERIENCE ON
FACEBOOK WHAT EXACTLY DOES THAT
MEAN.
I COULD ALWAYS HAVE MY FACE A
TRACED
A BECAUSE IT WAS ASSOCIATED WITH
MY NAME.
THIS INCREASED CAPABILITY WILL
IT NOW BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND MY
MOOD IN CERTAIN SITUATIONS.
WITH CERTAIN PEOPLE AROUND ME I
DON'T KNOW AND I THINK WE SHOULD
SO WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND AND
BECOME MORE TRANSPARENT ABOUT
WHAT THESE TECHNOLOGIES ARE USED
FOR. AND TO SOME DEGREE WE NEED
TO MAKE THE MORE EXPLAINABLE
RIGHT WE HAVE A DARPA INVESTING
HEAVILY IN.
A I EXPLAINED ABILITY USING ONE
TOP OF A AYE TO EXPLAIN ANOTHER
TAPE TYPE OF A AYE.
AND THAT'S HOW COMPLEX IT IS
TODAY BECAUSE SOME OF THESE
MODELS ARE GET REALLY REALLY.
REALLY REALLY COMPLEX AND HARD
TO UNDERSTAND.
WE OF COURSE HAVE THE LAPD THE
NYPD USING PREDICTIVE TO.
ANALYTICS AND MACHINE LEARNING
AND OTHER A AYE TECHNOLOGIES IN
ORDER TO.
SECURE OR SAFER NEIGHBORHOODS
AND FOR PREDICTIVE POLICING. AND
WE ALL KNOW THAT THAT IS BEING
FOUGHT OUT IN COURT RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE SOME OF THESE ALGORITHMS
CAN'T REALLY TELL YOU WHY YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD WAS IDENTIFIED AS
PARTICULARLY. RISKY AND A
COMMUNITIES FEEL STIGMATIZED.
SO SO EXPLAINED ABILITY IS A A
BIG PROBLEM AND WE NEED TO
DEMAND MORE OF IT BUT WE NEED TO
BE VERY DIFFERENTIATED.
APPLICATION AREA BY APPLICATION
AREA LEST WE WANT TO HAVE VERY
GENERAL OVER ARCHING REGULATION
SUCH AS THE EUROPEAN. UNION.
DATA PROTECTION DIRECTIVE THAT
WAS JUST.
RELEASED AND IS COMING TO
FRUITION THIS YEAR.
WHICH AS INNOVATORS AROUND THE
WORLD.
VERY RETICENT
TO INVEST IN EUROPE BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO BE SLAPPED WITH
BILLION DOLLAR FINES SO I THINK
WE HAVE TO BE A BIT MORE NUANCED
AND APPLICATION SPECIFIC.
THEN THERE IS THE AREA OF AGENCY
WHICH IS PERSONAL CHOICE.
AM I BEING NARROWED IN MY CHOICE
BECAUSE ALGORITHMS FIGURE OUT
WHO I AM. AND THEY FIGURE OUT
WHAT I AM ATTRACTED TO YOU AND
THEY KEEP ME ON THAT TRAJECTORY
ALWAYS SPEEDING ME MORE CONTENT
MORE RELATIONSHIPS MORE PRODUCTS
AND SERVICES THAT ARE PLAYING
INTO WHO I AM TODAY.
Y. WAS YESTERDAY.
OR WILL A AYE ENABLE ME TO
EXPAND MY HORIZONS AND MY SET OF
CHOICES IN WAYS THAT I HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO ENJOY BEFORE THAT
IS A VERY BIG QUESTION.
THAT NEEDS TO BE RESOLVED.
SO.
SO THOSE ARE THE SOCIETAL
ISSUES NOT TO MENTION SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF COURSE WE'VE TALKED
A LITTLE BIT IN A AYE ABOUT.
ACCIDENT PREVENTION ABOUT
MORALLY DICEY SITUATIONS YOU
PROBABLY HEARD ABOUT THE TROLLEY
PROBLEM.
HOW DOES IT AUTONOMOUS
AUTOMOBILE OR THE A AYE IN IT OR
IN THE NETWORK THAT GOVERNS IT?
DECIDE WHEN TO.
HIT A DOG IN THE ROAD OR A TREE
ON THE SIDE OF THE ROAD.
AND OF COURSE IDEALLY
AUTOMAKERS WILL KEEP US OUT OF
THAT SITUATION TO BEGIN WITH BUT
THERE MAY BE OF MARGINAL
SITUATIONS WHERE THAT BECOMES
VERY IMPORTANT.
WE ALSO NEED TO PAY ATTENTION TO
AUTHENTICITY AND VERACITY IN
SOCIETY AND THAT IS BEING
THREATENED AS WE ALL KNOW.
EH THROUGH.
THROUGH.
MANIPULATIVE ACTORS ON OUR
SOCIAL MEDIA WE'RE NOW SEEING
THE EMERGENCE OF WHAT I WOULD
CALL DEEP FAKE ACTORS.
THAT ARE NOT REAL THAT ARE
PRETENDING TO BE.
TO BE IN DECISION MAKING
PROCESS SEIZE.
THAT WILL BE A PROBLEM FOR HOW
WE TRANSACT IN HOW WE ENACT
DIPLOMACY FOR INSTANCE.
A SO THESE ARE ALL AREAS THAT
IMPACT OUR SOCIETAL FABRICTHAT
IMPACT HOW WE LIVE TRUSTS.
TRUST TO ME IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT CURRENCY IN SOCIETY.
AND TRUST WILL.
DETERMINE WHETHER WE AS
CALIFORNIA WILL THRIVE WHETHER
WE WILL BE TORN APART. AND WE
HAVE SEEN MUCH OF THIS HAPPENED
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS A
IN OUR SOCIETY.
SO WE NEED TO GET AHEAD OF THIS
OUR AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
MACHINE.
SILICATES THAT HE AYE
FACILITATES OUR HUMAN FABRIC OUR
TRUST OUR PROSPERITY BUT NOT
JUSTPROSPERITY IN TERMS OF
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. ALSO IN
TERMS OF HUMAN GROWTH AND HUMAN
DEVELOPMENT.
THE MACHINE NEEDS TO FACILITATE
US A. I. NEEDS TO FACILITATE US
IT SHOULDN'T WE SHOULDN'T SERVE
A AYE RIGHT. I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW.
SO AT THE END OF THE DAY THIS
SHOULD ABOUT A BE ABOUT US
CREATING A BETTER SOCIETY
SOLVING SOCIETY'S PROBLEMS
RATHER THAN BEING RUN BY THE
MACHINES AND I THINK THERE'S A
REAL. POTENTIAL FOR THAT TO
ENGAGE IN A REAL PARTNERSHIP.
A ICE HERE TO STAY. IT IS
OVERHEATED THERE IS A BUBBLE.
BUT IT'S NOT GOING TO GO AWAY
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE DOT COM
BUST.
I THINK WHAT WE WOULD HAVE TO
CONCLUDE IS THAT YES WE OVER
HEATED THE BUBBLE BURST BUT THE
INTERNET WAS HERE TO STAY.
IT IS STILL HERE TO STAY.
AND IT IS MORE PERVASIVE THAN
EVER AND I BELIEVE A I WILL GO
THROUGH A SIMILAR CYCLE.
THE POTENTIAL FOR CHANGE
POSITIVE CHANGE IS A VAST.
IF WE SHAPE IT AND GET AHEAD OF
IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH UPPER PHOTOGRAPH A
WITHOUT THAT LIKE TO OPEN A FULL
QUESTIONS.
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO ASK
LET ME START OFF WITH MY
QUESTION EARLIER YOU TALKED
ABOUT BIG DATA ARE YOU KNOW JUST
WONDERING WHAT KIND OF DATA IS
BEING COLLECTED BY ALL THESE
TECHNOLOGIES AND WHETHER
WHATEVER THE APPLICATION MAY BE.
SO ODD EASIER ONE COMMON THEME
IS THERE ONCE ONE COMMENTS
SORTED DATA HAS BEEN COLLECTED
BY BY THESE.
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES
WHATSOEVER. YET TO GO TO TO
DESCRIBE IT BROADLY WHAT.
.
WHAT'S MOST VALUABLE IS WHAT'S
CALLED LIFE PATTERN DATA.
SO DATA THAT.
SPEAKS TO YOUR LIFE PATTERN TO
YOUR PERSONALITY TWO YOUR
MOVEMENT.
THROUGHOUT THE DAY.
THE STRUCTURE OF YOUR LIFE.
UNDERSTANDING WHAT'S MOST
VALUABLE TO YOU.
AND.
THAT IS OF COURSE THEN THE
HIGHEST VALUE BECAUSE IF A
COMPANY CONSERVE SERVICES INTO
THAT NEEDS PICTURE. TAKING
COMMAND.
MONEY. HIGHER PRICES AND WE
LIKE IT AND IT'S ENRICHES OUR
LIVES.
OUR LIVES
SO LIFE PATTERN DATA IS REALLY
THE MOVEMENT PATTERN THE SOCIAL
STRUCTURE.
THE RELATIONSHIPS IS REALLY
WHERE MOST OF THE.
WITH MOST OF THE VALUE IS.
ADDED ARE YOU ALSO TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THEIR WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS DOING WHEN
IT COMES TO FUNDING.
YOU KNOW WHETHER THE FUNDING
ARE IS BEING ALLOCATED TO DEFEND
THEIR OTHERWISE SO DO YOU SEE
WHAT DO YOU SEE THE TREND BEING
ARE LET'S SAY FROM THAT SAVED
FROM PREVIOUS. ON ADMINISTRATION
TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY I MEAN DO
YOU SEE OUT THAT DOT OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF A AYE AND AS SUCH
OR ASA RESULT THEN WE
ALLOCATING MORE FUNDING INTO.
INTO THIS AREA OR NOT AND
THOUGHTFUL OF QUESTION IS THAT
YOU KNOW IF SO OR REGARDLESS IN
WHAT CATEGORIES ARE WELL WE
BASICALLY. ARE USING THAT THE
FUNDING FOR OUR AND.
DOING IT APPROPRIATELY YEAH.
VERY GOOD QUESTIONS SO I THINK
WE SAW THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
BEING VERY ACTIVELY.
CONCERNED WITH SETTING A A AN
AGENDA AND ECONOMIC AND THE
SOCIAL AGENDA.
RECOGNIZING BOTH THE POTENTIAL
AND THE RISKS.
I THINK THIS WAS TOWARD THE END
OF THE ADMINISTRATION.
I'M UNAWARE AS TO THE SIZE OF
THE FUNDING AT THE TIME.
I THINK.
JUDGING BY RECENT CONVERSATIONS
WITH AND PUBLICATIONS BY PEOPLE
LIKE MICHAEL CAUGHT CIOS AT THE.
AT THE O. A STEEP BE THE OFFICE
OF SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY POLICY
THAT DEPUTY CTO.
WE RECENTLY MADE ABOUT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE
SPECIFICALLY TO.
R. AND D. IN ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE IT IS NOT CLEAR TO
ME.
WHETHER THIS IS PART OF THE
SEVEN POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
SPEND AT THE DOD ON A AYE AND
RELATED TECHNOLOGIES OR WHETHER
THIS IS SEPARATE.
AT I ALSO DON'T KNOW HOW THIS
RECONCILES WITH THE.
EXISTING OR THREATENED DE
FUNDING OF SCIENCE AND THE
FUTURE AND SF BUDGET.
SO THOSE ARE THOSE ALL STILL BE
QUESTION MARKS
YEAH YEAH I'M SO YEAH IS THEIR
EMPHASIS ON ANY PARTICULAR AREAS
FOR EXAMPLE AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES
OR OTHERWISE.
AS FAR AS CATEGORIES OF FUNDING
THAT. NYSERDA CERTAINLY WHAT
WE'RE HEARING IS AUTONOMOUS
WEAPONS SYSTEMS.
AND RELATED COMMANDING CONTROL
AND GOVERNANCE STRUCTURES.
SO THIS IS NOT NECESSARILY SOME
THE FAIRIES ACTIVITY THIS IS
THIS IS UNDERSTANDING HOW DO WE
RELATE TO.
SMART MACHINES IN THE
BATTLEFIELD.
OR IN POLICING AND HOW DO WE
MAKE WHAT THE MACHINE DECIDES
RECOMMENDS EXPLAINABLE TO
THE HUMAN DECISION MAKER.
AND.
AND SO I THINK THAT'S ONE BIG
AREA. I THINK.
BRAIN COMPUTER INTERFACES IS
ANOTHER AREA WHERE A I WILL BE
INSTRUMENTAL. AND I KNOW THAT
THAT IS ALSO BEING STUDIED.
ACT ARE BY NO THE PLACES.
AND ISRAEL IN PARTICULAR ALSO
HAS SOME VERY EXCITING.
NEW VENTURES IN THAT AREA.
SO THOSE ARE JUST A FEW AREAS
AMONGST OTHERS.
A MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO YOU
MENTIONED THE EXPLAINED ABILITY
PROBLEM.
AND THAT IS AN AREA THAT I THINK
IS GOING TO.
REPRESENTS ONE TO KEEP THE KEY
PROBLEMS WITH THE INTEGRATION OF
THESE EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES INTO
SOCIETY.
SO WHEN WE HAVE AN ALGORITHM.
AN ALGORITHMIC SOLUTION TO THE
PROCESSING OF DATA AT LEAST WE
CAN EXPLAIN TO PEOPLE HOW WE GOT
TO THE RESULT FROM THE INPUT BUT
WHEN WE HAVE. A A NEURAL NETWORK
THAT WERE TRAINING WITH MACHINE
LEARNING WE REALLY CAN'T
ARTICULATE THAT AND SO YOU CAN
ANTICIPATE. A TIME A COUPLE
YEARS FROM NOW WHERE WE GOT
INSURANCE COMPANIES THAT ARE
SETTING.
LIFE INSURANCE RATES BASED ON
LIFE EXPECTANCIES ARE CALCULATED
FROM THESE BIG DATA SETS AND WE
CAN'T ARTICULATE TO PEOPLE WHY.
THIS PARTICULAR SET OF PEOPLE IS
AT GREATER RISK THAN THIS SET OF
PEOPLE I COULD BE. A OF A WIDE
VARIETY A COMBINATION OF THINGS
SO WHEREAS NOW. YOU CAN EXPLAIN
TO SOMEONE LOOK YOUR SMOKER AND
THAT'S WHY YOUR AVERAGE LIFE
EXPECTANCY IS LOWER THEY MIGHT
NOT LIKE IT BUT THEY ACCEPTED
WHEREAS WE GET INTO TO THE.
.
THE EXPLAINED ABILITY PROBLEM
SPACE WHERE I YOU KNOW WE REALLY
CAN'T ARTICULATE THAT SO THE
QUESTION IT'S OPEN AND QUESTION
WHAT WHAT CAN WE DO ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE I SEE THAT AS A BIG
HINDRANCE. IN THE UP OUR ABILITY
TO USE A AYE IN WAYS THAT ARE
PRODUCTIVE TO OUR SOCIETY NOW. I
THINK IS THAT THAT'S A THAT'S A
AND EMILY IMPORTANT QUESTION
RIGHT NOW WE'RE SEEING A AYE
BEING USED BY COURTS AND BY
JUDGES.
IN VARIOUS U. S. STATES.
MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT.
RECIDIVISM AND ABOUT BAIL
DECISIONS.
THAT ARE FRAUGHT WITH BIAS.
AND IT'S NOT THAT THE MACHINE IS
BIASED IT'S THE HUMAN THAT
CREATED THE DATA.
THAT GETS FED INTO THE MACHINE
THAT IS BIASED AND I THINK THE
WAY TO COUNTERACT THIS A IS TO.
DO TWO THINGS.
FIRST OF ALL WE NEED TO WE NEED
TO GOVERN THIS WE NEED TO SEE
THROUGH IT WE MIGHT NEED TO MAKE
IT TRANSPARENT.
SO IF IT IF THESE ARE A AYE
APPLICATIONS IN THE PUBLIC
INTEREST WE NEED TO DEMAND THAT.
THE LOGIC BY WHICH OF THESE.
ALGORITHMS MAKE THESE DECISIONS
NEEDS TO BE MADE OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT SO THAT DEFENDING
COUNSEL CAN ALSO HAVE ACCESS TO
IT.
SO THAT IS DEFINITELY ONE THING
WE HAVE TO DO SECONDLY I THINK
WE NEED TO START LOOKING AT. A
VERY FINE.
OR ALTERNATIVELY SCRUBBING A
DATA SETS OF FROM BIAS.
AND MAKING SURE THAT THE DATA
THAT IS OUT THERE ALREADY.
THROUGH THE INTERNET THAT WE
ARE ALL USING AS IT IS FED INTO
THE MACHINE ISN'T.
THAT THAT BIAS INGRAINED IN THAT
DATA SAID ISN'T EXACERBATED
WHICH IS WHAT IS HAPPENING
TODAY.
SO THAT NEEDS TO BE SOME
REQUIREMENT.
OF DIAGNOSING AND SCANNING FOR
AND THEN SCRUBBING FOR THAT BAS.
THAT TO ME WOULD BE THE SECOND
SET OF RECOMMENDATIONS.
THAT'S
IT MAKES PERFECT SENSE.
MY FEAR WOULD BE THAT THAT
REQUIRES A AN INCREASED LEVEL OF
SOPHISTICATION ON BEHALF OF THE
PUBLIC TO UNDERSTAND HOW
SCRUBBING THE DATA SAID. IN
BEING TRANSPARENT ABOUT THE DATA
ON THE ALGORITHM I SHOULD LEAD
TO A GREATER.
A GREATER RELIABILITY OF THE
OUT YOU KNOW TO GREATER TRUST IN
THE OUTCOME.
AND I'M NOT SURE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET THERE
BECAUSE IT'S HARD ENOUGH TO
ARTICULATE. WITH ALGORITHMICS
SOLUTION.
YOU HAVE JUST PUT YOUR FINGER ON
ONE OF THE MOST SUBSTANTIAL
PROBLEMS IN ALL OF THIS WHICH IS
THAT WE JUST SIMPLY DON'T HAVE
NO.
BROUGHT ENOUGH OF A SKILL BASE
AND A KNOWLEDGE BASE TO REALLY
CRITIQUE MUCH LESS CHANGE MUCH
OF WHAT'S GOING ON. AND I THINK.
YOU KNOW WE SHOULD CERTAINLY
TAKE NOTE WHEN CHINA AS
TEACHING.
PRIMARY AND SECONDARY SCHOOL
STUDENTS
HOW DO YOU SAY I BECAUSE I THINK
WE NEED TO EDUCATE OUR PUBLIC TO
BECOME MUCH SMARTER ON DATA
SCIENCE. AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO
BE A COMPUTER SCIENCE MAJOR TO
UNDERSTAND.
WHAT'S GOING ON A TO MAKE USE
OF IT IF YOU JUST EQUIPPED
TEACHERS AND.
AND TRAINERS AND COACHES TO
TEACH US MORE BROADLY ABOUT HOW
THINGS WORK.
SO YOU'RE ACTUALLY RIGHT THAT
COMPLEXITY IS OVERWHELMING AND
MOST OF US DO NOT HAVE THE RIGHT
TOOLS.
TO SEE THROUGH ALL OF THAT BUT
THAT CAN BE HELPED WITH
EDUCATION MEASURED MEASURES WITH
TRAINING. WITH DATA SCIENCE
COMPONENTS ACROSS THE
EDUCATIONAL SPECTRUM.
IT'S FASCINATING THANK YOU KNOW.
ARE MISGUIDED WHO HAD.
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY OUT WHAT IT IS THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT ACHIEVEMENT OF
A AYE RESEARCHERS TO DATE IS
THAT.
BEING ABOUT THAT.
YOU KNOW I'LL. BE THE WORLD
CHAMPION AND GO.
IS BEING ABLE TO BLOSSOM POKE
HER.
WHAT YOU KNOW IS THERE ANYTHING
THAT YOU'VE SEEN THAT REALLY
HIGHLIGHTS I? YOU KNOW.
THE CAPABILITIES THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN DEVELOPED.
YEAH I MEAN I THINK THERE'S THE
OBVIOUS ONES WHICH IS AUTONOMOUS
CARS RIGHT AND.
I THINK WE WE WILL BE SEEING
OVER THE NEXT TWO TO THREE
YEARS.
AUTONOMOUS CAR IS NAVIGATING.
NOT JUST ON HIGHWAYS BUT
STARTING TO NAVIGATE IN INNER
CITIES WHICH ARE IMMENSELY
COMPLEX ENVIRONMENTS.
WHETHER THAT IS LEVEL FOR LEVEL
FIVE AUTONOMY EXPERTS ARE
FIGHTING OVER AT THIS POINT.
SO BEING ABLE TO PUT YOUR KID
INTO A CAR AND HAVING THE CAR
DRIVE THE CHILD TO THE SCHOOL
WITHOUT A DRIVER IN IT.
IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
PROBABLY GOING TO BE SEEN TO BE
SAFE OVER THE NEXT I DON'T KNOW
FIVE OR SIX YEARS. THAT'S A
MAJOR SHIFT IN OUR IN OUR TRUST
AS WELL IN TECHNOLOGIES.
THERE ARE OTHER APPLICATIONS
OUT THERE THAT ARE.
OBVIOUSLY FASCINATING LIKE
CANCER DIAGNOSTICS.
ON YOU KNOW CERTAIN A AYE BEING
ABLE TO UNDERSTAND TO TAKE IN.
DECADES OF RESEARCH ON BREAST
CANCER ARE AND THEN TAKE A
BREAST CANCER PATIENTS DIAGNOSED
LE OWE IT AT SITUATION IN THEIR
OWN WORDS.
MATCH IT UP.
WITH EXISTING CANCER RESEARCH
AND THEN MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE DOCTOR.
ABOUT AT THE BEST TREATMENT
PACKS.
AND DOING SO IN AN IDEAL
EMOTIONALLY INTELLIGENT WAY WITH
THE PATIENT AS WELL
COMMUNICATING THESE INSIGHTS TO
THE PATIENTS.
WE HAVE STARTED TO WORK ON THESE
THINGS AND THEY'RE STARTING TO
TAKE SHAPE.
THERE ARE OTHER APPLICATIONS OUT
THERE DARPA FOR INSTANCE IS
WORKING ON. HOW TO MANAGE FOOD
CRISES UNDERSTANDING WEATHER
PATTERNS AND SUPPLY CHAIN?
PATTERNS AND.
SOIL CONDITIONS
MARKET CONDITIONS.
TO PREDICT WHERE AROUND THE
WORLD WE MIGHT BE SEEING FOOD
CRISIS AND THEN MITIGATING THOSE
SO THAT WE DON'T SEE LARGE SCALE
FAMINE.
ARE THOSE ARE ALSO.
AMAZING AND THEN THERE IS A AYE
AND CLIMATE CHANGE FOR INSTANCE
HELPING THE UN IPCC SEE.
UNDERSTAND WHICH OF ITS CLIMATE
CHANGE MODELS ARE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE CLIMATE CHANGE IS A
WICKED PROBLEMS. WE DON'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND HOW HOW HOW EXACTLY
THINGS WORK AND TIPS. A I CAN
HELP US WITH THOSE WITH THOSE
THINGS
THERE'S MANY MANY MORE.
THAT I COULD DESCRIBE SUCH AS
YOU KNOW ENABLING. LARGE A LE
ILLITERATE POPULATIONS IN AFRICA
AND INDIA
TO ALL OF A SUDDEN PARTAKE IN
COMMERCIAL ECONOMIC PROCESS
SEES.
THEY'RE BY DEVELOPING A
POLITICAL VOICE RIGHT THE
UNFORTUNATE REALITY IS THAT IN
TODAY'S WORLD ALL OVER THE
PLANET.
YOU HAVE A VOICE WHEN YOU HAVE
MONEY OR WHEN YOU ARTICULATE.
COMMERCIAL BUYING POWER.
SO BRINGING THOSE ILLITERATE
MASSES INTO THE COMMERCIAL
ECONOMIC PROCESS IS VERY
POWERFUL AND THAT'S HAPPENING.
ARE ALREADY IN IN PLACES LIKE
INDIA AND AFRICA CAN.
THANK YOU AND THAT YOU HAD A A
QUOTE SOMETHING TO THE EFFECT
THAT I TECHNOLOGY MOVES QUITE
RAPIDLY BUT PUBLIC POLICY. AYE
INCREMENTALLY AND I YOU KNOW
WERE AND WITH WITH A AYE IN
PARTICULAR I'M YOU KNOW WE COULD
BE LOOKING AT.
TRANSFORMATIONS THAT CUT ACROSS
EVERY.
POLICY AREA.
IN AND IT'S PRETTY OPEN ENDED
IN THE SENSE THAT WE MAY NOT
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THAT'S GOING
TO LOOK LIKE.
IN IT COULD MOVE ON VERY AS YOU
SAY VERY FAST TIME SCALES SO
WHEN WE'RE SORT OF DEALING WITH
THE THE THINGS THAT WE TYPICALLY
TALK ABOUT AROUND HERE HOW DO
YOU THINK THAT OUGHT AT. AYE
IMPACT THAT YOU KNOW THE
DISPOSITION WE BRING TO BEAR AS
POLICY MAKERS WHEN WE HAVE KIND
OF THIS.
UNKNOWN APPROACHING YES. THAT'S
A GREAT QUESTION AND I SUPPOSE
THAT CITY GETS ME INTO THE REALM
OF OF OF SUGGESTIONS FOR POLICY
OR APPROACHES FOR LEGISLATORS.
LIKE YOURSELVES.
I BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE WE NEED
TO DO TWO THINGS THE FIRST ONE
IS WE NEED TO STUDY THIS NOW SO
IT WOULD HELP.
TO HAVE SACRAMENTO.
FACILITATE OR BE PART OF.
WHEN MICHAELA THINK TANK
BETWEEN CORPORATIONS
ENTREPRENEURS UNIVERSITIES.
AND THE GOVERNMENT TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE ALL THIS IS
GOING WHERE WHERE DO WE THINK
THE NEXT BREAKTHROUGH IS GOING
TO COME ONE OF THE MOST
PROMISING AREAS AND HOW SHOULD
WE FACILITATE THOSE
BREAKTHROUGHS WE DON'T WANT TO
HALT ECONOMIC GROWTH.
I'M A BUSINESS PERSON I WANT TO
SEE ECONOMIC GROWTH.
BUT UNDERSTANDING WHERE IT MIGHT
HAPPEN NEXT IS SOMETHING WE CAN
DO IF WE PUT OUR HEADS TOGETHER
SETS NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO IS. I
THINK IT WOULD HELP TO HAVE AN
EXERCISE.
OF CHARTING THE KIND OF FUTURE
WE WANT FOR CALIFORNIA.
RIGHTS IF IF WE DON'T WANT TO
BE OVERWHELMED OR.
TAKEN BY SURPRISE WHY NOT
CREATE A VISION FOR CALIFORNIA
TWENTY THIRTY WHAT DO WE WANT
OUR ECONOMY OUR SOCIETY LOOK
LIKE. AND THEN BACK INTO IT IS
WHAT WE CALL BACK CASTING WHAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN BETWEEN NOW AND
THEN. FOR THIS TO BE SHAPE
POSITIVELY AND WE DO HAVE THE
POWER TO DO THAT WE DON'T HAVE
TO JUST ROLL OVER.
AND THAT.
A I WALK ALL OVER US WE CAN
HARNESS THERE'S LOTS OF
POTENTIAL IN THIS THAT WILL BE
THE SECOND RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I KNOW THAT
WE WILL HAVE ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY
TO ASK QUESTIONS OF THE
PROFESSOR AND A LITTLE. LATER
TIME ON SO I WANNA THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US.
IF YOU CAN JUST STAY AROUND A
BIT LONGER TO WILL BRING UP
AGAIN THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OUT THAT BRINGS US TO THE
NEXT PANEL.
.
THE NEXT PANEL WILL.
SPEAK ON THE TOPIC OF AUTOMATION
APPLICATIONS AND WORKFORCE
IMPLICATIONS JOINING US.
OUR IS A LANEY MENDONCA WHO IS
THE CO CHAIR OF CALIFORNIA
FORWARD ALSO A SENIOR PARTNER
EMERITUS AT MCKINSEY AND
CHAIRMAN OF NEW AMERICA.
ALSO JOINING US IS ROBERT
ATKINSON PRESIDENT OF THE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY AND
INNOVATION FOUNDATION. WHO WILL
BE JOINING US FROM SKYPE?
AND FINALLY MISTER DOUG BLOCKED
CHO WHO IS THE POLITICAL
DIRECTOR AT THE TEAMSTERS JOINT
COUNCIL SEVEN. SO WITH THAT DOWN
AND WE GONNA GET.
.
HOPEFULLY GET THEIR MACHINE TO
WORK
.
MKTO.
S. RECONCILE.
ANY HARRIS.
YES BUT IN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
A PLEASURE THANK YOU
VERY WELL THEN I THOUGHT WHY
DON'T WE START WITH DOWN ON MR
INMAN DANKA.
WHO IS THEIR CULTURE OF
CALIFORNIA FORWARD?
ALSO SENIOR PARTNER EMERITUS AND
MACKENZIE.
GREAT THANK YOU CHAIRMAN ADAMS
WELCOME WELCOME HELLO THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN SHALL ON MEMBERS.
I'M IT'S MY PLEASURE TO BE HERE.
AS I YOU SAID I. COULDN'T.
I AM A FORMER SENIOR PARTNER
MACKENZIE BUT I'M NO LONGER
ASSOCIATED WITH THE FARMER AND
THE WORK THAT I'M WILL DESCRIBE
BRIEFLY WAS NOT DONE ON MY WATCH
ALTHOUGH I THINK IT'S GREAT
WORKS OF THE OPINIONS ARE JUST
MY OWN NOT THEIRS.
I'M WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS
BRIEFLY SUMMARIZE SOME OF THE
RESEARCH ON. MOST RECENT
RESEARCH ON ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND ITS
IMPLICATIONS FOR THE LABOR
FORCE.
AND THEN LEAVE YOU WITH THREE
THOUGHTS ON THINGS THAT I WOULD
PAY ATTENTION TO.
SO LET ME START WITH THE SUMMARY
OF THE RESEARCH.
MY TOP LINE ON IT IS STOP
CALLING THIS THE ROBOT
APOCALYPSE.
IT'S NOT HELPFUL.
SCARES PEOPLE AND IT ISN'T A
BALANCED VIEW ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING OR WHAT THE
IMPLICATIONS ARE WE REALLY NEED
TO STEP BACK AND TAKE A
THOUGHTFUL BICU ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING AROUND. ON RATHER THAN
RESORT TO HOLLYWOOD ERA VIEWS
ABOUT THE FUTURE OF THE WORLD.
THE TCHNOLOGY IS A PROFESSOR
GOT ROTH WERE DESCRIBING
ACTUALLY PROMISE AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF HIGHER PRODUCTIVITY
GREATER EFFICIENCY MORE SAFETY
FLEXIBILITY AND CONVENIENCE.
THEY DO APPROPRIATELY AS A
RESEARCH SHOWS STROKE FEARS
ABOUT THE EFFECTS ON JOB SKILLS
AND WAGES.
MANY HAVE LOOKED AT THESE MOST
RECENTLY REALLY GOOD WORK AT
OXFORD. AND OF STUDY THAT I
MENTIONED FROM THE MCKINSEY
GLOBAL INSTITUTE. FIND THAT
LARGE SHARES OF EMPLOYMENT IN
BOTH DEVELOPING AND DEVELOPED
WORLD.
TECHNICALLY BE AUTOMATED.
HOWEVER IS HISTORY HAS SHOWN.
THE ANXIETIES ABOUT WHAT MAYNARD
KEYNES CALLED JOHN MAYNARD
KEYNES CALLED A CENTURY AGO
TECHNOLOGICAL UNEMPLOYMENT. A
TERM THAT I PREFER TO THE ROBOT
APOCALYPSE
WERE ACTUALLY QUITE OVERBLOWN A
MORE APPROPRITE QUESTION HAS TO
DO. WITH REEMPLOYMENT HOW ARE WE
GOING TO FIND WAYS THAT THE JOBS
THAT ARE CREATED BY THESE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES.
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE HERE HAVE
THE SKILLS AND OPPORTUNITIES TO
PURSUE THOSE JOBS.
IN THE FUTURE MOST LIKELY AS IN
THE PAST THE RESEARCH HAS SHOWN
THAT TECHNOLOGY IS LIKELY TO
FUEL PRODUCTIVITY GAINS.
INCOME GROWTH AND BOOST DEMANDS
FOR LABOR. ADD TO THAT LOWER
PRICES AND RISING QUALITY
DEMANDS AND GOODS FOR SERVICES
AND SERVICES ARE LIKELY TO RISE.
MANY OF JOBS THAT WILL BE
CREATED.
COULD NOT EVEN HAVE BEEN
IMAGINED IN THE PAST
A CENTURY AGO WHO WOULD HAVE
THOUGHT THAT AUTOMOBILES WOULD
LEAD TO A DRIVE THROUGH
RESTAURANTS A ROADSIDE MORE
TELLS. WILL MORE RECENTLY THAT
THE INFORMATION AGE WOULD LEAD
TO STADIUMS FULL OF PEOPLE
WATCHING VIDEO GAMERS COMPETE
AGAINST EACH OTHER.
THE WORK FROM THE MCKINSEY
GLOBAL INSTITUTE DID A VARIETY
OF SCENARIOS AROUND WHAT HAPPENS
TO JOBS UNDER THE. APPLICATION
OF EXISTING TECHNOLOGY DEPENDING
ON THE SPEED AND PACE WITH WHICH
IT PROCEEDS.
THEIR MID POINT ESTIMATE WAS
THAT ABOUT FIFTEEN PERCENT OF
THE GLOBAL WORK FORCE.
WILL BE DISPLACED OR COULD BE
DISPLACED OVER THE NEXT DECADE
FROM FROM THE SETS OF
TECHNOLOGIES.
A FASTER PACE COULD CRACK
TRIGGER GREATER DISPLACEMENT AND
OBVIOUSLY A SLOWER PACE WOULD DO
SLOWER DISPLACEMENT.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT AS A
RESULT OF INCREASES AND DEMANDS
AND SERVICES AS I DESCRIBED FOR
GOODS AND SERVICES.
THERE WILL BE JOB GROWTH IN
AREAS SUCH AS INFRASTRUCTURE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND RENEWABLE
AND NEW JOBS ARE AS LIKELY TO
OUTPACE THE JOB LOSS.
THE NEW JOBS WILL DIFFER
MIGHTILY HOWEVER FROM THE JOBS
THAT ARE LOST.
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT ARE OUT
PACED AND DISPLACED BY
AUTOMATION THAT IS GONNA REQUIRE
SUFFICIENT.
TRANSITIONS AND COSTS ON WORKERS
BUSINESSES AND COMMUNITIES.
IN THE UNITED STATES DEPENDING
ON THE PACE OF THAT AUTOMATION
THEIR ESTIMATE WAS. THAT UP
BETWEEN TEN AND. THIRTY PERCENT
OF THE WORK FORCE THE UNITED
STATES WILL HAVE TO EITHER
CHANGE OCCUPATIONAL CATEGORY
SPORTS SKILLS ASSOCIATED WITH
THEM.
THE MOST LIKELY SCENARIO IS THAT
THIS WILL NOT RESULT IN MASSIVE
JOB LOSSES BUT IT WILL CHANGE
THE JOBS OF JUST ABOUT EVERYONE.
SO THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS
NOT TO THINK ABOUT ARE WE GONNA
HAVE ROBOTS IT OUR JOBS. BUT HOW
DO WE FIND THE SETS OF SKILLS
AND CAPABILITIES THAT ALLOW
PEOPLE TO WORK ALONGSIDE ROBOTS
TO ENSURE. THAT THEY HAVE HIGH
QUALITY OPPORTUNITIES.
THE THREE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS
THAT I WOULD THINK ABOUT AS
YOU'RE EXPLORING THIS ISSUE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
OUR NUMBER ONE.
DO NO HARM.
MAKE SURE NO ONE ELSE DOES ANY
HARM.
AND WE ARE IN FACT AS PROFESSOR
ACROSS SAID IN AN INTELLECTUAL
AND DATA ARMS RACE NOT JUST WITH
OTHER STATES BUT WITH OTHER
COUNTRIES.
AND THERE IS NOTHING TO SAY THAT
CALIFORNIA OR THE UNITED STATES
HAS AN INEVITABLE RIGHT TO WIN
THIS ARMS RACE.
WE DO NEED TO ENSURE THAT THE
TECHNOLOGIES AND CAPABILITIES
THAT ARE BEING INVENTED HERE.
ARE APPLIED AND USED TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES AND PRODUCTIVITY
AND GROWTH.
BUT THAT THOSE WHO ARE DEPLOYING
THOSE TECHNOLOGIES PLAYS BY PLAY
BY RULES OF THE GAME. THAT MAKE
SURE THAT THIS WORKS FOR
EVERYONE.
AS PROFESSOR ACROSS SAID
IMPORTANTLY ON THAT LIST ARE
ISSUES AROUND ETHICS AND PRIVACY
TO ENSURE THAT THE TRANSPARENCY
THAT'S NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT
THESE TECHNOLOGIES ARE DEPLOYED
FOR THE PUBLIC GOOD. NOT JUST
THE PRIVATE GOOD.
AREN'T AREN'T IMPORTANT PART OF
EQUATION.
THE SECOND AND PERHAPS MORE
IMPORTANT IMPLICATION. OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES.
ARE THE IMPACT THAT THEY WILL
HAVE ON IN EQUALITY AND ECONOMIC
MOBILITY.
THE TECHNOLOGIES WILL BE
DEPLOYED IN ALL LIKELIHOOD AND
WILL BENEFIT THOSE WHO CAN
BENEFIT FROM THEM. WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE GAINS GO
PROBABLY NOT JUST NARROWLY TO
THOSE WHO HAVE CREATED THE
TECHNOLOGY OR HAVE THE SETS OF
SKILLS TO IT TO BENEFIT FROM
THEM.
CALIFORNIA'S LIKELY TO SEE THESE
IMPACTS EARLY. NOT JUST BECAUSE
OF THE DEPLOYMENT OF THE
TECHNOLOGIES BUT BECAUSE THE
NATURE OF OUR WORK FORCE AND OUR
POPULATION TO BEGIN WITH.
ACCORDINGLY CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
LEAD ON THINKING ABOUT THE
IMPLICATIONS
FOR EQUALITY AND MOBILITY AND
ENSURING THAT WERE TRACKING
THAT.
WE NEED TO HAVE GOALS FOR
ECONOMIC MOBILITY. THAT ARE AT
THE SAME.
LEVEL OF IMPORTANCE AS WE HAVE
GOALS FOR. CLIMATE. GOALS AND
THAT WE WERE THINKING ABOUT NOT
JUST THE DEPLOYMENT OF
TECHNOLOGIES BUT ITS IMPACT ON
PEOPLE AND THEIR OPPORTUNITIES
WE CAN'T JUST WAKE UP TWENTY
YEARS FROM NOW FIND THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVEN'T PAID
ATTENTION.
AND THE THIRD AND PERHAPS MOST
IMPORTANT ELEMENT THAT THIS
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN. IS THAT THE
BIGGEST QUESTION HAS TO DO WITH
HOW WE MANAGE THROUGH THIS
TRANSITION.
AND HOW WE DO IT AT THE PACE AND
SCALE THAT'S NECESSARY.
TO KEEP PACE WITH THE
TECHNOLOGICAL CHANGE.
THERE ARE TWO IMPORTANT ELEMENTS
OF THAT FROM MY VIEW THAT NEED
TO BE ON THE AGENDA AND ARE
IMPORTANT TO BE. THOUGHT OF NOT
JUST AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL BUT AT
THE STATE LEVEL.
THE FIRST ONE OF THOSE IS
RETHINKING OUR SOCIAL SAFETY
NET.
THERE WILL BE LARGE
DISPLACEMENTS FROM A NUMBER OF
THESE TECHNOLOGIES.
WHICH WILL REQUIRE THAT THERE
WILL BE PEOPLE FOR SUBSTANTIAL
PERIODS OF TIME WHO ARE GOING TO
NEED OME HELP WORKING THROUGH
THAT TRANSITION.
SO THINKING ABOUT WHAT OUR
UNEMPLOYMENT PROGRAMS LOOK LIKE
THINKING ABOUT WHAT OUR OUR
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS TO ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE HAVE. THE ABILITY TO
MANAGE THROUGH THOSE ARE ALL
REAL. AND CONNECTED TO FINDING
OPPORTUNITIES AGAIN. I DO THINK
THINGS LIKE PORTABLE BENEFITS
JUST AND FINDING OPPORTUNITIES
TO ENSURE THAT THERE ARE A.
CASH AND OTHER SUPPORT FOR THOSE
TIME PERIODS ARE CAN BE
IMPORTANT.
PERSONALLY I'M NOT A BIG FAN OF
YOU BI I AS A SILVER BULLET TO
THE SOLUTIONS BUT THE QUESTION
AROUND CASH TRANSFERS NEEDS TO
BE PART EQUATION. AS WELL.
SECONDLY WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT.
PASTE AND CHANGE OF OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM TO MEET THE
PACE OF CHANGE OF WHAT'S GOING
ON IN TECHNOLOGY.
IT'S NO LONGER GOING TO BE
APPROPRIATE TO THINK ABOUT YOU
LEARN FROM ZERO TO TWENTY TWO.
AND YOU AREN'T AFTER THAT WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO THINK ABOUT LIFE
LONG LEARNING. WHERE YOU HAVE
PERIODS OF TIME WHEN YOU WILL BE
IN SCHOOL PERIODS OF TIME YOU
WILL BE WORKING AND MOST LIKELY
MANY PARENTS THROUGHOUT YOUR
LIFE WHEN YOU WILL BE DOING
BOTH?
SO WE NEED THE SAME THINKING AND
AGGRESSIVENESS THAT CALIFORNIA
LED TO THE MASTER PLAN FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION TO THINK ABOUT.
HOW WE MANAGE THROUGH A
TRANSITION OVER THE COURSE OF
THE NEXT TWO DECADES?
TWO A NECESSITY FOR LIFELONG
LEARNING. THAT WILL INCLUDE
INVESTING AND INNOVATIONS THAT
ALLOWED PEOPLE TO CONTINUE TO
EARN WHILE THEY LEARN NOT STEP
OUT OF THE WORK FORCE FULLY TO.
BE ABLE TO.
REGAIN THOSE SKILLS SO THINGS
LIKE ONLINE LEARNING BLENDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES TO.
CONTINUE TO BE EMPLOYED IN AND
SAT EMPLOYERS TO INVEST IN
LEARNING WILL BE AN IMPORTANT
PART EQUATION AS WELL.
SO IN SUMMARY I'M NOT SCARED OF
THE ROBOT APOCALYPSE.
MOST AVAILABLE EVIDENCE SUGGESTS
THAT THIS IS TEN TO FIFTEEN
YEARS OF TRANSITION OF ONE OR
TWO PERCENT OF THE WORKFORCE
TRANSITIONING EVERY YEAR.
THAT IS A BIG NUMBER TO HAPPEN
EVERY YEAR BUT IT IS NOT LIKE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE NO JOBS IN A
DECADE. THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
IS THAT WE ENSURE THAT WE GET
THE GAINS FROM THESE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT WE AND MAKE
SURE THAT IT DOESN'T JUST
AFFECT.
AT ECONOMIC MOBILITY AND THAT WE
HELP ALL CALIFORNIANS ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIAN UNITED STATES
MANAGED TO THE TRANSITIONS AS WE
LOOK AS WE UP MOVE TO THIS NEXT
ECONOMY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUT. MR AT.
MISRAQ.
YES.
THANK YOU AYE SHALL REMEMBER.
HERE WE LOOK AT.
YES.
OKAY. GO AHEAD.
FIRST OF ALL LET ME. START
BROUGH BY THING I AGREE WITH
VIRTUALLY EVERYTHING THAT LIKE
CALLING MY NAME IS ALSO SAID.
LET ME START WITH SEVERAL QUOTES
THAT I THINK FRAME THIS ISSUE
QUITE WELL.
FIRST IS QUOTE AUTUMN IS
AUTOMATIC MACHINERY DRIVEN BY
LIMITLESS POWER GOING TO LEAVE
HONOR HERE'S A STATE OF CHRONIC
AND INCREASING. UNEMPLOYMENT.
SECONDLY WE MUST CONVINCE OUR
ON THEM FULL EMPLOYMENT THE PACE
OF TECHNOLOGICAL CHANGE
XCELERATED.
THE THIRD IS THE EFFECT OF
AUTOMATION ON UNEMPLOYMENT AS
BEEN WIDELY IT RESPONSIBLY
EXAGGERATED. PRINCIPALLY BY
SOCIAL SCIENTISTS WHO SEEM
ENGAGE IN A COMPETITION OF ALL
OF THIS.
ARE ALL THREE OF THOSE VOTES.
ONE OF QUIRK WONDER GO ON THE
FIRST WAS BY THE U. S. SECRETARY
OF LABOR IN NINETEEN TWENTY
SEVEN.
THE SECOND WAS FROM A LEADING A
AYE SCIENTISTS AND STILL TODAY.
SAYS THE SAME THINGS THAT HE
SAID THAT IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR.
AND THE THIRD WAS FROM A VERY
GOOD BOOK CALLED THE AUTOMATION
HANNEKE.
FROM NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE.
MY POINT OF.
GIVING THOSE CLOSES POINT OUT
THAT THIS IS NOTHING NEW.
HISTORICALLY WHEN THEY'VE BEEN
PERIODS OF NEW WAVES OF
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION AND
YOUR LAST ECONOMY.
THEY'D BEEN ACCOMPANIED
OFTENTIMES BY WHAT YOU CALL
TECHNO PANIC.
PARTICULARLY AROUND LABOR MARKET
IMPLICATIONS.
WE SEE THE SAME THING GOING ON
AGAIN TODAY.
THERE ARE. PUNDITS AND AUTHORED
LIKE MARTIN FORD THAT.
AUTHORIZES THE ROBOTS WHO SAYS
THAT. BY TWENTY IT IS SUCH A BY
THE END OF THE CENTURY ADOBE
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT
UNEMPLOYMENT ONLY TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT OF PEOPLE WORKING.
ANOTHER A JOURNALIST KEVIN DRUM
RATES IN MOTHER JONES THAT IN
FORTY YEARS THERE SIMPLY WILL BE
NO JOB LAST.
IT IS THIS FEAR FRANKLY AS AS AS
MONEY SAID THE THERE ARE YOUR
APOCALYPTIC FEARS THAT ARE JUST
HAVE NO BASIS IN GROUNDED IN
EITHER HISTORICAL. EVIDENCE OR
ECONOMIC REALITY.
WE CAN REST ASSURED THAT IN
TWENTY OR TWENTY FIVE YEARS WE
WILL HAVE PLENTY OF JOBS.
WHAT WHAT I DO THINK WE HAVE A
CHALLENGE ON IS THE ADJUSTMENT
ISSUE POWER WORKERS GOING TO
COPE WITH HAVING TO BE HAVING TO
MOVE TO NEW KINDS OF JOBS?
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY DOUBT
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE AN
INCREASE IN LABOR MARKET
DISLOCATION RIGHT.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT THE LAST FOR
THE LAST FEW YEARS I'VE BEEN
QUITE GOOD.
.
WE RECENTLY RELEASED A STUDY
WHERE WE LOOKED AT.
LABOR MARKET DESTRUCTION.
HER EVERY DECADE IN THE US
ECONOMY FROM EIGHTEEN FIFTY TO
THE TO TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN.
AND WHAT WE FOUND WAS THAT IN
PRIOR DECADE LIKE IN THE AGE IN
THE NINETEEN FIFTIES EARLY
EIGHTEEN NINETIES.
pOCCUPATIONAL CHURNING OF.
JOBS JUST BEING DESTROYED BY
NEW TECHNOLOGY.
.
FARMING FOR EXAMPLE WAS A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF THAT THE OTHER ONES
PEOPLE FORGET IN THE NINETEEN
FIFTIES THE SIXTIES THERE WERE A
LOT OF. JOBS THAT PEOPLE THAT IN
OFFICE IS CALLED FILE CLERK.
PETER CAME ALONG THEY WERE NO
MORE JOBS. AS FILE CLERK.
SO THEN WHAT WE'VE BEEN
EXPERIENCING IS NOT ANYTHING
NEAR WHAT WE HAVE HAD IN THE
PAST IN THE PAST WE'VE DEALT
WITH IT REASONABLY WELL.
I THINK WHAT THAT MEANS TODAY
THOUGH.
IS.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO COPE WITHIN
AND INEVITABLE INCREASE IN THE
RATE OF OCCUPATIONAL LABOR
MARKET DESTRUCTION?
IT'S LIKELY IN FIVE TO TEN YEARS
IT BE TECHNOLOGIES GET A LITTLE
BIT BETTER GET MORE WIDELY
DIFFUSED IN THE MARKETPLACE.
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO SEE MORE
JOBS LOST BECAUSE OF
PRODUCTIVITY.
AND CERTAIN OCCUPATIONS.
IMPACTED MORE THAN OTHERS.
THERE'S A STUDY THAT WE'VE WE'VE
DONE.
FOR PAPER WE PRESENTED FOR THE
G. SEVEN CONFERENCE IS COMING UP
IN MONTREAL WHERE.
WE LOOKED AT THE OXFORD
UNIVERSITY ESTIMATES WHICH WE
THINK ARE WAY TOO HIGH BUT THEY
DID RIGHT OCCUPATIONS IN THE
LAST BY RISK AND WE ALSO. LIKE
YEAH I F. WE DID OUR OWN STUDY
WHERE WE RANK OCCUPATIONS AT
RISK.
I BY THE WAY I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT THE STUDY THAT WE DID OF
THE STUDY THAT THE OECD DID IN
PARIS. AND THE MCKINSEY STUDY
THAT LINE HE REFERRED YOU ALL
CAME UP WITH PRETTY MUCH THE
EXACT SAME NUMBER. ABOUT FIFTEEN
PERCENT OF JOBS. THAT RISK BEING
LOST FROM TECHNOLOGY OVER THE
NEXT FIFTEEN YEARS OR SO.
BUT WHAT WE DID WITH THIS WITH
OUR STUDY IN LOOKING AT THE
MACKENZIE HE SAID IF WE LOOK AT.
WHAT'S THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
DEMOGRAPHIC FACTORS AND THE REST
OF LOSING YOUR JOB IN THE FUTURE
FROM TECHNOLOGY AND WHAT WE
FOUND AGAIN AND EAGER. TO BE
BIGGER CORRELATIONS.
UP THERE IS NO CORRELATION
ESSENTIALLY BETWEEN GENDER.
SO MEN AND WOMEN HAVE ABOUT THE
SAME DRESS.
THERE IS A NEGATIVE CORRELATION
WITH AGE WHICH IS A GOOD THING
ARE OLDER WORKERS WERE HANDED BE
AN OCCUPATION THAT WERE LESS AT
RISK OF AUTOMATION THAN YOUNGER
WORKERS.
OLDER WORKERS HAVE A HARDER TIME
MAKING TRANSITIONS SO THAT'S
THAT'S A GOOD THING.
.
WELL THERE IS NO REAL OF. IT A
LITTLE BIT OF THERE WAS A LITTLE
BIT OF CORRELATION WITH RACE.
SO I HISPANIC AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN HANDED TO BE AN
OCCUPATION THAT WERE HAD A
HIGHER RISK OF AUTOMATION.
UP BUT WHEN YOU CONTROL FOR WAGE
AND IN AND EDUCATION LEVELS
RATES.
WENT AWAY THE BIGGEST FACTOR
THAT WE FOUND IS THAT.
THE RESCUED REALLY MUCH MORE
ORIENTED TO LOW WAGE. LOWER
SKILLED OCCUPATIONS.
THAT'S NOT TO SAY THAT THERE
WON'T BE IMPACTS IT ACROSS THE
INCOME.
AND OCCUPATIONAL SPECTRUM.
BUT IT APPEARS THAT THE BIGGEST
IMPACTS ARE GOING TO BE AT LOW
WAGE WORKERS ARE LOWER PATIENTS
ARE ON THE ONE SIDE
THAT.
IS GOOD.
IN THE SENSE THAT IT WILL SHIFT
THE ECONOMY MORE TOWARD MIDDLE
WAGE JOBS.
IT'S HARD TO PAY PEOPLE WELL IN
LOW WAGE JOBS BECAUSE
PRODUCTIVITY THOUGHT HIGHER.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME PEOPLE IN
LOW WAGE JOBS AND WITH LOWER
SKILL LEVELS HAVE A HARDER TIME
MAKING TRANSITIONS.
SO LET ME SUGGEST WHAT THAT
IMPLIES I THINK FOR.
WHAT CALIFORNIA CAN DO AND
FRANKLY WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE DOING? TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR WORKERS TO
MAKE THESE TRANSITIONS.
WE REALLY STILL REPORTED I YEAH
I HAVE TWO WEEKS AGO THAT LAID
OUT A COMPREHENSIVE AGENDA.
AND IT WAS ORIENTED AROUND TWO
OR THREE DAY THINK ONE THE FIRST
ONE WAS REALLY ENSURE THAT
WORKERS HAVE BETTER SKILLS.
BEFORE THEY LOSE THEIR JOBS.
ONCE A WORKER LOSES THEIR JOB IT
IS HARDER TO DO THINGS THAT THEY
HAVE STRONGER CAPABILITIES
COMPETENCIES AND SKILLS.
IF YOU'VE HEARD ON THE GO AND
MAKE A SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION.
ONE OF THE KEY THINGS WITHOUT WE
BELIEVE IT'S GIVING WORKERS.
GIVING STUDENTS I SHOULD SAY
AND EVEN ADULT WORKERS STRONGER
DIGITAL SKILLS.
IT'S STRIKING TO US SO THAT I
DON'T I JUST USES BECAUSE THE
DATE IS THERE BUT I ALL STATES
ARE SIMILAR TO THIS BUT IT'S
STRIKING THAT IN CALIFORNIA FOR
EXAMPLE.
MORE A LARGER SHARE OF HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS TAKE POTTERY.
IN HIGH SCHOOL.
THEN TAKE COMPUTER SCIENCE.
ISSUES THEN I THINK A PROBLEM.
I THINK WE NEED MORE OF OUR
CHILDREN MORE OF OUR STUDENTS
TAKING COMPUTER SCIENCE.
EIGHTY SEVEN PERCENT OF AMERICAN
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS TAKE
GEOMETRY BUT ONLY EIGHT PERCENT
TAKE STATISTICS.
AGAIN I WOULD ARGUE THESE
STATISTICS IS REALLY ONE OF
THOSE CORE SKILLS OR KNOWLEDGE
SAYS THAT WORKERS NEED TO KNOW
WHETHER THEY'RE OPERATING A
MACHINE AND INDUSTRY FOUR POINT
OH SMART MANUFACTURING
ENVIRONMENT. OR WHETHER THEY'RE
IN A HOSPITAL WORKING ON ON THAT
TESTING MACHINES.
THIS IS THE COURSE HILL YET WE
DON'T TEACH IT IN HIGH SCHOOL.
SO I THINK REACHED AS MONEY
AGAIN LINDA RETHINKING.
NOT JUST YOU CAN CALL BUT HIGHER
EDUCATION HOW WELL WE'RE DOING
IN. IMPARTING OR SKILLS.
A SECOND IS TO DO A BETTER JOB
OF SECOND BIGGER DOING A BETTER
JOB OF HELPING WORKERS WHEN THEY
DO LOSE THEIR JOBS FROM
TECHNOLOGY.
OUT WELL EVERY STATE IN THE
NATION HAVE THE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW WORKERS TO GET
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE TO ALSO
BE INVOLVED IN TRAINING. AFTER
THEY LOSE THEIR JOB.
MOST STATES AND I BELIEVE
CALIFORNIA IS IN THIS CAMP.
DON'T ACTIVELY WORKED TO ALLOW
AND ENCOURAGE WORKERS WHO ARE
LAID OFF.
GET TRAINING.
THE INCENTIVE FOR MOST STATES
IS IT IS YEAH WORKERS BACK IN
THE WORKFORCE AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE TO KEEP YOU WHY COSTS
DOWN.
THEIR MENTION GOOD STUDIES AT A
SHOW THAT THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE COMMISSION OTHER
STATES ARE JUST SIMPLY SEND THE
LETTER TO WORKERS WHEN THEY
COLLECT WHEN THEY APPLY FOR YOU
WHY. TO JUST LET THEM KNOW THAT
THEY ARE ELIGIBLE FOR TRAINING.
BOTHER COLLECTING UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE.
THAT'S TRAINING INVOLVEMENT GOES
UP BY FORTY PERCENT.
SO I THINK THAT AN EASY SIX THIS
THE BEST TIME FOR WORKERS TO BE
INVOLVED IN TRAINING BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE A JOB AND THEY
HAVE TIME AND THEY HAVE SOME
INCOME SUPPORT.
ARE.
THE ONE THING I WOULD SUGGEST
IN.
WE REALLY DO NEED TO DO A MUCH
BETTER JOB OF PROVIDING ONLINE
TOOLS.
FOR WORKERS
TO HELP THEM WITH THINGS LIKE
SKILL ASSESSMENTS.
FINDING TRAINING RESOURCES DOING
JOB SEARCHES.
I EVERY STATE HAS ESSENTIALLY OF
WHAT'S CALLED AN ONLINE ONE
STOP.
PORTAL.
.
I HAVEN'T LOOKED AT CALIFORNIA'S
BUT I'VE LOOKED AT A NUMBER OF
STATES AND THEIR FRANKLY NOT
VERY GOOD.
THEY DON'T PROVIDE AN EASY TO
USE INTERFACES REALLY HARD FOR
PEOPLE TO USE THAT.
AND I ENCOURAGE YOU TO THINK TO
LOOK AT OF OR TO HAVE YOUR
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR LOOK AT WHAT
SOME OF THE MORE IT MORE
INTERESTING PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP MODEL DOING NOW AND
IN PARTICULAR.
A PROGRAM THAT.
THE MARKLE FOUNDATION.
REPORTING IN COLORADO WITH THE
MICROSOFT.
FOUNDATION AND LINK IN.
WHERE THEY CREATED OF SYSTEM
COMPLETELY STATE OF THE ART
ONLINE PORTAL?
WORKERS CAN GO ON THEIR THEY CAN
DO ON ONLINE SKILLS ASSESSMENT.
TELL THEM WHERE THEY'RE WE WHERE
THEY'RE STRONG WHERE THEY NEED
TO GET SOME ADDITIONAL HEALTH.
THEY CAN SAY WHAT OCCUPATION
THAT THAT END AND THEY CANNOT
FIND AYE SIMILAR OCCUPATIONS
WHERE THE SKILL AT EDITIONS
AREN'T ALL THAT GREAT. THEY CAN
FIND VERY EASILY ONLINE TRAIN A
SIGNIFICANT FIND ONLINE TRAINING
RESOURCES TO GET INVOLVED IN.
TO ME EVERY STATE SHOULD HAVE
THE ROBUST ONLINE EASY TO USE
SYSTEM FOR WORKERS AND I THINK
IT'S.
SOMETHING WE CAN DO STATES IS
LIKE TO DO THAT BUT FRANKLY WE
JUST HAVEN'T DONE IT YET.
OTHERS CLOSE BY SAYING ARE
AGREEING WITH LENNY I THINK WE
SHOULD ALL THE STATE OF. DEEP
BREATHS AND CALM DOWN THE THESE
TECHNOLOGY TRANSITIONS TAKE
LONGER THAN WE THINK.
IT'S GONNA HAPPEN I THINK WE
WILL COPE WITH THAT WE WON'T
HAVE HIGHER UNEMPLOYMENT. WE
WILL HAVE I WOULD ARGUE HIGHER
PRODUCTIVITY AND WAGE GROWTH.
BUT WE DO NEED A MUCH BETTER
SYSTEM FOR HELPING WORKERS MAKE
THAT LEADS TRANSITIONS THAT ARE
COMING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND MISTER
ATKINSON.
.
NEXT LET'S THERE GO TO MR DOUG
BLOCK UP POLITICAL DIRECTOR WITH
TEAMSTERS JOINT COUNCIL SEVEN
WELCOME. THANK YOU THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN TELL AND MEMBERS.
.
S. BEEN STATE MY NAME IS DOUG
BLOCKED I'M THE POLITICAL
DIRECTOR WITH TEAMSTERS JOINT
COUNCIL SEVEN WHICH COVERS A
HUNDRED THOUSAND TEAMSTERS FROM
BAKERSFIELD UP TO THE OREGON
BORDER.
AND FOR PURPOSES OF THIS
DISCUSSION I WANNA FOCUS ON OUR
MEMBERS WHO ARE DRIVING TRUCKS.
BUSES AND TRAINS.
AND FIRST LET ME SAY HOW HAPPY I
AM TO BE HERE TODAY BECAUSE I'M
SPENDING ABOUT HALF OF MY TIME
ON THESE ISSUES.
THAT'S HOW CRITICAL THEY ARE OF
IMPORTANCE TO THE TEAMSTERS
ACTUALLY JUST CAME FROM.
BARGAINING WITH UNITED PARCEL
SERVICE AT.
THE HILTON OFF OF ARDEN WAY.
WE ARE IN BARGAINING WITH UPS
IT'S THE SINGLE LARGEST
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
IN THE COUNTRY.
COVERS.
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND WORKERS.
AND OBVIOUSLY ONE OF THE ISSUES
WE'VE BARGAIN ON AROUND IS THE
INTRODUCTION USE OF TECHNOLOGY.
WHETHER THINGS LIKE DASH CAMS OR
AUTOMATED SPEED CONTROLS OR
ROUTING SOFTWARE AND GPS ARE
THINGS THAT CAN ACTUALLY HELP.
MAKE OUR MEMBERS MORE PRODUCTIVE
OR SIMPLY TOOLS TO DISCIPLINE
THEM. AND SOMETIMES THEY DESERVE
TO BE DISCIPLINED SO EXACTLY HOW
DOES THAT WORK WHEN YOU USE
TECHNOLOGY.
.
AND I WOULD POINT OUT THAT.
EVERYDAY I OUR MEMBERS DRIVING
TRUCKS.
OR ANY VEHICLES HAVE TO MAKE
DECISIONS AND IN A SPLIT SECOND
ON WHETHER THEY'RE GOING TO
PROTECT.
SOMEBODY ON THE ROAD THAT'S IN
FRONT OF THEM OR PROTECT THE
CARGO.
AND THAT IS A DECISION THAT
RIGHT NOW IS LEFT UP TO HUMANS
AND NOT AN ALGORITHM SO I AGREE
WITH THE ORIGINAL.
SPEAKER THAT THESE ARE HEAVY
QUESTIONS.
NOW. AMAZON IS U. P. S.'S
LARGEST CUSTOMER.
AND AMAZON IS PATENTED A HIGHWAY
NETWORK THAT CONTROL SELF
DRIVING TRUCKS
AND CARS.
THEY'RE DEVELOPING AN APT TO
MATCH THE DELIVERIES WITH
SHIPMENTS FROM THE DISTRIBUTION
CENTERS THEIR TESTING DRONES
THEIR AUTOMATING THEIR
WAREHOUSES.
UPS IS RIGHT THERE WITH AMAZON.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN. I HAD TO LEAVE
BECAUSE WE WORKED WITH HIM LAST
YEAR ON A BILL AB SIX SIX NINE.
WHICH ALLOWED FOR.
PERMITTING OF OF TESTING FOR
DRIVERLESS TRUCK PLATOONS BY A
MOUNTAIN VIEW BASED COMPANY
CALLED PELOTON TECHNOLOGY.
WHICH U. P. S. HAS INVESTED IN.
THE GOOD NEWS ABOUT THAT IS THAT
WE WORKED WITH MISTER BERMAN AND
AND WITH PALATINE SO THAT WHILE
THESE TRUCKS ARE BEING TESTED
THERE'S GOING TO BE A DRIVER
WITH THE COMMERCIAL. DRIVER'S
LICENSE IN EVERY TRUCK AND IN
CASE YOU DON'T KNOW PLATOON IS A
CONVOY OF VEHICLES. WHERE YOU
HAVE A DRIVER IN THE FIRST TRUCK
WHO COULD? CONTROL ALL THE OTHER
TRUCKS BEHIND.
HIM OR HER WIRELESSLY.
BUT WHILE PELOTON IS TESTING
HERE.
THESE THERE'S A DRIVER IN EVERY
TRUCK AND IN FACT OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH THEM AND OTHER
PEOPLE IN THE INDUSTRY. WE'RE
REALLY SEEING THIS IS TECHNOLOGY
THAT COULD ACTUALLY AUGMENT JOBS
INSTEAD OF AUTOMATE THEM.
NOW AS I'VE TRAVELED FROM
SILICON VALLEY TO SAN FRANCISCO
TO SACRAMENTO TO D. C.. I LIKE
LENNY I KEEP HEARING ABOUT THIS
ROBOT APOCALYPSE NOW FOUR
MILLION TRANSPORTATION WORKERS
WHO LOSE THEIR JOBS IN THE NEXT
FIVE TO TWENTY YEARS.
AND.
I AGREE WITH OTHERS THAT THAT
THE ONLY THING INEVITABLE ABOUT
HERE ABOUT THIS IS THE
TECHNOLOGY.
THE OUTCOMES ATTACH TO THAT ARE
STILL UP IN THE AIR.
WE CAN DECIDE IF.
THIS TECHNOLOGY BENEFIT SOCIETY
IF IT BENEFITS WORKERS OR IF IT
JUST BENEFITS.
COMPANIES AND THEIR
SHAREHOLDERS.
TO BE BLUNT.
AND I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT THE WORKERS.
FOR EXAMPLE A DRIVERLESS TRUCKS
THE TRUCK DRIVERS ARE HAVE A
SEAT AT THE TABLE.
IN ARE CONSULTED ON WHAT ARE THE
PROBLEMS WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE
WITH THIS TECHNOLOGY.
SO I WANT TO TALK ABOUT.
ABOUT DRIVERLESS TRUCKS IN
PARTICULAR AND AND. WHO ARE
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE FOR THOSE
PROBLEMS AND WHETHER THE
SOLUTION OF AUTOMATION IS GOING
TO MAKE THINGS WORSE?
AND I'M AFRAID RIGHT NOW IT
LOOKS LIKE THE ANSWER TO THAT IS
YES.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF GOOD
ENVIRONMENTAL REASONS.
.
EFFICIENCY REASONS COST SAVING
SAFER HIGHWAYS.
FOR DRIVERLESS TRUCKS.
BILL ONE OF THE JUSTIFICATIONS
WE KEEP HEARING ABOUT IS A
MASSIVE SHORTAGE OF AVAILABLE
TRUCK DRIVERS.
IN A LOOMING CRISIS AROUND AND
THAT'S TRUE FOR BUSES AS WELL.
SO I WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHY
THESE JOBS ARE HARD TO FILL IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
BEFORE DEREGULATION IN THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
TRUCK DRIVING WAS A GOOD MIDDLE
CLASS BLUE COLLAR JOB FOR
SOMEBODY WITH VERY LITTLE
EDUCATION.
YOU KNOW I THAT MY DAD HAD A CB
RADIO IN HIS PICK UP TRUCK THERE
WERE SONGS ON THE RADIO ABOUT
TRUCK DRIVERS IT WAS KIND OF A
MYTH THE CALLED MIDDLE CLASS
JOB.
AND.
.
AFTER DO YOU WE WERE THE LARGEST
IN IN THE COUNTRY IN AFTER
DEREGULATION WE SHRANK TO
DRAMATICALLY.
THE PHOENIX THAT ROSE OUT OF THE
ASHES OF DEREGULATION WAS THIS
BUSINESS MODEL OF HIRING PEOPLE
AS INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS
INSTEAD OF EMPLOYEES IN A TIE
THIS BACK TO A AYE.
AND AUTOMATION HERE.
AND OUT OF COURSE THIS IS THE
UBER AND LYFT BUSINESS MODEL SO
IT IT'S NOTHING NEW TO US.
BUT WHAT IT ENABLE THE TRUCKING
COMPANIES TO DO WAS TO.
SHIFT.
ESSENTIALLY SHIFT ALL THE COSTS
AND BURDENS ONTO THE BACKS OF
THE WORKERS FOR OWNING AND
OPERATING A TRUCK.
AND AS A SMALL BUSINESS UNDER
THE LAW AN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR HAS NO RIGHT TO
ORGANIZE A UNION.
AND I I SHOULD SAY THERE IS A
TIME AND A PLACE FOR INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTING I'M JUST TALKING
ABOUT THIS WITH TRUCK DRIVERS.
AND.
STUDIES HAVE DOCUMENTED THAT IN
TIME IT WENT FROM A A GOOD JOB
TO ONE WHERE NOW THEY WORK
SEVENTY EIGHTY HOURS A WEEK THAT
NO SOCIAL SAFETY NET NO
UNEMPLOYMENT NO WORKERS COMP. NO
HEALTH INSURANCE NO BENEFITS NO
RIGHT TO NEGOTIATE AROUND THOSE
THINGS.
AND.
THEY MAKE LESS THAN MINIMUM
WAGE.
SO IT'S NO WONDER THAT THEY
CAN'T FIND PEOPLE TO TAKE THESE
JOBS.
AND I WOULD.
SO HUMBLY SUGGEST THAT THE
INDUSTRY IS NOW USING DRIVERLESS
TRUCKS TO SOLVE A PROBLEM THAT
THEY THEMSELVES CREATED.
ARE AROUND THE BY DESTROYING THE
QUALITY OF THE JOBS.
SO THE QUESTION TO ME IS WILL
THIS TREND JUST FURTHER
EXACERBATE THIS PROBLEM.
AND I WAS INTERVIEWED BY THE
ATLANTIC.
MAGAZINE A FEW MONTHS AGO.
AND ASKED TO RESPOND TO A REPORT
BY UBER THAT PREDICTED AN ACTUAL
NET INCREASE IN JOBS DO THE SELF
DRIVING TRUCKS I BELIEVE THAT
ACTUALLY TO BE TRUE.
.
A.
IT I THINK IT'S MORE GOING TO
BE.
BECAUSE DRIVERLESS TRUCKS CANNOT
OPERATE IN AN URBAN ENVIRONMENT
AND SO THEY'RE GOING TO BE.
NEW JOBS THINK ABOUT THE AMAZON
FLAX DRIVER DOING DELIVERIES
OVER THE SHORT HAUL DRIVERS LIKE
WE HAVE AT THE PORTS OF LA LONG
BEACH IN OAKLAND.
THE PROBLEM WITH THE REPORT.
IN MY OPINION WAS THAT WAS
TOTALLY SILENT ON THE ISSUE OF
JOB QUALITY.
FIRE WHETHER THESE JOBS CAN ARE
THEY GONNA BE GOOD UNION JOBS
THAT ARE CREATED ARE THEY GOING
TO BE MORE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR JOBS.
HOW WILL THAT IMPACT OUR UPS
DRIVERS TO?
WHO?
ARE MAKING DECENT WAGES WITH A
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA.
WITH FULLY PAID FAMILY HEALTH
CARE IN A PENSION.
I'M ALSO SKEPTICAL ABOUT
UNIVERSAL BASIC INCOME AND I'M.
HONESTLY SKEPTICAL ABOUT
PORTABLE BENEFITS.
I'M ALSO SKEPTICAL ABOUT
RETRAINING. AND I LET ME TELL
YOU WHY.
WE HAVE A PLANT CLOSURE WE JUST
GOT NOTICE TWO THOUSAND
TEAMSTERS AT SENECA FOODS
CANNERY IN MODESTO ARE GOING TO
LOSE THEIR JOBS.
THIS IS HAPPENING AS WE SPEAK.
AT OUR PEAK WE HAVE A HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEMBERS WORKING IN
CANNERIES MOSTLY IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
AND WE'RE DOWN TO FIFTEEN
THOUSAND AS I SAID WE'RE GONNA
LOSE TWO THOUSAND MARK.
THE LAST PLANT CLOSURE WE HAD
WAS HERE IN SACRAMENTO CAMPBELL
SOUP IN TWENTY TWELVE AND EIGHT
HUNDRED TEAMSTERS LOST THEIR
JOBS.
THE GREAT ARTICLE ACTUALLY
HORRIBLE ARTICLE IN THE SACK BE
THE DAN MORAINE WROTE PROFILING
ONE OF OUR MEMBERS WHOSE MOM HAD
WORKED THERE HER WHOLE LIFE SHE
FOLLOWED HER MOM THERE.
IT WAS NOT UNCOMMON. SINGLE MOM
WITH TWO KIDS LOST HER JOB.
HER UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE RAN
OUT SHE GOT RETRAINING.
THROUGH THROUGH UNDER THE WARN
ACT AND AND TRADE ADJUSTMENT.
IT TOOK HER THREE YEARS TO LEARN
TO BECOME AN ULTRASOUND
TECHNICIAN
BY THAT TIME. SHE HAD LOST THEIR
HEALTH INSURANCE GOT SICK MOVED
HER FAMILY BACK IN WITH HER MOM.
AND AT THE END OF HER RETRAINING
THERE WAS NO.
JOB GUARANTEE SHE WAS NOT
MATCHED TO A JOB.
IN THE SAME ARTICLE.
MISTER MORAINE TALKED ABOUT THE
OWNER OF THE CAMPBELL SOUP.
COMPANY WHO WAS A MEMBER OF THE
SEVENTEENTH WEALTHIEST FAMILY IN
THE UNITED STATES ACCORDING TO
FORBES WHO.
IN THE PANAMA PAPERS IT CAME OUT
HE MOVE TO IRELAND RENOUNCED HIS
US CITIZENSHIP TO AVOID PAYING
TAXES.
SO VERY DRAMATIC EXAMPLE BUT.
IT REINFORCES THE POINT TO ME
THAT WE CANNOT TRUST THE
COMPANIES.
CORD DEVELOPING THIS TECHNOLOGY
TO WRITE THE RULES
CANNOT TRUSTS THEM TO DO THAT
FOR THE WORKERS AND FOR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS
AND. WE NEED YOU. TO WRITE THE
RULES.
THE TEAMSTERS ARE NOT AGAINST
INNOVATION.
MORE NOT GONNA STOP.
THE THE REVOLUTION THE ROBOT
APOCALYPSE WHATEVER YOU WANNA
CALL IT WE'RE NOT GOING TO STOP
IT.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO PROTECT ALL
THE JOBS BUT WE'RE GONNA DO OUR
VERY BEST TO PROTECT THE
WORKERS.
AND WE NEED YOU TO GET
COMMITMENTS FROM THE COMPANIES
TO RETAIN AND RETRAIN INCUMBENT
WORKERS.
TO TO WORK WITH US AND WITH
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THE SKILLS ARE THAT
PEOPLE NEED NOW HOW DO YOU MATCH
THEM UP.
AND THEN WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE ARE QUALITY JOBS
THE PEOPLE CAN AFFORD TO SUPPORT
THEIR FAMILIES. TO ME THAT'S
REAL INNOVATION.
THAT'S TECHNOLOGY THAT'LL MAKE
PEOPLE'S JOBS
SAY FOR THAT MAKE THEM MORE
PRODUCTIVE SO THAT THEY CAN EARN
MORE MONEY.
IT SHOULD REDUCE THE GAP BETWEEN
THE HAVES AND THE HAVE NOTS.
THESE ARE THE PROBLEMS WE SHOULD
BE SOLVING FOR WITH TECHNOLOGY
INTO THAT AND I WILL CLOSE ON
THIS I AGREE WITH ONE OF THE
OTHER RECOMMENDATIONS.
THAT WE WOULD ACTUALLY BE WELL
SERVED BY A COMMISSION THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE.
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR TO LOOK AT
THESE ISSUES AROUND TECHNOLOGY
AUTOMATION IN THE FUTURE OF WORK
THAT INVOLVES INDUSTRY. LABOR
AND WORKERS WERE LEFT OFF THAT
EARLIER LIST AND I THINK WE ARE
AN IMPORTANT VOICE.
AND WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION TO
PUSH THIS IDEA. AND I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION TO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION JAM AND.
WITHOUT DOUBT QUESTIONS OF
MISTER OBERNOLTE GO AHEAD.
I THINK THAT YOUR QUESTION FOR
MR MENDONCA AND.
I I WAS FASCINATED BY YOUR
COMMENTS ABOUT TECHNOLOGICAL
UNEMPLOYMENT AND PARTICULARLY
THE.
ASSERTION THAT WHEN WE SAY. OUR
UNEMPLOYMENT WE'RE REALLY
TALKING ABOUT DISPLACEMENT WE'RE
TALKING NOT TALK ABOUT
UNEMPLOYMENT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE NEED TO RETRAIN PEOPLE INTO
NEW JOBS BECAUSE. THE USUALLY
THIS KIND OF TECHNOLOGY CAN
CATALYZE THE CREATION OF MORE
NEW JOBS OF THE JOBS IT
DISPLACES BUT IT CREATE CREASES
BIG SOCIETAL PROBLEM. A LOT OF
THE OTHER PANELISTS AT SIMILAR
THINGS TO SAY ABOUT THAT BUT I
WONDER FOR BEING A LITTLE BIT
NAIVE WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SOLUTIONS BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IT
LOGICALLY. THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT HOW TO RETRAIN PEOPLE AND
AND HOW TO GET THEM TO
TRANSITION INTO FROM AS YOUR
LOCAL JOBS INTO THE NEW FIELDS.
YEAH BUT IF YOU LOOK BACK AT
HISTORY OF. WHAT WE'VE GONE
THROUGH THESE CIRCUMSTANCES
BEFORE I MEAN IN THE WHAT THE
EIGHTEEN ELEVEN? WHEN WE HAD THE
LUDDITES BURNING THE TEXTILE
MILLS IN ENGLAND.
.
IT IT THAT WAS REALLY WHAT
CATALYZED THE BIGGEST EXPANSION
IN OUR QUALITY OF LIFE IN HUMAN
HISTORY UP UNTIL THAT POINT. AND
YET I DON'T THINK THAT IF WE
WENT DOWN TO THE TO THAT MOB
WITH THE TORCHES AND SAID HEY
WAIT WE'RE GOING TO GET YOU NEW
JOBS YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND I
DON'T THINK THAT WOULD DO ANY
GOOD SO. WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
ROBOT APOCALYPSE ALMOST LOOK AT
IT FROM AN OPPOSITE POINT OF
VIEW AND IT'S NOT LIKE WE FEAR
THE ROBOTS WE FEAR OUR REACTION
TO. THIS TECHNOLOGY AND I WONDER
WHAT WE CAN DO TO TO EDUCATE
PEOPLE ABOUT THIS COMING
TRANSITION BECAUSE TO ME THAT'S
KEY TO AVOIDING THE THE
APOCALYPTIC PART OF WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
AND SO.
BUT THERE ARE A COUPLE OF TIMES
IN RECENT HISTORY WHERE WE HAD
THE SCALE OF CHANGE.
A MOVEMENT FROM THE
AGRICULTURAL.
EMPLOYMENT TO.
THAT MANUFACTURING EMPLOYMENT
FOR MANUFACTURING TO TO.
SERVICE WERE ENTERING THE THIRD
YEAR OF THAT A TRANSITION TO A
TECHNOLOGY BASED
ERA IN EACH OF THOSE PRIOR IS
THAT WAS PUSHED BACK FOR THE
TECHNOLOGY.
BUT THERE WAS ALSO A MASSIVE
INNOVATION AND HOW WE ENABLED
PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THEM SO
IN THE FIRST ONE WE INVENTED IN
UNIVERSAL HIGH SCHOOL.
THE SECOND ONE WE MOVED PRETTY
DRAMATICALLY THE GI BILL AND TO
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THINGS LIKE
THE MASTER PLAN TO CALIFORNIA.
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE HAD THE
SIDE OF OPPORTUNITIES TO BE ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT NEXT
MONTH WE'RE GONNA NEED THAT SAME
SCALE OF THINKING HERE.
BECAUSE IT'S IT IS THERE IT
IT'S NOT THAT WE SHOULDN'T BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THESE
TECHNOLOGIES I AGREE WITH THAT
WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT. HOW OUR
PACE AND SCALE OF ENSURING THAT?
THE WORK FORCE IS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THESE GAINES
MATCHES THE PACE OF CHANGE OF OF
THE TECHNOLOGY AND SO THAT'S
WHERE I'M BY I THINK THAT
CONVERSATION REALLY NEEDS TO BE
ABOUT THAT PART OF IT HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE. I DO
THINK THERE WILL BE NEW JOBS
THERE AND I SHARE THE VIEW THAT
A LOT OF THESE TECHNOLOGIES WILL
CREATE DIFFERENT KINDS OF JOBS.
SO THERE MAY BE MORE JOBS AND
TRANSPORTATION IS THE RESULT OF
SOME OF THESE CHANGES THEY'LL BE
VERY DIFFERENT JOBS.
I WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
PARTICIPATED NOTS.
THANKS I AGREE WITH YOU I JUST
WONDER IF THAT BATTLE STARTS
DOESN'T START NOW NOT WIN THE
PEOPLE'S PEOPLE DISPLACED BUT
YOU KNOW THAT BATTLE STARTING
NOW WITH AN EDUCATIONAL PROCESS
THAT SAYING LOOK THIS CHANGES
COMING. WE NEED TO BE PREPARED
FOR IT COMPLETELY GREAT. THANK
YOU.
BOB THANK YOU ARE ON THE ISSUE
OF EDUCATION I THINK.
ON COMPUTER SCIENCE
PARTICULARLY I THINK THE EXAMPLE
WAS THAT WAS GIVEN WAS.
POTTERY VOICES COMPUTER SCIENCE
SO IT'S A QUESTION AYE I THINK
WAS EITHER AT MISTER ATKINSON
OR.
LENNY UP BUT THE QUESTION IS
HOW DO WE MOTIVATE YOUNG YOUNG
PEOPLE TOO. ARE MAKING MANY
STANDARD COMPUTER SCIENCES YOU
KNOW THE ESSENCE OR THAT DENTAL
THAT'S GONNA BE THE BUILDING
BLOCK FOR THE FUTURE JOBS AND
AND ALL. ON SUSU YOU KNOW WE WE
DO WANT TO INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE TO
YOU KNOW GET INTO COMPUTER
SCIENCE BUT BUT WHAT IS WHAT IS
THE.
WHAT WHAT DOES IT TAKE TO
MOTIVATE YOUNG PEOPLE?
ARE YOU THERE. WELFARE.
YEAH I I I DIVERT ALL.
THE REASON WHY POTTERY IS SO
POPULAR IN CALIFORNIA HIGH
SCHOOL DID THE REQUIREMENTS.
PARTS PARTS IS A REQUIREMENT
COMPUTER SCIENCE IS NOT A
REQUIREMENT.
I DON'T THINK IT'S REALLY IT ALL
THAT MUCH OF A QUESTION THE
MOTIVATION I I THINK THERE. LOTS
AND LOTS OF KIDS WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN ENGAGING IN
TECHNOLOGY YOU LOOK AT IT AND
YOU LOOK AT ADDITION LIKE FIRST
ROBOTICS. ABACHA.
A FANTASTIC PROGRAM I I'M SURE
EVERY.
SCHOOL ARE I'M SURE THERE IS A
SCHOOL IN EACH ONE OF YOUR
DISTRICTS WHERE YOU HAVE FOR
ROBOTICS COMPETITION GOING ON A.
JOIN IN.
REGION ALL THE NATIONAL
COMPETITIONS AND EVEN HER
NATIONAL THAT YOU CAN BUILD THE
BEST ROBOTICS IT WOULDN'T WHEN
YOU'RE IN HIGH SCHOOL.
IF YOU MEAN IF I THINK IF YOU
RESTRUCTURECURRICULUM AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERY KID YEAH IN
EVERY HIGH SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA
HAS. HIGH QUALITY COMPUTER SCI
FI THING AND CLASSES WHICH IS
NOT THE CASE RIGHT NOW BEEN IN
EVERY COUNTRY IN EVERY STATE IN
THE UNION. AND SECONDLY TO REACH
RESTRUCTURE CURRICULUM SO THAT
YOU CAN HAVE PROJECT BASED
LEARNING AROUND THESE THINGS.
WHEN WE LOOK AT SOMEBODY'S
WRITING BASED LEARNING THINGS
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE OUT.
THE MAKER MOVED ANOTHER WOULD
HAVE A CERTAIN SORT OF IF YOU
WILL TWENTY FIRST CENTURY SHOP
CLASS IN WHAT WAY TO THINK ABOUT
IT. IT ALL THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT IS PILOTING WITHOUT
HIGH SCHOOLS AROUND THE COUNTRY
TO DO THAT IN THE ENGAGEMENT
WITH HIS IS JUST ENORMOUS THEY
COULD ACTUALLY. USE COMPUTERS.
DESIGN THINGS THEY USE COMPUTER
A SPECIES THAT BUILD THINGS.
I'M NOT SURE QUESTION MOTIVATION
I THINK IT IN SOME WAY TO THE
QUESTION OF IF YOU.
LEAVE THE HORSE TO WATER HERE
THEY WILL BRING.
S. FARMING I HAD YEAH JUST ONE.
MAKE IT QUICK OF WHAT COMMENTS
APOLOGIES FOR MISSING MOST OF
THE THE COMMENTS ADDED TEN
CONSTITUENT GROUPS BACK MY
OFFICE.
BUT I'D.
PIGGY BACKING OFF OF.
MISTER ATKINSON'S COMMENTS.
.
I KNOW THAT STATISTICS IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN TODAY'S THE MY
CAMPAIGN A LOT AND I HAVEN'T
CHECKED THE UPDATED ONES BUT IN
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN ONLY FORTY
FIVE PERCENT OF HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA. HAD
ACCESS TO COMPUTER SCIENCE.
IT WAS TYPICALLY THE HEAVILY.
LATINO AND AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES WHERE THE SCHOOLS
DIDN'T OFFER COMPUTER SCIENCE
AND SO WE NEED TO INCREASE OUR
W. TO BRIDGE THAT.
KIND DIGITAL LEARNING DIVIDE
THAT EXISTS.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND MISTER ATKINSON MENTION
MAKING IT A REQUIREMENT.
.
I I THINK HE MEANS PART OF A
THROUGH G. CURRICULUM.
WHICH ARE THE OFF THE WALL IT
CAN BE GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS
OR COULD BE THE IF YOU'RE G.
CURRICULUM WHICH OF THE.
REQUIREMENTS TO QUALIFY FOR THE
USE YOUR SEATS YOU SYSTEMS. NON
AND THERE'S CURRENTLY I KNOW A
STATE COMPUTER SCIENCE
CURRICULUM COMMITTEE AND I'M
SURE I DIDN'T GET THE NAME
RIGHT.
BUT THAT'S LOOKING AT IDEAS FOR
HOW WE CAN BETTER.
YEAH IMPLEMENT COMPUTER SCIENCE
INTO OUR CLASSROOMS HOPEFULLY K.
THROUGH TWELVE ON YOU KNOW YOU
HEAVY COATING IN
SECOND GRADE BUT YOU CAN. BE
CERTAIN I LEARNED SOME OF THE
CONCEPTS AND SO.
I'M LOOKING FOR TO SEE WHAT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE FROM THAT
COMMITTEE.
AND FIGURING OUT HOW WE CAN
IMPLEMENT THEM.
OUT SO.
ONE IS I THINK MISTER BLOCK.
FOR THE WORK THAT WE DID
TOGETHER LAST YEAR THAT I KNOW
YOU MENTIONED WELL WHEN I WAS IN
HERE.
ON AB WAS A SIX SIX NINE SIX
SIX NINE.
AND YOU KNOW REALLY APPRECIATED
IT WE DESPERATELY AND I ONE
THING THE CHAIR FOR FOR BRING
ALL OF US TOGETHER BECAUSE WE
DESPERATELY NEED TO BRING
TOGETHER. OUR TECHNOLOGY
INDUSTRY IN OUR INNOVATION
ECONOMY WITH LABOR AND I THINK
WITH ACADEMIA.
TO REALLY HAVE HONEST
CONVERSATIONS.
USING.
REALISTIC.
KIND OF.
DE EXPECTED IMPACTS.
SOME OF OF THE IMPACT OF OF
INNOVATION IN A AYE ON THE WORK
FORCE.
AND DOES MISTER WHEELER
OBERNOLTE IF IT WAS IT WAS
TALKING ABOUT YOU GET OUT IN
FRONT. OF THIS WE CAN'T WAIT
UNTIL WE KNOW THAT CERTAIN
THINGS ARE GOING TO HAPPEN.
LET'S IDENTIFY WHAT THEY ARE IN
THIS DEVELOP THE POLICIES NOW.
TO START. PUTTING TOGETHER THE
PROGRAMS SO THAT WHEN THAT
HAPPENS WERE READY FOR IT AND WE
CAN HOPEFULLY TRANSITION FOLKS.
EVEN BEFORE IT HAPPENS.
INTO THE THE JOBS OF THE FUTURE
AND SO YOU KNOW I THINK THIS IS
A GREAT FOR START.
ON THAT AND AND REALLY
APPRECIATE IT I WAS TALKING
WITH.
AN EXPERT AT AT STANFORD
UNIVERSITY IN MY DISTRICT.
AND YEAH AND THEY HAVE A TON OF
IDEAS AND THEY HAVE NO SKIN IN
THE GAME.
AND I THINK THAT ACADEMIA
WHETHER IT'S.
WHATEVER YOU INSTITUTION CAN BE
REALLY GOOD NEUTRAL NAM KIND OF
ARBITERS FOR SOME OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS.
TO BRING FOLKS TOGETHER AND AND
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT POLICIES
WE CAN IDENTIFY AND IMPLEMENT AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE SO. I KNOW I
THEM EAGER TO BE A PART OF THAT.
AND I KNOW THAT YOU ALL SIDES
OF THIS CONVERSATION I HOPE OR
AND AND THINK ARE YOUR THAT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THAT CONVERSATION
AND. THE SOONER THE BETTER.
MISTER MENDONCA MENTIONED THE.
NINETEEN SIXTY MASTER PLAN.
FRAT HIGHER EDUCATION AND I WAS
SELECT COMMITTEE.
TO RICK TO REVIEW THAT.
EVENTUALLY TO REVISE THAT
NOTHING THIS NEEDS TO BE A BIG
PART OF THAT CONVERSATION AS WE
MOVE FORWARD SO WITH THAT I'M
GONNA RUN OUT.
BUT JUST REALLY WANNA MAKE SURE
TO MAKE IT BACK TO SAY THANK
YOU.
TO EVERYBODY LOOKING FORWARD TO
HAVING MORE MORE CONVERSATIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND DO HERE.
COMMENTS AND IF THERE ARE NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FOR THIS PANEL I WANT TO THANK
THE GENTLEMAN FOR YOUR FOR
SHARING YOUR PERSPECTIVES NOW.
AND IT WILL BRING UP THE NEXT
PANEL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GENTLEMEN.
IF YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
ATKINSON.
THANK YOU MY PLEASURE AND I
LOOKED LIKE TO BE THERE. THANK
YOU AGAIN
* IT.
AT THIS TIME I'M TO BRING UP
THE NEXT PANEL.
OUR NEXT PANEL. WILL DISCUSS
THE TOPIC OF GOVERNMENT SOCIAL
COMMERCIAL APPLICATIONS AND WHAT
THOSE APPLICATIONS MIGHT MEAN
TENS OF SOCIAL BENEFITS AND
CONVENIENCE FOR USERS. AS WELL
AS UP BIAS AND PRIVACY
IMPLICATIONS.
I JOINING US FOR THE PANEL WE
HAVE SEVERAL SPEAKERS SUFFERS
VOTE FIRST OF ALL WE HAVE MISTER
PETER LIEBERT. WHO IS THE CHIEF
INFORMATION SECURITY OFFICER OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY?
WE ALSO HAVE MISTER OF LIKE RUM
A YEAR VICE PRESIDENT OF PUBLIC
POWER.
PUBLIC POLICY AND STRATEGIC
COMMUNICATION OPPOSE MAKES.
OUR MISTER PAUL DUGAN.
MD AND PHD FOUNDER AND CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF MIND
STRONG.
ARE MAPPED HAGEL TECHNOLOGY AND
CIVIL LIBERTIES ATTORNEYS ACLU
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND A
MISTER JONATHAN FELT MEN OF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION. ARE GENTLEMEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I WELCOME I'M SAY
WITHOUT DOW WHENEVER YOU ARE
READY WE CAN START WITH MR
APPEAL LEVER.
GOOD MORNING IT'S A AN HONOR TO
BE HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. OF
MEMBERS.
.
I THINK OUR OUR PANELISTS HERE
IT'S A PRETTY GOOD GROUP WIDE
RANGING.
SO I'M GOING TO ACTUALLY.
TALK A LITTLE BIT TODAY ABOUT
AN AREA I THINK OF THE HASN'T
TOUCHED ON YET. BY THE WAY THE
IT'S BEEN FANTASTIC SO FAR I'VE
BEEN REALLY EXCITED SNOWING HERE
TOPICS OF.
THAT IS SPECIFICALLY A ON
CYBERSECURITY.
SOL START OFF WITH A WITH A
STORY AND.
TWENTY SIXTEEN I ATTENDED
A CONFERENCE CALL DEF CON.
AND.
IT DURING THAT CONFERENCE THEY
HAD SOMETHING CALLED THE CYBER
CHALLENGE.
DARPA PUT TOGETHER ACTUALLY WAS
A MULTIMILLION DOLLAR PRICE.
THEY HAD MULTIPLE ACADEMIC AND
RESEARCHER TEAMS.
A COMPETE IN A IN THE CHALLENGE
A ACTUALLY A BERKELEY AND CENTER
BARBARA BURKE BOTH IN THE
FINALS.
.
AND THAT THE PREMISE WAS SIMPLE
AND DEVELOP A AT COMPLETELY
AUTONOMOUS.
A COMPUTER A SYSTEM THAT PLAYS.
BASICALLY A VIRTUAL VERSION OF
CAPTURE THE FLAG.
WELL HOW DOES THAT WORK WELL
EACH OF THE.
.
MACHINES HAVE.
ACIDIC HE'S WITHIN THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE OTHER
MACHINES HAVE TO ATTACK THAT
MACHINE AND TRY TO.
GRAB THOSE KEYS AND TO PROTECT
OUR THERE'S THIS PROTECT IS
ACTUALLY A OF NEVER BEFORE SEEN
PIECE OF CODE.
WHICH THERE HAVE TO IDENTIFY
VULNERABILITIES PATCH.
AND THEN ATTACK USING THE
PREVIOUS.
IDENTIFIED VULNERABILITIES
AGAINST OTHERS AGAIN COMPLETELY
AUTONOMOUS NO NO INDIVIDUAL IN
THE LOOP.
.
IT WAS A PRETTY FAST AND WATCH
WHAT THE LAST SEVERAL HOURS.
ACTUALLY UNFORTUNATELY NONE OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEAMS.
ONE IT WAS CARNEGIE MELLON. BUT.
IT PROVED A POINT THAT.
.
YOUR AYE POWERED CYBERSECURITY.
ON BOTH ON THE OFFENSE AND
DEFENSE ASSISTANT DEFENSE OF
SIDE. IS HERE AYE IT IS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT HAS A A FANTASY.
AND I THINK.
YOU CAN SEE THAT ARE IN THE
MARKETPLACE.
FROM A.
UNPACKING WHAT THE STORY.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DEFENSIVE
SIDE. THERE ARE.
YOU NAME THE NUMBER OF
COMPANIES OUT THERE DOZENS AND
DOZENS THAT TALENT.
A AYE CAPABILITIES.
IMUS IS IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE.
DEFENDING NETWORKS IS A VERY
COMPLEX VERY DIFFICULT THERE'S A
LOT OF DATA TO CHEW THROUGH. A
TO TRY IDENTIFY MALICIOUS AND
SUSPICIOUS ACTIVITY A AYE IS A
HUGE HELP IN THAT.
I WAS ABLE TO FIND THOSE NEEDLES
IN THE HAYSTACK AND AUTOMATE
MANY CASES.
INITIAL SCRIPTED RESPONSES TO
UPLOAD HOLES IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE ACTUALLY UTILIZE SIM A I AM
THE STATE ALREADY.
SOME OF THE.
TECHNOLOGY SOLUTIONS THAT WE
BUILT WITHIN OUR SECURITY
OPERATIONS CENTER RECEIVED A.
USES MACHINE LEARNING.
p AND THAT HELPS OUR ANALYST AT
BE ABLE TO DO WHAT THEY'RE
WRITTEN THEY DO.
IT IS A.
CONTINUALLY EVOLVING.
SKILL SET OUT IS SOMETHING HAS
TO BE TUNED.
COSTLY MONITORED.
BUT IT DEFTLY HAS HELPED.
NOW THAT'S THAT'S THE GOOD NEWS.
ON COULD THE BAD NEWS FRONT.
JUST AS YOU HAVE A AYE DEFENSES
YOU'RE LOOKING AT A AYE OFFENSE
AS WELL.
IS YOU KNOW CURRENTLY THERE ARE
A LOT OF.
SCRIPTING ENGINES OUT THERE
THAT YOU DO AUTOMATIC ATTACKS
WOULD BLOCK ALLOTMENT BICU HAS
ALREADY.
THEY'RE JUST HUNTING FOR A
PREVIOUSLY KNOWN
VULNERABILITIES.
AND WANTS TO GET A FOOTHOLD THAT
CAN ACTUALLY LAUNCH A PLUMERI.
TAX.
TO ESTABLISH A FOOTHOLD AND
THEN ALLOW HUMAN IN LIEU.
.
THAT WILL GET BETTER OVER TIME.
ATTACKERS WILL BECOME A JUSTICE
DEFENDERS ARE MORE MORE RELIANT
ON A AYE WHICH MEANS THAT.
SADLY YOU'RE GONNA LOOK AT
FASTER CHEAPER.
AND MORE TAILORED TO TAX.
ALSO OF MORE HARDER TO
ATTRIBUTE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY UTILIZE FOR ATTRIBUTION
TODAY CURRENTLY. WITH CYBER
ATTACKS
IS OUR THE FLAWS THAT YOU WOULD
SEE FROM HUMAN ERROR IN CODING
I'M.
FOLKS THAT DEVELOPMENT WHERE A
LOT TIMES THEY'VE WE'VE LITTLE
CLONE CARDS THAT EVEN KNOWING
IT.
THAT GOES AWAY ONCE YOU START
LOOKING AT A AYE. BUILT.
MALWARE AND OUR PLATFORM
ENGINES.
.
YOU KNOW EH IF YOU'RE TO USE
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF OF WHAT THIS
MEANS FOR US FOR A COMMON
EVERYDAY USER.
.
SPAM EMAIL FISHING EMAIL RIGHT
NOW EYES BECOMING MORE MORE
TAILORED.
THE ONLY THING THAT WE HAVE
GOING FOR US IS REALLY TO GET A
VERY GOOD COOK WELL CRAFTED
SPEAR PHISHING EMAIL COMING YOUR
WAY. YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOMEONE
SIT DOWN AND REALLY ANALYZE THE
TARGET.
USE OPEN SOURCE INTELLIGENCE AS
THEY GO TO SOCIAL MEDIA.
THE SEEGER TRYING TO TARGET.
MANY STARCRAFT IN IT THAT.
IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T MAKE THAT
INDIVIDUAL THINK IT'S TRUSTED
AND CLICK IT.
ARMS SPEARFISHING OR TARGETED
FISHING OR WILL FISHING IS ALSO
KNOWN AS A.
.
WHEN YOU PUT A AYE ENGINE BEHIND
THAT.
AND BEGIN INPUTTING DATA SUCH AS
SOCIAL MEDIA NETWORKS.
YOU KNOW EVERYTHING FROM HOME
YOU KNOW AT PUBLIC APPEARANCES
ETCETERA.
AND THEN YOU CAN HAVE A AYE IN
THEORY BE ABLE TO CRAFT.
SPEAR PHISHING EMAILS UP TO
HAVE A MUCH WIDER. USER DATABASE
IF YOU WELL OTHER PREVIOUSLY
KNOWN AND THAT HIS GOING TO BE.
SOMETHING EXTREMELY PROBLEMATIC.
WE ALREADY ARE NOT VERY GOOD AT
IDENTIFYING SPEAR PHISHING
EMAILS WE IS IN THE ROLE WE.
AND IN GENERAL.
.
AND.
IT'S GOING IT HARDER AS AS EASY
TO ATTACK SAID BECOME MORE MORE
PROFICIENT IN A HIGH BACKED.
SO.
.
SOMETHING TO HAVE GUESTS LOOK
FORWARD TO.
IN THE FUTURE.
IT IS.
IT'S IT'S REALLY GOING TO BE A
RACE BETWEEN.
ENSURING THAT YOU REALIZE IN
BOTH A THE BEST POSSIBLE PRE TO
TECHNOLOGY.
ARE ON THE DEFENSIVE SIDE WHICH
A LOT OF IT IS A I ENABLED AYE
HAS MACHINE LEARNING BEHIND IT.
IN ORDER COUNTY THERE'S THREATS
SO.
THAT'S A TALL HAD.
GRAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
MISTER ONLY BURKE.
NEXT LET'S GO TO MISTER AREA
HERE.
THERE'S A CORRECTLY YOU DID YOU
ALL FEEL FREE TO CORRECT ME.
I I GOT IT.
WELL MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THE HONORABLE VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANKS
FOR HAVING ME HERE.
CLAIMS VICTIM IRE IN THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF PUBLIC POLICY
PROPOSED MAKES.
I DON'T I JUST START SINCE WORD
OF THE ONE INDUSTRY
REPRESENTATIVE HERE ABOUT HOW
WE'RE ACTUALLY APPLYING A AYE
WITHIN OUR BUSINESS MODEL AND
TALK ABOUT SOME THE LESSONS
LEARNED FAIR. PARTICULARLY
GERMANE TO SOME THE CONCERNS OF
WHEAT FOR US.
POST MATES IS A IT'S AN APT
ENABLED START UP THAT ALLOWS YOU
TO GET.
ALMOST ANYTHING YOUR COMMUNITY
DELIVERED TO YOUR DOORSTEP
WITHIN AN HOUR.
IT PAIRS YOU WITH A LOCAL
MERCHANT.
IF YOU WANTED A FOOD DELIVERED
TO YOU IF YOU'RE A SENIOR
CITIZEN WITH MOBILITY ISSUES IN
NEED OF HEALTH AND WELLNESS
PRODUCTS.
AT THEN PAIRS THAT MERGE INTO A
LOCAL CAREER WE HAVE BEEN ACTIVE
NETWORK OF ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND CAREERS IN ANY GIVEN
MOMENT ON THE PLATFORM I'M AND
THEN DROPPED THAT OFF AT YOUR
HOME. SO FOR US ARE TESTING OF A
I ACTUALLY COMES IN THE FORM OF
ROBOTICS AND IT STARTS FROM ITS
BASE OF UNDERSTANDING AND
REALIZING THAT THE WAY COMMERCE
IS SHIFTING. IN CITIES IS
ACTUALLY TRANSFORMING OVERNIGHT
AMER ALL FAMILIAR WITH AN AMAZON
LIKE PLATFORMER WALMART DOT COM
LIKE PLATFORM. PAPER CONVENIENT
HYPER USEFUL BUT THEIR APPROACH
IS ACTUALLY BUILDING A WAREHOUSE
ON THE OUTSKIRTS OF CITIES AND
AND FUNNELING THOSE GOODS INTO
TOWN.
A COMPANY LIKE POST MATES IN
WHAT WE CALL THE ON DEMAND
SECTOR ACTUALLY APPROACHES IT IN
THE INVERSE MODEL WE ACTUALLY
TREAT THE ENTIRE CITY AS A
WAREHOUSE.
WE INDEXED THE PRODUCT OFFERINGS
OF LOCAL HARDWARE STORES MOM AND
POP RETAILERS BRIGHAM MODE MODEM
A PSYCHIATRIC MORTAR MERCHANTS
AND THEN GIVE THEM THE TOOLS
THEY NEED TO DISTRIBUTE THEIR
GOODS.
SO MY NUMBERS WITHIN THE UNITED
STATES WE OPERATE ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY U. S. CITIES WE
TRANSACT ABOUT THREE MILLION
DELIVERIES PER MONTH ON THE
PLATFORM.
LAST YEAR ALONE WE SOLD ABOUT
ONE BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
GOODS ON THE PLATFORM AND INTHE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA PER AND
ECONOMIC IMPACT REPORT WERE
ACTUALLY GOING TO RELEASE AT THE
END OF THIS MONTH. WE'VE
ACTUALLY SEEN THAT LOCAL
RETAILERS HAVE SEEN A GROWTH BY
ABOUT THREE POINT SEVEN OR FOUR
TIMES AND THE CONCEPT FOR THIS
IS QUITE SIMPLE AND THAT'S
BECAUSE NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN.
INSTEAD OF YOU GETTING YOUR
LIGHT BULBS FROM AMAZON DOT COM
YOU CAN ACTUALLY GET THEM FROM A
LOCAL HARDWARE STORE NOW ALL OF
A SUDDEN A MOM AND POP BAKERY OR
TALK AREA OWNER OR FOUGHT SHOP
OWNER IS ABLE TO. TRANSPORT
THEIR GOODS ACROSS TOWN AND NOT
ONLY BRIDGE GEOGRAPHIES OF THAT
REGION BUT ACTUALLY SELL TO NEW
CUSTOMERS THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
NEVER SOLD TO BEFORE BEYOND JUST
THE SQUARE FOOTAGE OF THEIR
DINING ROOM.
SO FOR US FOOD DELIVERY OR ON
DEMAND DELIVERY IS WAY BIGGER
THAN JUST BEING.
LAZY ON A SUNDAY AFTERNOON AND
TRYING TO GET SOMETHING
DELIVERED TO YOUR DOORSTEP IT'S
TRANSFORMING THE MARKET
APPLICATION OF TECHNOLOGY SMART
ALGORITHMS AND COMMERCE AS WE
KNOW IT AND WE CAN DO SO IN A
WAY THAT INVEST IN THE HELP OF
LOCAL ECONOMIES. AS OPPOSED TO
AT THE EXCLUSION OF THOSE LOCAL
ECONOMIES.
UP BUT A BIG PART OF THAT
NETWORK FOR POST MATE MATCHING
YOU THE CUSTOMER TO A MERCHANT
TO A CAREER IS POWERED BY THE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS ON OUR
PART. WE CALL THEM POST MADE
I MENTIONED WE HAVE ABOUT A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND ACTIVE ON
OUR PLATFORM AT ANY GIVEN TIME.
ON BALANCE THEY EARN A BETWEEN
SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS AN HOUR SO CERTAINLY
BETTER THAN MINIMUM WAGE IN MANY
JURISDICTIONS BUT WE ASK
OURSELVES A VERY SERIOUS
QUESTION. HOW DO YOU ACTUALLY DO
RIGHT BY THESE POST MATES AND
ENSURE THAT THEY CAN MAINTAIN
THOSE HIGH WAGES AND THE PREMISE
OF THE IS QUITE SIMPLE? IF WE
USE THE POST MAKES PLATFORM
RIGHT NOW TO DELIVER TO THIS
BUILDING FROM THE STARBUCKS
ACROSS THE STREET. A POST MAKE
CAREER WOULD BRING IT TO US BUT
FINANCIALLY SINCE WE KNOW IT'S
JUST A FEW BLOCKS AWAY IT'S NOT
THAT ADVANTAGEOUS TO THEM SO WE
WOULD STARTED OUR
EXPERIMENTATION WITH AN A I
DRIVEN ROBOTIC SYSTEM. BECAUSE
WE WANTED TO KNOW HOW DO YOU
ENSURE THAT YOUR RESERVING OUR
HUMAN CAREERS FOR LONGER
DISTANCE RUNS SO THAT WAY THEY
CAN MAKE MORE MONEY OFF THE
PLATFORM. NOT SHORT CHANGE THEM
AT HYPER SHORT DISTANCE RUNS BUT
AT THE SAME TIME NOT PENALIZE
THAT COFFEE SHOP OR THAT
MERCHANT THAT'S CLOSE IN TO YOU
OR NEARBY DENSE DOWNTOWN URBAN
AREA.
AND THAT PREMISE.
WAS TOPPLED INITIALLY WITH THE
USE OF ROBOTICS WE STARTED IN
THE DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA WE'VE
EXPANDED IN VIRGINIA WISCONSIN
PARTS OF TEXAS PARTS OF THE BAY
AREA. AND WHAT WE TRY TO DO IS
ACTUALLY SEE CAN WE USE A LITTLE
COOLER ON WHEELS THAT USES THE
SAME SIMILAR LIGHT OUR
TECHNOLOGY IS NOT TAUGHT IN THIS
VEHICLE. AND IS SELF LEARNING SO
THAT WE CAN UNDERSTAND THE
OBJECTS AROUND IT THROUGH OUR
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE IN A AYE
CAPABILITIES
IT CAN HOW CAN IT MAKE SURE THAT
YOU CAN ACTUALLY LEARN ENOUGH SO
THAT WAY IT AVOIDS. A PEDESTRIAN
THAT MAYBE DISABLED AND ISN'T
USING A WALKING SICK OR IS IN A
WHEELCHAIR HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT IT ACTUALLY TO YIELD TO
TRAFFIC PATTERNS. AND ALSO NOT
CLOG PARTICULARLY DENSE REGIONS
I EAT THE SIDEWALKS OF SAN
FRANCISCO.
AND I THINK FOR US WE STARTED
APPLYING THIS TECHNOLOGY ONE OUT
OF THE PROMISE OF TRYING TO MAKE
SURE AS I MENTIONED BEFORE THAT
OUR CAREERS CAN BE RESERVED FOR
LONGER DISTANCE RUNS. BUT FROM
ANOTHER PERSPECTIVE IT'S THAT IF
YOU START WITH THAT EARLIER
POINT THE WAY COMMERCE INSISTS
IT IS MOVING IN CITIES IS
CHANGING THAT ALSO MEANS THAT
THERE ARE VERY UNIQUE URBAN
TOPOGRAPHIES IN EACH.
FIREMAN'S
SO WE'RE NOT GOING ABOUT THIS
PROMISE FOR THIS PRACTICE TO TRY
AND REPLACE OUR CAREERS
OVERNIGHT WERE ACTUALLY DOING SO
SIMPLY TO AUGMENT THAT EXIST
IF WE AND SEE HOW WE CAN BE
MINDFUL OF SUPER. SHORT
DISTANCES ALONG THE WAY.
ALL SAY THAT PER THE PURVIEW OF
THIS COMMITTEE IN THIS HEARING
WE'VE LEARNED A COUPLE OF
INSIGHTS
ONE WE WERE ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY
INTEGRATE THE ROBOTICS IN OUR
SUPPLY CHAIN STARTING IN THE
SEA.
WITHOUT IMPACTING A SINGLE HUMAN
JOB ON.
WE WERE ACTUALLY ABLE TO
RESERVE OUR CAREERS TO MAKE MORE
MONEY BECAUSE OF THIS
EXPERIMENT.
TO WE WERE ACTUALLY ABLE TO
DEPLOY FEWER CARS ON THE ROAD
VIA THE POST MAKES PLATFORM IN
SOME OF OUR SELECT TEST CITIES
SO WE'RE NOT GONNA HARP
TATTERSALL'S IN THE BACK AND SAY
THAT THIS MEANS CONGESTION IS
GOING AWAY OVERNIGHT. BUT WE'RE
TAKING INCREMENTAL STEPS TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THAT.
THREE WHEN IT CAME TO OUR
APPROACH OF DEPLOYING THESE IN
TOWNS WE TOOK A FUNDAMENTAL.
RESPECT FOR GOVERNMENT AND
PRIORITIZE THAT FIRST MEANING
THAT WE DO NOT OPERATE A GO TO
MARKET WITHOUT TALKING TO LOCAL
MAYOR'S OFFICES STATE
GOVERNMENT'S DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC WORKS DEPARTMENT OF TRADE
PETITIONS AND PART OF THAT
FRAMEWORK INSURED A DATA SHARE.
IN WHICH ANY DATA THAT WE WERE
GETTING OUT OF THE
EXPERIMENTATION INCLUDING ANY
GUIDELINES WE HAD AROUND PRIVACY
DISPOSAL IF THAT LIGHT OUR
TECHNOLOGY WAS MONITORING ARE
FILMING AROUND IT WE WOULD
ENSURE THE GOVERNMENT ON THEIR
TERMS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. THAT
WE WOULD COMPLY WITH THEIR
NEEDS.
AND IT ACTUALLY ALLOWED US TO
WORK WITH THE NEW JOB TYPES WE
NOTICED THAT VETERANS FROM THE
AIRFORCE AND THE NAVY
PARTICULARLY POST IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN THAT ARE
PARTICULARLY WELL SUITED FOR
ROBOTIC FLEET MANAGEMENT SON SAN
FRANCISCO WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH AN ORGANIZATION CALLED.
SOARED TO PLOWSHARES TO HIRE FOR
THIS SPECIFICALLY WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE MAYOR'S OFFICE
IS TO ENGAGE IN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM SO WE CAN TRAIN UP FOLKS
TO ENGAGE THIS FLEET OF
ROBOTICS.
BUT ULTIMATELY I'LL CONCLUDE
WITH THIS STATEMENT AND THAT IS
THAT WE KNOW THAT WHETHER YOU
TAKE OUR USE CASE OF A AYE OR
OTHER USE CASES OF A AYE THERE
ARE CHALLENGES AND AS WILL
CONTINUE TO HEAR. THEY'RE GOING
TO BE REAL CONCERNS ABOUT HOW TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE ARE
INCLUSIVE SYSTEMS NON BIASED
SYSTEMS AND SYSTEMS THAT WORK
FOR THE GROWTH OFHUMAN JOBS ALL
ALONG THE WAY. AND I KIND OF
JUST ONE ARRIVE AT THIS
COMMITTEE AND TO THE CHAIRMAN
WITH THE SIMPLE MESSAGE AS THE
LONE TECHNOLOGY COMPANY THAT
SHOWED UP FOR THIS CONVERSATION
TODAY. WE REALLY WANT TO WORK
WITH THE GOVERNMENT
WE ACTUALLY REALLY WANT TO WORK
WITH LABOR AND WE APPLAUD
ACTUALLY THE TEAMSTERS FOR
WORKING WITH ROBOTICS COMPANY IS
AN ICE. PACK SAN FRANCISCO CITY
HALL CONVERSATION WHERE THE CITY
TRIED TO BAN ROBOTICS WE WANT TO
WORK WITH LABOR TO MAKE SURE
THAT IF FOR TRAINING AND NEXT
GENERATION OR CURRENT
GENERATION.
OF HARDWARE MECHANICS AND THOSE
THAT DO NOT HAVE THESE FANCY
STANFORD COMPUTER SCIENCE DEGREE
THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY ABLE TO
ENGAGE THROUGH. VOCATIONAL
TRAINING ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAMS AND CONTINUOUS LEARNING
PROGRAMS THAT CERTAINLY EXTEND
BE ON THE STEM INVESTMENTS THAT
WE NEED TO MAKE IT AN EARLIER
STAGE LEVEL BUT CAN ALSO ACCOUNT
FOR LATER STAGE INVESTMENT.
AND FINALLY I THINK THAT IF WE
GIVE OURSELVES AND GIVE INDUSTRY
I HAVE BECOME A THE PITCH
THEY'VE WILL GIVE INDUSTRY THE
CHANCE TO EXPERIMENT AND WE USE
CITIES OR USE YOUR DISTRICTS ARE
YOU STATES. AS THE PETRI DISH OF
TESTING THEN THE MORE DATA THAT
WE GET THE MORE WE CAN SHARE
BACK OF THE GOVERNMENT.
THE MORE THAT WE TEST THESE
TOOLS THE MORE THAT A AYE WHICH
IS SELF LEARNING CAN ACTUALLY
ACCOUNT FOR STRUCTURAL BIASES
AND IMPROVE OVER TIME AND THE
MORE WE CAN UNDERSTAND WHERE
THERE ARE GAPS ARE THAT WE NEED
TO TACKLE TOGETHER. SO THERE'S A
LOT OF INVESTMENT THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN IN THIS SPACE TO TRULY
ACTUALIZE IT THERE'S A LOT OF
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT THAT WE AS
A TECH COMPANY WANT TO TAKE A
PARDON SO WE SUPPORT BILLS GOING
ON IN THIS. LEGISLATURE WHEN TO
COME SYSTEM INVESTMENT FOR
CONTINUOUS LEARNING INVESTMENTS
BUT WE ALSO WANT THE ROOM TO
TEST SO THAT WAY WE CAN BE
WORKING PARTNERS AS OPPOSE TO
SPARRING PARTNERS. CALIFORNIA
DOESN'T JUST COMPETE WITH OTHER
STATES.
WE CAN BE WITH THE REST THE
WORLD SO FRANKLY FOR US THIS IS
ALSO ABOUT THE COMPETITIVENESS
OF THE STATE THAT WE GET TO CALL
HOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
MESSAGE NEXT.
CAN WE GO TO MR ALL PAUL HOW DO
THEM THAT I SECRETLY.
DATA
PLAGUE. THAT MISTAKEN NUMBER
FOUND.
I THANK YOU VERY ME SO I
REPRESENT.
MIND STRONG HOW.
BY WAY BACKGROUND I'M A
COMPUTER SCIENTIST PHD AND MD
FROM STANFORD AND RESIDENTS AT
STANFORD.
AND I'M GONNA TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT.
HOW WE'RE FEELING A SHORTAGE OF
PURSES?
DISPLACING SERVICE WORKERS.
AT MY SON HELP WE'VE DEVELOPED
A WHEN THE BIG CHALLENGES MENTAL
HEALTH WERE DRESSING MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUE THERE'S A CABINET
JANET DISORDERS.
IN THE BIG CHALLENGE HAS BEEN
ACCESS AND MEASUREMENT.
SO IN MENTAL HEALTH TODAY OUR
STATISTICS ARE NOT IMPRESSIVE
ONE IN THREE PATIENTS WITH
SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS CAN BE
ADMITTED.
EVERY TWELVE MONTHS INTO THE
HOSPITAL.
WHEN INTO PETITIONS HE'S GOING
TO PATIENTS WITH A SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER AN OPIATE USE DISORDER
GARY ADMITTED EVERY TWELVE
MONTHS.
IT'S THAT THEY WERE IT WE'RE NOT
DOING VERY GOOD AT MANAGING A
WHAT'S BECOMING A CRISIS LUNCHES
HERE IN THIS COUNTRY BUT.
A GLOBAL CRISIS MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS IN WHAT WE'VE DEVELOPED
IN SMART IT'S. A AYE TRIP THEN
IT'S TAKEN SIX YEARS OF ARE
INDEED.
EXCEPT A A LOT OF INVESTMENT A
LOT OF TIME AND AND AND A LOT OF
SACRIFICE FROM BROUGH VERY
TALENTED TEAM. IS THE ABILITY TO
PASSIVELY ACQUIRED DATA FROM
PEOPLE SMARTPHONE THAT DIGITAL
HUMAN COMPUTER INTERACTION DATA
AND BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND AND
REPRODUCE GOLD STANDARD NO
COGNITIVE METRICS FOR FOR THESE
PATIENTS WE CAN NOW UNDERSTAND
HOW SOMEONE. IS FUNCTIONING
COGNITIVELY WE CAN UNDERSTAND
HOW THEY'RE DOING EMOTIONALLY
ARE IN THEIR ENVIRONMENTS WHERE
IT MATTERS MOST.
WHERE THERE POTENTIALLY SEE A
HAVING DIFFICULTY COPING
STRESSING?
AND WENT WHERE THINGS
ULTIMATELY WHERE.
IT WHEN WE THINK ABOUT BAD
OUTCOMES LIKE SUICIDE IT HAPPENS
YOU KNOW IT DOES THE DOES NOT
HAPPEN THE CLINIC IT HAPPENS AT
TWO IN THE MORNING SOMETIMES.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE DEVELOPED
AND THE OTHER ASPECT OF THIS IS
TO BE ABLE TO SOLVE NOT JUST THE
MEASUREMENT TOWNS BUT TO BE ABLE
TO SOLVE THE ACCESS PROBLEM THE
ACCESS PROBLEM TO HELP. ALICE'S
NIGHTS IS GOOD ENOUGH TO KNOW
THAT SOMEONE'S IN TROUBLE IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO
DELIVER HELP AND THE MOBILE
PHONE THE SMARTPHONE IS THE
PERFECT TOOL PERFECT DEVICE FOR
TELEHEALTH WE'VE DEVELOPED. A
MODEL OF INTERACTIVE HEALTH.
THAT TAKES BAD.
INITIAL SIGNAL AND DELIVERS
VERY QUICKLY A MIND STRONG A AYE
SOLUTION THAT INTERVENES USING.
NATURAL LANGUAGE INTERACTION
WITH A WITH A PERSON TO BE ABLE
TO UNDERSTAND THE SITUATION AND
TO BE ABLE TO QUICKLY ESCALATE A
SITUATION TO EIGHT ACT I CARE
PROVIDER. IF.
THAT IF IT'S URGENT AND.
NEEDS IT NEEDS IMMEDIATE
ATTENTION.
SO FROM THIS PERSPECTIVE WHAT WE
HAVE IS WE HAVE THE ABILITY NOW
TO.
CARE FOR A A VERY.
DIFFICULT A SET OF.
POPULATION.
THAT.
HAS BEEN LARGELY
DISENFRANCHISED.
AND.
WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT OUR
APPROACH AND WHAT WE'VE DONE IS
THAT MENTAL HEALTH IS NOT JUST A
FIRST WORLD PROBLEM IS A GLOBAL
PROBLEM AND WE HAVE NO SOLUTION
THAT NOT JUST. ADDRESSES MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES IN THIS COUNTRY
BUT POTENTIALLY GET THAT LEAK
PRODUCTS INFRASTRUCTURE AND CAN
ALLOW US TO ADDRESS A CHALLENGES
AND OTHER THIRD WORLD COUNTRIES
AS WELL.
SO THAT'S ON THE GOOD SIDE AND I
THINK IT'S ALL VERY EXCITING WE
pAN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF WORK WITH
SOME THE TOP.
UNIVERSITIES AND ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND WE DO THAT IN A PRO BONO.
MODEL WHERE WE DON'T WE DON'T
CHARGE THEM ANYTHING WE DO
ENORMOUS WANNA WORK WITH.
DRUG MANUFACTURERS.
TO IN ADOPTING A NEW DRUGS
TARGETED UP PHARMACEUTICALS.
AND THAT OUR LICENSE HERE
COMMERCIAL PLATFORM IN WE'RE
INVOLVED WITH SOME OF THIS
COUNTRY'S LARGEST PAIR PROVIDERS
SYSTEMS.
TO HELP ADDRESS THIS THIS
EXCITING USE OF A AYE I THINK.
YOU IT IT. IF THERE WERE A
POTENTIAL.
CONCERNED IT WOULD BE A AND
YEAH POTENTIAL MISUSE OF THIS
TYPE APPROACH AS YOU'RE THINKING
THROUGH THE THE YOUNG THE.
APPLICATIONS OPPORTUNITIES AND.
RISKS OF A AYE YEAH I WOULD SAY
THAT.
IT WOULD BE DIRECT TO CONSUMER
MODEL COULD COULD BE.
.
YOU WOULD WE GO DIRECTLY THROUGH
THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND IF
WE'RE LOOKING DIRECT CONSUMER
MODEL.
THERE MIGHT BE SOME CONCERNS IN
TERMS OF.
HOW PATIENT OR PERSON WOULD?
USES TECHNOLOGY.
AND POTENTIALLY AND MISUSES OF
THE OF THE ABILITY TO MEASURE A
COGNITION AND MOOD.
IN IN THE FORM OF NARROW NO
MARKETING AND OTHER SUCH
APPLICATIONS BUT I THINK THAT.
IN IN IT FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
WE'RE VERY EXCITED.
WITH WHAT WE'VE DEVELOPED AND.
THE OPPORTUNITY AND HOPE THAT
WOULD BRING TO A LARGE POT.
SEGMENT OF POPULATION THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ES
NEXT SO CAN WE GO TO MISTER IMAD
KEIKO.
I THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DISCUSS SOME PRESSING ISSUES
IN POLICY CONSIDERATIONS RELATED
TO THE FIELD OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE.
MY NAME IS MAC HAGEL AND I AM A
TECHNOLOGY AND CIVIL LIBERTIES
ATTORNEY AT THE ACLU OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND BASINS ARE CISCO.
SO SO MUCH MY WORK FOCUSES ON
ENSURING THAT MODERN DIGITAL
SYSTEMS.
WHETHER THEY BE PRIVATE
PLATFORMS ARE PUBLIC PROJECTS
ARE PUBLICLY DEBATED AND
IMPLEMENTED WITH EQUALITY AND
JUSTICE AND MINE.
SO WITH THAT IN MIND.
I WANNA TALK MORE BIG PICTURE
ABOUT A AYE. SO YOU MAY ALREADY
BE FAMILIAR WITH A AYE POWERED
AYE VOICE ASSISTANCE AND STORIES
DESCRIBING HOW A AYE IS GOING TO
BRING ABOUT SELF DRIVING CARS.
AYE BUT ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
WITH ITS POWER TO FIND PATTERNS
IN LARGE DATA SETS.
AND TO AUTOMATE DECISIONS
PREVIOUSLY LEFT.
TO HUMANS IS POISED A
FUNDAMENTALLY TRANSFORM THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN PEOPLES
PEOPLE AND THEIR GOVERNMENTS.
I'LL A AYE POWER SYSTEMS THAT
FOR IT FACILITATE PERVASIVE
SURVEILLANCE AND INFLUENCE
CONSEQUENTIAL ON PERSONAL
DECISIONS.
ESPECIALLY WHEN DEPLOYED WITHOUT
ADEQUATE SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE
RAISE THE RISK.
CRADLE TO GRAVE TRACKING. THAT
IS INCONSISTENT WITH CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS OF FREE
SPEECH AND PRIVACY.
IN THESE EFFORTS APPLICATIONS A
AYE IS EXACTLY THE TYPE OF QUOTE
MODERNS THREAT TO PERSONAL
PRIVACY. THAT ARTICLE ONE
SECTION ONE OF OUR CONSTITUTION
WAS INTENDED TO ADDRESS.
BASIC DUE PROCESS AND FAIRNESS
IS ALSO UNDERMINED WHEN
SIGNIFICANT DECISIONS AFFECTING
OUR LIVES SUCH AS WHERE PUBLIC
RESOURCES ARE DEPLOYED OR
WHETHER AN OFFICER. CONFRONTS A
PERSON WITH DEADLY FORCE ARE
INFLUENCED BY PROPRIETARY
SYSTEMS RUNNING SECRET
ALGORITHMS ANALYZING POTENTIALLY
BIAS DATA.
AND WITHOUT RULES IN PLACE TO
PREVENT ABUSE.
SO THE STAKES FOR A AYE SYSTEMS
ARE PARTICULARLY HIGH ESPECIALLY
IN RIGHT AND IN THE CURRENT
POLITICAL AND SOCIAL CLIMATE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
RUSHING TO EXPLOIT AUTOMATED
SYSTEMS AT LOCAL LEVEL IN
VIOLATION OF THIS LEGISLATURE'S
COMMITMENT TO PROTECT IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES.
THEY WANT YOU SEE SYSTEMS TO
TRACK TARGET AND THE POOR
VULNERABLE COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
WE MUST NOT LET THIS HAPPEN.
WE ARE ENCOURAGED THAT THIS
COMMITTEE IS THOUGHTFULLY
EXPLORING A TODAY AND AND HOW WE
CAN SAFEGUARD THE RIGHTS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
SO ADDRESSING POLICY ISSUES
RELATED CA I. AND ITS USE IN THE
GOVERNMENT CONTEXT IS CRITICAL
BECAUSE A AYE IS ALREADY
POWERING SURVEILLANCE
TECHNOLOGIES HEARING CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING SOFTWARE THAT SCOURS
BILLIONS OF SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS
BIOMETRIC SYSTEMS THAT SCAN
PEOPLE'S FACES AND EYES LIKE A
SCENE FROM MINORITY REPORT.
AND LICENSE PLATE READERS THAT
TRACK ARE DRIVING PATTERNS.
AND FEDERAL AGENCIES AS A SAID
BEFORE SUCH AS ICE ARE MOVING
RAPIDLY TO CONSCRIPT CALIFORNIA
SYSTEMS FOR THE ADMINISTRATION'S
DEPORTATION MACHINE.
SOCIAL MEDIA SURROUNDS IS JUST
ONE EXAMPLE IN TWENTIES IN A
TWENTY SIXTEEN PUBLIC RECORDS
VESTED ASIAN. THE ACLU RIVER
DISCOVERED THAT MORE THAN ONE
THIRD OF SURVEYED CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT WERE USING AUTOMATED
SOCIAL MEDIA SURVEILLANCE
SOFTWARE.
THESE TOOLS ARE SPECIFICALLY
MARTIC MARKETED TO CALIFORNIA
AGENCIES
FOR PURPOSES OF MONITORING.
AND TARGETING UNIONS.
ACTIVISTS OF COLOR SO SHE WOULD
LIKEWISE MATTER AND PROTESTERS
CHARACTERIZING THEM AS OVERT
THREATS.
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN SOCIAL MEDIA
SURVEILLANCE MISUSED.
IN SAN JOSE WE LEARNED THAT
POLICE MONITORED ASIAN.
.
MUSLIM AND SIKH PROTESTERS.
IN FRESNO POLICE CALLED USED A
PRODUCT CALLED BEWARE THAT
ASSIGN COLOR THREAT LEVELS TO
RESIDENTS BASED ON SOCIAL MEDIA
POSTS.
AND BILLIONS OF OTHER COMMERCIAL
RECORDS.
OFFICERS RESPONDING TO INCIDENTS
WILL BE SHOWN CONCLUSIONS DRAWN
BY SECRET ALGORITHMS.
WHEN ONE CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
FOUND HIMSELF FLAG IS AN
ELEVATED THREAT HE HAD NO WAY TO
DETERMINE THE BASIS FOR THAT
DECISION.
THERE WERE NO RULES GOVERNING
THE USE THAT SYSTEM.
THIS LACK OF TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WAS NOT UNIQUE TO
FRESNO SOCIAL MEDIA EXPERIMENT.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF SOCIAL OF
CALIFORNIA LOOK COUNTIES THAT WE
SURVEYED. COULD NOT PRODUCE A
SINGLE RECORD OF PUBLIC DEBATE.
OR WRITTEN POLICIES TO PREVENT
DISCRIMINATORY TARGETING.
NEITHER COMMUNITY MEMBERS NOR
LAWMAKERS HAVE ANY WAY TO KNOW
HOW THE SYSTEMS ACTUALLY WORK.
NOW THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS
ANNOUNCED HIS INTENT TO USE
SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS.
TO CONTINUOUSLY MONITOR
IMMIGRANTS VIA PROGRAM KNOWN AS
THE QUOTE EXTREME THAT
INITIATIVE.
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES HAVE ALSO PILOTED
ADVANCED A AYE POWERED FACIAL
AND IRIS RECOGNITION SO
SURVEILLANCE.
THESE SYSTEMS AUTOMATE THE
PERVASIVE TRACKING OF
INDIVIDUALS AT PROTESTS.
AND INCORPORATE ALARMINGNOTIONS
OF WHO SHOULD BE DEEMED
SUSPICIOUS.
SINCE AT LEAST TWENTY FIFTEEN
SAN BERNARDINO RIVERSIDE AND LOS
ANGELES COUNTIES HAVE USE THAT
TECHNOLOGY FIRST DEPLOYED.
BY US FORCES IN IRAQ. TO
COLLECT IRIS PHOTOS FROM
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS.
COUNTY SHERIFF'S ALONG THE US
MEXICO BORDER HAVE ANNOUNCED A
PLANS TO DO THE SAME.
FISH OVER CAN'T FIGURE FISHER
RECOGNITION ON THE OTHER HAND IS
NOW POWERFUL ENOUGH TO TRACK
PEOPLE IN REAL TIME.
ENGAGING INPROTECTED SPEECH AT
PROTESTS ARE GOING ABOUT THEIR
DAILY LIVES ALL WITHOUT THEIR
KNOWLEDGE.
SOME OF THESE COMPANIES CLAIM
THAT THEY CAN ESTIMATE
DEMOGRAPHICS AND PREDICT VIOLENT
BEHAVIOR SOLELY BASED ON A PHOTO
OF A FACE.
THESE OUTLANDISH CLAIMS INVITE
POLICE TO MAKE A LIFE FOR DEATH
DECISIONS BASED ON LEGALLY
PROTECTED CHARACTERISTICS. AND
UNVERIFIED PSEUDOSCIENCE.
AND RIGHT NOW IT'S I. SUGGESTED
BEFORE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
AGGRESSIVELY IN ITS CAMPAIGN TO
TARGET
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES.
JUST LAST MONTH I STRUCK A DEAL
WITH A NATIONWIDE AYE I STRUCK A
DEAL WITH A LICENSE PLATE READER
COMPANY CALLED VIGILANT TO GET
ACCESS TO A NATIONWIDE LICENSE
PLATE DATABASE.
FEATURING THE LOCATIONS OF
DRIVERS COLLECTED BY THE VENDORS
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT CUSTOMERS.
IN CALIFORNIA WE KNOW THAT.
AN ESTIMATED HUNT ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY.
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
USE VIGILANT SYSTEMS IN SOME
FORM.
LICENSE PLATE SYSTEMS ARE
ALREADY RIGHT FOR ABUSE
POLICE IN NEW YORK HAVE USE
LICENSE PLATE READERS TO SPY A
MUSLIM AMERICANS AND MOSQUES.
AND BLIND RELIANCE ON THESE
READERS IN SAN FRANCISCO LED TO
A AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN BEING
DETAINED AT GUNPOINT. WHICH
TRIGGERED A MULTI YEAR CIVIL
RIGHTS LAWSUIT.
I SEARCHING FOR PLATE NUMBERS IN
THIS DATABASE ICE INTENDS TO
TRACK AND TARGET CALIFORNIANS
WHO RELY ON THEIR CARS TO DRIVE
TO WORK.
TO RUN ERRANDS AND TO TAKE KIDS
TO SCHOOL.
SO A AYE IS HERE ALREADY.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES LACK
THE MECHANISMS TO ASK THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS OR TO FOLLOW A
CONSISTENT PROCEDURE TO ENSURE
MEANINGFUL PROTECTIONS ARE IN
PLACE FOR RESIDENTS.
WE'RE YOU KNOW THAT LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
TO PLACE SURVEILLANCE SYSTEMS
WITH LITTLE TO NO TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY OR OVERSIGHT. OUR
STATEWIDE.
REVIEW IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
UNCOVERED EVIDENCE OF PUBLIC
DEBATE. A PROCEEDING
ACQUISITIONS OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES FOR ONLY FIFTEEN
PERCENT OF THE ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY PROGRAMS WE SURVEYED.
WE FOUND A PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
USE POLICY FOR FEWER THAN ONE IN
FIVE THESE PROGRAMS. AND MANY OF
THESE POLICIES AMENITIES
PROGRAMS HAD NO POLICY
WHATSOEVER.
CALIFORNIA VOTERS WANT CHANGE
THERE IS WIDESPREAD SUPPORT FOR
LAWMAKERS TO DEVELOP ENFORCEABLE
STATE AND LOCAL LIMITS.
ON SURVEILLANCE CHECK NOT
TECHNOLOGY AND TO REQUIRE LOCAL
APPROVAL AND A VOTE BEFORE USE.
SIXTY FOUR PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIANS WANT CITYWIDE
POLICIES TO SET LIMITS ON
SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGY. USED BY
POLICE ACCORDING TO TWENTY
FIFTEEN POLL.
WE KNOW THAT WITHOUT PUBLIC
DEBATE AREN'T OR ENFORCEABLE
RULES COMMUNITIES WILL PURCHASE
EXPENSIVE AUTOMATED SYSTEMS.
I DO MORE HARM THAN GOOD.
THAT FEE DATABASE IS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL SEEK TO EXPLOIT.
AND THAT CAN UNDERMINE DUE
PROCESS BY PLACING THE BASIS FOR
DECISIONS BEHIND SECRET
ALGORITHMS.
CALIFORNIA CANNOT AFFORD TO
BLINDLY RELY ON A AYE SYSTEMS.
WHICH MEAN THAT POWER IN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S DEPORTATION
MISSION OR WHOSE DECISIONS MAYBE
FLAT OUT WRONG BECAUSE OF BIAS
DATA OR HUMAN ERROR.
SO NOW'S THE TIME TO ENSURE THAT
THE SYSTEMS THAT ARE BUILT ON
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE ARE
TRANSPARENT AND SUBJECTED TO
MEANINGFUL PUBLIC DEBATE.
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU AND OTHER CALVET CALIFORNIA
LAWMAKERS TO ADDRESS THESE
IMPORTANT PRICING ISSUES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A.
LET'S NEXT GO TO MISTER JOHNSON
FILMING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEF
SHEESH.
WELCOME. THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
JOHN FELDMAN SAYS THAT
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION.
HERE BASICALLY DISAGREE WITH
EVERYTHING HAVE HIGH SCHOOL HE
SAID.
NO BUT I MEAN I'D SERIOUSLY I.
SO I GET I GET THE CONCERNS IN
THERE ARE TWO SIDES OF THIS
DEBATE THERE'S THE PRIVACY.
YOU KNOW GOVERNMENT INTRUSION
INTO PRIVATE LIVES SIDE WHERE
YOU KNOW IT'S ON THE FARTHEST
EDGE YOU KNOW IT'S ALL.
INTRUSIVE.
.
USING IT FOR NEFARIOUS PURPOSES
TO TRACK YOU DOWN.
KEEP TABS ON YOU FOR WHATEVER
REASONS THAT WE WANT OUTSIDE OF
YOU KNOW CRIMINAL OR.
INVESTIGATIVE PURPOSES.
BIT THAT ARE SO I MEAN AND ON
THE OTHER SIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
WE WOULD SAY THAT WE USE THE
TECHNOLOGY TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES.
WERE FACING INCREASING THREATS
AND WE SEE THESE THESE.
.
MASS EVENTS OF VIOLENCE.
IT EVERY SO OFTEN IT SEEMS LIKE
MORE AND MORE. AND THEN I'D KNOW
CHECKS US ALL OF THE CORE AND WE
TRY AND FIGURE OUT WHAT WE CAN
WE DO TO PREVENT IT AND
TECHNOLOGY IS A SOLUTION IT'S
GOING TO BE A.
SOME IT'S USEFUL TO SAVE A LOT
OF LIVES BUT THERE IS GONNA BE A
BALLOTS THAT'S GONNA HAVE TO BE
STRUCK BETWEEN OUR TWO SIDES.
ON WHERE'D WHERE'D IS.
PUBLIC INPUT.
.
ALLOW THE CITIZENS TO HAVE SOME
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT WE'RE
DOING AND WHERE TO GO TOO FAR TO
WEAR ALLOWS.
OFFENDERS AND PERPETRATORS.
.
AN ADVANTAGE AGAINST US
SO THAT'S THE DEBATE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A YOU KNOW
TECHNOLOGY IS ALREADY HERE IT'S
ALREADY. IT'S ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE BEING USED BY A
BUSINESS IS HEALTH COMPANIES.
WHEN OUR SOCCER.
CYBER DEFENSES LAW ENFORCEMENT.
.
THE PUBLIC HAS IT YOU KNOW WHERE
IT'S.
A.
SO IF YOU TALK ABOUT.
CONCERNS ABOUT IT YOU KNOW OUR
PERSONAL. LIVES BEING.
CONSTANTLY FOLLOWED CONSTANTLY
MONITORED AND IT'S IT'S ALREADY
HAPPENING IF IT'S NOT LAW
ENFORCEMENT ITS MARKETING
COMPANIES THAT.
YOUR FRIENDS POSTING PHOTOS OF
YOU EVERYWHERE YOU GO. MINUTES
IT'S THERE SO LET'S FIND A WAY
TO BALANCE THAT BETWEEN ALL OF
OUR INTERESTS.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GONNA TRYING
TO.
NOW WITH OUR INTERESTS.
ALWAYS BEEN PUBLIC SAFETY FIRST
AND FOREMOST.
SO QUICKLY CANADA I.
WHAT WE HAVE OUT NOW AND AND?
THEN I'LL TRY AND DRAW A LINE TO
WEAR COULD GO IN THE FUTURE YOU
KNOW FIRST THAT IS THE FIRST.
PUBLIC SAFETY BROADBAND NETWORK
THAT WE'RE DEVELOPING NATIONWIDE
IT'S CAN BE A NETWORK SOLELY A.
THE SOLE PURPOSE IS FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO HAVE.
FAST ACCESS TO INTERNET SERVICES
IN REMOTE AREAS.
CALIFORNIA JUST OPTED IN SO
WILL BE DEVELOPING IN HERE IN
THE STATE. AYE WE WANT THE FIGHT
FOR PRIORITY USE OF THE AIRWAVES
WITH OTHER.
.
PRIVATE COMPANIES ARE WHO ELSE.
I'M.
COULD BE INTERFERING SO THAT'S
CAN BE A GREAT THING.
ITS ITS MOBILE OVER CAN BE ABLE
TO CREATE HOTSPOTS IN SOME OF
THOSE RURAL AREAS OF CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS BEEN A HUGE ISSUE.
I'D SPECIALLY VIEW GET FAR UP
NORTH UP IN THE MOUNTAINS WITH
IS NOT A LOT OF SERVICES.
I'M SO EXCITED ABOUT THAT YOU
KNOW.
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS ALWAYS RELIED
ON EVIDENCE AND DATA COLLECTION
AND WE'VE GOT REALLY GOOD AT
COLLECTING MORE AND MORE DATA
BUT. PARSING THROUGH HIS BECOME
MORE AND MORE DIFFICULT THE MORE
WE COLLECT.
I MEAN THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS
OF HOURS OF BODY CAM FOOTAGE.
MILLIONS OF DATA POINTS ON.
.
FOR INVESTIGATIONS AND AND WHAT
NOT.
IT TAKES HOURS AND HOURS MAN
HOURS TO GO THROUGH COME THROUGH
AND FIND CONNECTIONS AND PUT
TOGETHER AND A LOT OF TIMES WERE
OPERATING MULTIPLE APPLICATIONS.
THAT WE HAVE TO USE.
I.
TO PUT IT ALL TOGETHER AND SO
HAVING A.
.
SOME.
ANALYTICAL HELP FROM ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE TO GO THROUGH THAT
COME THROUGH THAT FIND PATTERNS
I KNOW THAT IS GOING TO CONCERNS
ABOUT BIAS IN. WHAT THOSE
ANALYTICS ARE GONNA LOOK LIKE?
?
YOU NO BUT WE ARE OR BY SEEN FOR
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR IS WHAT WE'RE
GONNA BE TRYING TO DO.
WITHOUT DISCRIMINATING AGAINST
ANY ONE PARTICULAR GROUP AN ART
I KNOW THE BE EXAMPLES THAT ARE
GONNA CLEAR.
CLEARLY DEMONSTRATE THAT BY. YOU
KNOW SOMEONE STANDARDS BUT
THAT'S NEVER THE INTENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS A WHOLE.
OUTSIDE OF THE.
ANECDOTAL EXAMPLES IS IS
FOCUSED ON CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR
PROTECTING PUBLIC SAFETY THAT'S
WHAT WERE.
I MEAN PEOPLE RISK THEIR LIVES
FOR THEIR NIGHT OUT THERE THAT
YOU KNOW AND MASTER.
DOES SUBVERT ANYONE GROUP
ANOTHER.
.
SO HAVING THAT. ARTIFICIAL TIMES
TO HELP COME THROUGH THAT DATA.
IDENTIFY CRIMINAL PATTERNS.
IDENTIFY HOT SPOTS ON THIS CAN
BE INCREDIBLY HELPFUL FOR US.
YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT DRONES
ALIVE.
YOU KNOW THERE'S GONNA BE
PRETTY UBIQUITOUS.
AND SOCIETY IN GENERAL THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS I MEAN FOR EVERYTHING
FROM.
DELIVERY SERVICES OF GOODS THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT YOU CIVILIAN
ONLY GOT DRONES THAT CAN
AUTOMATICALLY DEPLOYED OUT THE
BACK OF THE SWAT VEHICLE. I YOU
KNOW FLY OVERHEAD SCOUT A SCENE
FOR US SO THAT WE KNOW WHAT
WE'RE WALKING INTO THAT'S GOING
TO SAVE LIVES.
A FIRE DEPARTMENTS AS WELL WITH
INFRARED.
.
THERMAL HEAT SENSORS THAT CAN
IDENTIFY WHERE THE HOT SPOTS THE
FIRE OR. AND THAT'S YOU KNOW.
THINGS THAT ARE BEING DEVELOPED
RIGHT NOW THE TECHNOLOGY IS
ALREADY OUT THERE IT'S ONLY
GONNA GET BETTER. I'M AND MORE
PREVALENT.
.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE DO HAVE SOME
FACIAL RECOGNITION SOFTWARE
THAT'S OUT THERE THAT'S A.
YOU KNOW IT'S JUST GONNA KEEP
GROWING AND GETTING BETTER.
.
YOU KNOW IT'S.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MUCH IS IS
BEING USED RIGHT NOW BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK IT'S A LOT WE DON'T
SEE A LOT OF IT.
.
BUT THAT'S GONNA CONTINUE TO GET
DEVELOPED OVER THE YEARS. SO I
YOU KNOW ALL.
I TALK TO A FEW CHEESE BEFORE
COMING TODAY TO TO TALK TO YOU
AND. WE KIND OF DISCUSSED SOME.
POTENTIAL SCENARIOS OF WHAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S GONNA LOOK LIKE IN
THE FUTURE THAT'S WHEN THE
QUESTIONS I ASKED EMANATE WE'VE
HAD THESE CONVERSATIONS.
SAW PAINT THIS PICTURE FOR YOU
GUYS.
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS CALLED TO A
SCENE.
.
WHICH IS BEEN IDENTIFIED BY AND.
FACIAL RECOGNITION SOFTWARE
THERE'S NOTICED A CRIME ALERTED
THE OFFICER THE OFFICER ARRIVES
IN A TON OF THIS VEHICLE.
BEFORE EXITING THE VEHICLE
DRONES LAUNCHED FROM THE VEHICLE
FLIES OVERHEAD IT READS
EVERYONE'S FACES IT FINDS OUT.
ARE THERE ANY WARRANTS ARE THE
ARMED.
DO THEY HAVE ANY PRIOR
CONVICTIONS ANY VIOLENT PAST.
AND I CAN READ HEART RATES TO
FIND OUT IS THIS PERSON STRESSED
BY THE ANGRY. ARE THEY.
.
SCARED OF READ THEIR FACIAL A
TEXT ACTUALLY FIND OUT YOU KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE MOTIONS ARE HOW
THEY'RE FEELING US THE OFFICES
CAN HAVE ALL THAT INFORMATION
BEFORE THEY EVEN GET OUT OF THE
VEHICLE.
A LITTLE PROTECT THE OFFICER.
YOU KNOW. NO MORE CHP OFFICERS
YOU KNOW WALKING UP TO A CAR
WINDOW IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT
DARK IN NOT KNOWING WHO'S INSIDE
THEY WILL KNOW.
.
AND THEY'LL BE ABLE ACT
ACCORDINGLY I MEAN WE'RE WORKING
ON DE ESCALATION TECHNIQUES OF
YOU KNOW SOMEONE STRESSED OUT
BEFORE YOU GET OUT THE CAR AND
GO AND TALK TO THEM. IF YOU KNOW
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE.
THEY'RE NOT ARMED THEY DON'T OF
ANY PRIORS YOU WILL HELP YOU.
ADJUST THAT SITUATION A DE
ESCALATED.
ON THE FLIP SIDE IF YOU THEY ARE
ARMED THEY ARE DANGEROUS THEY DO
HAVE A WARRANT. ON IT'S GONNA
PROTECT THE OFFICERS LIVES.
SO THAT'S KIND ALL WHERE WE'RE
HEADED.
.
YOU KNOW IT'S A.
NO WE ALL SEE THE MOVIES SKYNET.
TERMINATION ERA.
MINORITY REPORT I MEAN IT'S
IT'S.
NOT TOO FAR FETCHED THAT WE'RE
GONNA GET THERE IN OUR
LIFETIMES.
ASIDE I DO THINK WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO STAY VIGILANT CONTINUE
THESE DEBATES AND MAKE SURE THAT
YOU KNOW IT'S GONNA BE TOUGH JOB
FOR THE LEGISLATORS DRAW THAT
LINE.
I'VE WHERE PUBLIC SAFETY.
CONCERNS.
.
NOT OUT WAY PRIVACY CONCERNS
BUT.
OUR BALANCED WITH THEM.
HAVE ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GENTLEMEN WITHOUT. QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
I DO HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
THAT I ME ON EARLIER A DOCTOR
DEEGAN TALK LIVE AT ABOUT.
THE USE OF A AYE IN THE TOWN TO
DETECTION OF MENTAL. OF THE ONLY
MOTION OR COGNITION ON KIND OF.
RELATED.
.
BEHAVIOR SO TO SPEAK ANNA ANNA
YOU ALSO MENTION ABOUT THE.
YOU KNOW IT BEING USED ARE IN
THE.
PREDICTION OF SUICIDAL AT TIMES
SO I WAS JUST WONDERING HOW
SUCCESSFUL THAT THEY ARE THAT
PROJECT HAS BEEN IN AND WERE ARE
WE I MEAN OUR.
IN AND WE CAN WE CAN WE DEPLOY
THE USE OF THAT TECHNOLOGY YOU
KNOW TO EVEN A GREATER EXTENT.
A. IT IT'S BEEN A ASIDE FROM A
SUICIDE WHICH WE HAVE REAL
EXPORT BOY.
THE ABILITY TO TO TACTIC
COGNITION AND.
IMPACT OF.
EMOTION ON COGNITION THINGS
LIKE STRESS ANXIETY.
TRAUMA.
HEAD TRAUMA.
HAS BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE WE HAVE.
THE RECENT PAPERS COMING OUT IN
NATURE THAT DEMONSTRATES OUR
RESULTS AGAINST GOLD STANDARD
PASSED THE DIFFERENCE HERE SO WE
CAN NOW MEASURE THAT IS
ECOLOGICALLY. AND SOMEONE STATED
ENVIRONMENT HOW POSSIBLY
REMOTELY WITHOUT A PERSON HAVING
SOMEONE COME TO THE CLINIC AND
UNDERGO FOR OUR RURAL COGNITIVE
ASSESSMENT.
THE SAME GOES FOR.
MEASURING DEPRESSION ANXIETY.
HEY WE HAVE A NUMBER OF ACTIVE.
CLINICAL STUDIES.
WITH DRUG COMPANIES THAT ARE
USING ARE A POP FORM
COMMERCIALLY TO TRY TO IDENTIFY
BETTER.
DRUGS.
FOR THESE DISORDERS.
AND WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF US
SEVERAL QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAMS.
WITH.
SOME OF THE LARGEST.
IT APPEARS IN PRODUCTS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AND IN THE UK AND IN SINGAPORE
RIGHT NOW SO IT'S.
IT'S EARLY EARLY PHASE BY THINK
BY THE END OF THIS YEAR.
YOU'LL CERTAINLY BE READING.
WE HOPE ABOUT SOME OF THE
SUCCESSES BOTH ARE IN LARGE
SCALE.
PROJECTS HERE WITHIN THE U. S..
GOD I THINK YOU AND MR LIEBER
TALK LIVE IT ABOUT CYBER. ON AND
THE USE OF A AYE IN IN CYBER
WORLD ARM IS THERE ANY EVIDENCE
WHATSOEVER THAT HE I WAS BEING
USED BY. OTHER NATIONS STATE WHO
TO ARM.
ATTACK OUR ELECTION SYSTEM THAT
YOU COULD TELL.
I WOULD HAVE THAT INFORMATION.
.
UNFORTUNATELY.
I FINALLY MISTER FELDMAN YOU
TALK ABOUT THE PUBLIC SAFETY
BROADBAND NETWORK PRO PROJECT AT
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS JUST OPTED
IN. AYE HER LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT ALSO I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S BEING OPERATED
ON ARE BY EIGHTEEN THESE ARE THE
ONES THAT WE. SIT IN MOST
RECEIPTS HAVE OPTED AND IF IT'S
NOT CORRECT RIGHT SO IF YOU CAN
COME TO ELABORATE ON THAT A
LITTLE BIT SO WOOD. SO THAT
PROJECT IS BASICALLY OUR.
.
DRIVEN BY A AYE IS IS THAT NOT
WHAT IT IS OR WILL DO THAT TO.
IT THAT IS A PROGRAM IS USED TO
IDENTIFY HOT SPOTS AND AND A
CRIMINAL ACTIVITIES NOBODY'S OUT
HOW DID I WAS JUST A NETWORK
OKAY THAT'S JUST THIS THE
DEDICATED. BROADBAND NETWORK
THAT'S GONNA BE SOLELY USED BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT PUBLIC SAFETY SO
I PICKED SUSAN FIRE SO GIVES YOU
THE ABILITY TO SHARE INFORMATION
WITH OTHER STATES RIGHT NOW. IS
THAT HE ATTEND YEAH IT WILL BE A
TO BE NATIONWIDE WHEN IT SOLOMON
RUNNING.
BUT IT'S IT'S A DEDICATED HIGH
SPEED NETWORK FOR US
TO USE BUT THERE'S NO CONTENT OR
ANYTHING ON THAT JUST A NETWORK
THAT ALLOWS YOU TO
COMMUNICATION.
A CAPABILITY. OKAY I GOT OKAY
VERY GOOD WELL YOU THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS OR.
QUESTIONS I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL GENTLEMEN FOR SHARING YOUR
PERSPECTIVES.
AND I WILL BRING UP THE NEXT
PANEL.
THE FINAL PANEL FOR THE DATE IS
GOING TO HELP US EXAMINE
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES
THROUGH THE PUBLIC POLICY LANDS.
AND JOINING US AGAIN IS SO
PROFESSOR ROUGH HARGROVE.
AND ALSO WE HAVE SARA FLOCK SO
WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
A SEMANTIC CORBIN WITH PRIVACY
RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE IN THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION.
AND IN A ROW.
VICE PRESIDENT OF INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY AND LITIGATION ARE FROM
ADOBE. SO THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US OUR WELCOME LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
OF THE.
YEAH
.
ONE CHAIR SITUATED YOU MAY
PROCEED.
.
AND.
SINCE WE STARTED WITH THE
PROFESSOR GROWTH LAST TIME SO
LET'S MAYBE WE'LL GO WITH THAT.
SIT ON THIS THAT SERVE*
WITH A CALIFORNIA LABOR FOR
WHILE WE SEE. WITH IT MAKES
SENSE TO HAVE MISSED A PROFESSOR
GRAPH AGAIN TO START OFF.
ANY ANY. ANY SEQUENCE SURE LET'S
DO THAT.
ABSOLUTE PLEASE PLEASE DIFFERENT
TOPICS.
OKAY SO I. MADE MY HUMBLE
OPINION AS I SAID BEFORE
CALIFORNIA PASSED A LEAD.
PART OF THAT IS BECAUSE WE
BENEFIT FROM THE GROWTH OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE AND
AUTONOMOUS SYSTEMS PART OF THIS
IS BECAUSE THE TECHNOLOGIES WE
CREATE HERE SPREAD AROUND THE
WORLD.
PARTIALLY BASED ON OPEN SOURCE
AND WE BEAR SOME RESPONSIBILITY.
ABOUT HOW IT OF PANS OUT NOT
JUST IN CALIFORNIA BUT GLOBALLY.
.
IN ORDER TO.
GET OUR ARMS AROUND.
WHAT THE IMPLICATIONS ARE WE
NEED TO STUDY THE PROBLEMS MUCH
MORE CAREFULLY?
IF WE'RE LOOKING AT THE IMPACT
ON JOBS WE SINCERELY DON'T KNOW
TODAY WHAT THE JOBS OF THE
FUTURE ARE GOING TO BE.
WE HAVE LOTS OF CONSULTANCY
REPORTS THAT TELL US WHAT SOME
OF THE JOBS JOB CATEGORIES COULD
BE IN THE FUTURE BUT FRANKLY
THOSE ARE NOT NECESSARILY ONE
FOUR ONE. TEMPLATE JOBS THESE
ARE THOUGHTFUL.
PROVOCATIONS TO HELP US THINK
ABOUT SOME NEW FACETS OF JOBS SO
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE SHOULD
DO. IS TO ENGAGE IN A PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP.
HELP US UNDERSTAND BETTER WHAT
TYPES OF JOB SKILLS AND TASKS
COULD BE EMERGING.
RIGHT AND THIS PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP SHOULD CONSIST OF
NOTCHES BUSINESS PEOPLE AND
ENGINEERS BUT FRANKLY AND
APOLOGISTS
SOCIOLOGISTS.
DESIGN PROFESSIONALS WHO
UNDERSTAND ETHNIC GRAPHICS
HE COULD HAVE WHO CAN HELP US
EXERCISE SOME FORESIGHT ON THE
JOBS OF THE FUTURE.
.
I EIGHT TAKE A NOTE OF THE
COMMENT THAT WE HEARD FROM THE
THE GENTLEMAN.
FROM THE LABOR UNION.
THAT.
RETRAINING SCHEMES HAVE BEEN
FAULTY.
ARE THEY HAVE NOT BEEN A SUCCESS
WAS THEY SHOULD BE AND I WOULD
CERTAINLY CONCUR THAT IF IT
TAKES.
THREE YEARS TO RETRAIN FOR A NEW
JOB THAT MIGHT FRANKLY BE
OBSOLETE BY THE TIME THE
TRAINING ENDS.
AND THEN NOT BE MATCH FOR JOBS
IS A NON SEQUITUR.
SO WHAT DO WE DO ABOUT THIS
ONE OF THE THINGS ON A PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP PLATFORM.
THAT WE COULD ADD IS ACTUAL JOB
MATCHING.
WE'RE DOING THIS ALREADY ON
LINE.
AND IT'S NOT IDEAL IT'S NOT
PERFECT.
BUT THERE IS REALLY NO REASON
WHY WE COULDN'T PAIR INSIGHTS ON
THE JOBS OF THE FUTURE WITH SOME
INCENTIVE SYSTEMS FOR
CORPORATIONS. ARE. AND FOR
ACADEMICS TO JOINTLY DECIDE AND
DESIGN THESE JOBS AND THEN PLACE
PEOPLE INTO THEM.
RIGHT WE DO THIS ALREADY IN
OTHER AREAS OF LIFE.
WITNESS YOU KNOW MATCH DOT COM A
PARTNER SEARCH AT SUCH A THAT
WHY WOULD WOULD BE SO DIFFICULT
TO FIGURE OUT HOW SUITABLE
SOMEBODY IS FOR AN EXISTING. OR
NEW JOB PROFILE US THAT'S
ANOTHER IDEA.
.
THE.
THE KEY ELEMENT OF GETTING THE
DIFFERENT SIDES TO WORK TOGETHER
OF COURSE AS EVERYWHERE ELSE IN
LIFE IS INCENTIVES.
SO HOW DO WE INCENTIVIZE
CORPORATIONS TO.
TO.
PLAY THEIR PART IN THIS.
A NUMBER ONE OF COURSE
STRATEGICALLY NO CORPORATE
EXECUTIVE.
IS INTERESTED IN HAVING PUBLIC
OPINION TURNED AGAINST THEM WHEN
JOBS GET LOST WHEN PEOPLE HAVE
TO LAY OFF BE LAID OFF SO THAT'S
NUMBER ONE BUT WE NEED TO GET
MUCH MORE CONCRETE AND HANDS ON
TACTICAL ABOUT THIS IN MY HUMBLE
OPINION.
THE I. WITHOUT WANTING TO BECOME
TOO POLITICAL HERE BUT THE
RECENT.
TAX BILL THAT PASSED.
DOES FRANKLY NOTHING TO ENSURE
THAT CORPORATION SPEND SOME OF
THAT MONEY TO DESIGN THE JOBS OF
THE FUTURE AND PUT PEOPLE INTO
THEM THERE ARE SOME
CORPORATIONS.
THAT ARE GOOD AT THINKING ABOUT
THE FUTURE.
BUT MOST ARE FRANKLY MUCH TOO
PREOCCUPIED WITH SHORTER TERM
GOALS AND RIGHTLY SO.
IN ORDER TO DEVOTE MUCH ENERGY
AND RESOURCES TO THESE JOB
DESIGNS THAT MAY NOT A BECOME
RELEVANT.
NEXT YEAR OR THE YEAR AFTER BUT
RATHER FIVE SIX SEVEN YEARS OUT
SO WHY NOT DEVELOP A TAX
INCENTIVE SCHEME.
THAT SAYS HERE ARE SOME
ADDITIONAL TAX CREDITS OR OTHER
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES.
THAT WILL KICK IN WHEN YOU
PARTICIPATE IN THESE JOB DESIGN
PLATFORMS AND WHEN YOU HELP US
PUT PEOPLE INTO THOSE JOBS.
S. SO I THINK THAT WOULD BE THAT
WOULD BE ANOTHER.
SUGGESTION HERE TO GET QUITE
CONCRETE.
ABOUT THIS.
NEXT.
I WOULD SAY THAT WE HAVE TO.
MAKE SURE THAT DATA WHICH IS
REALLY THE CURRENCY OF POWER.
.
A GETS.
DEMOCRATIZED.
AND THERE ARE TWO THINGS THAT WE
CAN DO.
NUMBER ONE IS WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE OPEN DATA
PLATFORMS.
WHERE?
CONSUMERS CAN CHOOSE TO DEPOSIT
THEIR DATA POSSIBLY BECOME
CONCEITED BY THOSE WHO WANT TO
MAKE USE OF THE DATA.
BUT I THINK IT IS
UNCONSCIONABLE TO HAVE SIX LARGE
CORPORATIONS AROUND THE WORLD
OWN ALL THE DATA.
SO WE WE HAVE TO PUT SOME
THINKING INTO OPEN DATA
PLATFORMS.
EQUALLY THEN WE HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT HOW TO GIVE DATA OWNERSHIP
TO INDIVIDUALS.
I MAY WANT TO GIVE UP MY DATA IN
ORDER TO GET CONVENIENCE'S
SERVICES EXPERIENCES PRODUCTS.
BOB BUT I SHOULD HAVE OWNERSHIP
OVER THAT AND I SHOULD DETERMINE
WHETHER AT ANY GIVEN POINT IN
TIME I WANT TO GIVE UP OWNERSHIP
OVER THAT DATA I WANT TO GIVE
UP.
PRIVACY.
S. MAYBE EVEN AGENCY
AND THAT IS A DEAL THAT MOST OF
US A CAN MAKE I DO THINK WE HAVE
TO BE VERY PROTECTIVE OF
CHILDREN IN THIS AREA. AND WITH
CHILDREN I WOULD SAY ANYBODY
UNDER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN.
BECAUSE.
MANY. MANY YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE
NOT HAD ENOUGH LIFE EXPERIENCE
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT CAN HAPPEN
WHEN DATA GETS MIS USE.
I WILL TELL YOU BEING A
PROFESSOR IN A TEACHER OF LOTS
OF YOUNG PEOPLE MILLENNIALS IN
PARTICULAR.
BUT THEY ARE VERY AWARE OF THIS
AND THAT THEY ARE VERY VESTED IN
A SOLUTION IN FACT I JUST. GOT
DONE TEACHING A COURSE OF
BUSINESS IN GLOBAL SOCIETY IN
WHICH STUDENTS WERE ASKED TO
DESIGN ARE A AYE SYSTEMS THAT
COULD MAKE SOCIETAL UP PROBLEMS
GO AWAY AND MAKE SOCIETAL
SYSTEMS MORE. ARE RESILIENT AND
ANTI FRAGILE AND.
THEY ARE INCREDIBLY MOTIVATED
TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION BUT
WE DO HAVE TO TARGET THEIR
PARTICULAR NEEDS.
ARE SO THAT'S A THAT'S A STEP
NUMBER FOUR FIVE.
.
I THINK PRIVACY DOES WARRANT
SOME POLICY AND REGULATORY
APPROACH BUT I WOULD WARN
AGAINST.
JUST MIMICKING THE EUROPEAN
GENERAL DATA PROTECTION
DIRECTIVE AS I HAVE SAID BEFORE.
I DO BELIEVE THAT.
A MOST PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD
SHARE THE INTENT.
BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT IT IS TOO
BROAD AND IT WILL STIFLE
INNOVATION.
AND.
THE PROBLEM OF COURSE WITH
EUROPE IS THAT IT IS VERY
PROTECTIVE.
AND VERY OF. HAVE SECURE FOR
INDIVIDUALS BUT IT LACKS DIGITAL
INNOVATION POWER.
THAT IS SOMETHING WE HAVE AND
WE NEED TO MAINTAIN SOME WE DO
NEED TO PUT OUR HEADS TOGETHER
WITH THE EUROPEANS.
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN IN A BETTER
WAY.
I I WOULD HIGHLIGHTS HERE THAT
GERMANY IN THE NORDIC COUNTRIES
ARE A STEP AHEAD WHEN IT COMES
TO INTEGRATION OF LABOR AND
DIGITAL TOOLS LIKE ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND ROBOTICS. AND I
WOULD URGE US TO STRIKE THE
BRIDGE.
AND.
DEVELOP A JOINT INITIATIVE TO
FIGURE OUT. HOW WE CAN JOINTLY
FACILITATE LABOR AND WORK IN
GENERAL? AS I SAID BEFORE I'M
PART OF A BERKELEY INITIATIVE
CALLED WORKING LEARNING EARNING.
IN THE ERA OF INTELLIGENT TOOLS
AND SYSTEMS.
WAITS FOR SHORT LONG LONG TITLE.
INCOME BUT I THINK VERY
MEANINGFUL WORK.
BECAUSE WE FEEL THAT THERE
THERE IS A NEW ERA DAWNING HERE
WHICH IS THAT THE ERA OF THE.
LIFETIME JOB. AT THAT KEEPS YOU
EMPLOYED FOR FORTY HOURS PLUS A
WEEK.
IS ESSENTIALLY COMING TO AN END
WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK AT.
THE DEVELOPMENTS IN THE
CONTRACTING AREA.
OUR JOBS ARE GETTING
DEFRAGMENTER. BY DIGITAL
PLATFORMS SO THEN HOW DO WE HOW
DO WE WORK THAT INVOLVEMENT HOW
TO LEARN HOW WE ARE. AND CREATE
ENOUGH STABILITY SO PEOPLE FEEL
COMFORTABLE HAVING FAMILIES
ENGAGING IN PARTNERSHIPS BUYING
PROPERTY ALL THE THINGS THAT
THAT MAKE SOCIETY MORE STABLE
AND MORE WORTH WHILE LIVING IN.
NOT SO WERE SO.
I WOULD SAY WE SHOULD DO SOME
INTERNATIONAL ARE PARTNERING AND
BEST PRACTICE SHARING THEIR.
LASTLY I WOULD MENTION TWO
THINGS I THINK WE HAVE TO MAKE
THIS PROCESS PUBLIC.
LIKE I SAID BEFORE I DON'T THINK
WE CAN LEAVE IT TO JUST
ENTREPRENEURS AND SCIENTISTS.
AND I WORK WITH BOTH
AND.
THESE A VERY CONSCIENTIOUS
PEOPLE HAVE THE BEST INTENTIONS
IN FACT AS A GOOD FRIEND OF MINE
SAYS WHEN YOU GO INTO A COMPUTER
SCIENCE.
TODAY OTHERS ALMOST MORE
INTEREST IN A STUDYING OVERALL
SOCIAL JUSTICE.
THAN THERE IS IN STUDYING HOW
TO CODE.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE.
MOST COMPUTER SCIENTISTS ARE
BECOMING VERY AWARE THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT THEY
DON'T WANNA BE PART OF THE
PROBLEM THEY WANT TO BE PART OF
THE CITY.
RIGHT.
AND SO.
SO WE HAVE TO MAKE THIS PUBLIC
ENGAGE THE PUBLIC GET THE
COMPUTER SCIENTISTS.
THE.
PHILOSOPHERS THE
ANTHROPOLOGISTS
GET BUSINESS PEOPLE
ENTREPRENEURS POLICYMAKERS AND
THE MEDIA TOGETHER IN ONE ROOM.
I THINK THERE IS ROOM FOR A
MULTI STAKEHOLDER QUOTE UNQUOTE
CONGRESS. WE SORT OF.
TENTATIVELY DUBBED IT A
CAMBRIAN CONGRESS WHY CAMBRIAN
BECAUSE OF THE CAMBRIAN
EXPLOSION OF LIFE.
I AM A TECHNO OPTIMIST I DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY DAWNING HERE BUT WE
CAN'T HARNESS IT WITHOUT A
PUBLIC DIALOGUE SO WE HAVE TO BE
PARTICIPATORY. IDEALLY MAYBE IN
A STAGE TO EVEN CROSS BORDER.
BECAUSE THE THINGS THAT TO
HAPPEN IN CHINA AND ELSEWHERE
AROUND THE WORLD COME HERE. AND
VICE VERSA.
AND THAT KIND OF CONGRESS
SHOULD DEVELOP SOME KIND OF.
FORUM THAT DISCUSSES A CODE OF
CONDUCT.
AND THESE WILL NECESSARILY BE
VERY HIGH LEVEL RULES.
AND THESE WILL BE VOLUNTARY.
BUT I THINK PREMIUM.
BRAND EQUITY AS IT WERE AND
PREMIUM RELATIONSHIP EQUITY WILL
BE GIVEN TO THOSE PEOPLE IN
THOSE CORPORATIONS WHO SIGNED ON
TO THIS KIND OF DIALOGUE INTO
THIS KIND OF. A CODE OF CONDUCT.
THAT LEAVES OUT SOME GENERAL
PRINCIPLES ON WHAT KIND OF
VALUES WE ALL SHARE.
WHAT THAT WILL BE WE DON'T KNOW
AND THE DIALOGUE WILL SURFACE
THAT BUT I THINK JUST HAVING THE
DIALOGUE WILL BE IMMENSELY
POWERFUL? I'D LIKE TO CLOSE
MAYBE WITH THE COMMENT ON
EDUCATION.
I THINK PART OF MY.
COMMENTS ON A.
JOBS OF THE FUTURE THINK TANK
DASH JOB BROKERING PLATFORM IDEA
IS THE THE.
THE UNDERLYING PRINCIPLE THAT
WE NEED TO NOW.
START TO COACH.
FRANKLY ALL OF US BUT MOSTLY.
OR MOST IMPORTANTLY THOSE
PEOPLE THAT ARE THREATENED MORE
NEAR TERM. IN A COMBINATION OF
HARD AND SOFT SKILLS.
SO DATA SIGNS IS PREEMINENTLY
IMPORTANT AND I'M A BIG FAN OUT
OF OF MAKING THIS.
ACHE REQUIREMENTS TO A
CALIFORNIA STATE SCHOOLS.
AND.
AND THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
HOWEVER BASIC CODING SKILLS
CAN'T BE THE GOAL.
FRANKLY I JUST GOT BACK FROM
INDIA AND IN INDIA MANY PEOPLE
ARE NOW AFRAID FOR THEIR THIRTY
MILLION CODERS.
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT DEVELOPING
MACHINES THAT WILL DO BASIC
CODING THEMSELVES.
AND SO.
SO OBVIOUSLY WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THE SOPHISTICATED.
STANFORD OR BERKELEY PHD IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A LOWER ELEVEN CORE LOW
LEVEL CODING SKILLS IT'S NOT
THAT.
TODAY'S KIDS SHOULDN'T PUT THEIR
HANDS ON THE KEYBOARD TOOK TO
LEARN WHAT THAT'S LIKE BUT I
THINK IT'S MORE IMPORTANT TO
TEACH THEM HOW TO CRITICALLY
THINK ABOUT WHAT.
DATA SCIENCE DOES.
WHETHER IT IS IN FACT REAL
SCIENCE.
OR WHETHER IT'S JUST ENGINEERING
OF SOLUTIONS THAT ARE DRIVEN BY
CERTAIN INCENTIVES.
AND TO DEVELOP CRITICAL
THINKING AND ANALYSIS SKILLS
WHEN IT COMES TO COMPUTING
POWER.
S. SUCH AS ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE
IN COMBINATION WITH THAT.
I WOULD SAY CONVERSELY WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT COMPUTER
SCIENTISTS.
FRANKLY ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
BUT ESPECIALLY IN CALIFORNIA GET
ETHICS TRAINING.
AND I KNOW THAT MOST OF THEM
ALREADY FOR THIS AND THEY WANT
IT.
BY DE YOU KNOW UNFORTUNATELY.
ACROSS ACADEMIA SOME OF THE
STOVE PIPES AS IN MANY OTHER
AREAS IN LIFE DON'T TALK TO EACH
OTHER.
SO WE NEED TO GET THE
ANTHROPOLOGIST THE PHILOSOPHERS
DE ETHICS CALLERS.
SCIENTIST TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO
WE TALK TO EACH OTHER AND WHAT
KIND OF PRINCIPLES DO WE NEED TO
TEACH EACH OTHER FOR SOME JOINT
UNDERSTANDING.
OF THE FUTURE OF COMPUTING AND
THAT THAT'S ALSO ETHICS DRIVEN
OR AT LEAST VALUES DRIVEN WHICH
SEEMS TO BE THE THE MORE NEUTRAL
TERM.
AND SO I THINK IT'S BOTH IT'S
HARD AND SOFT ITS STATE OF
SCIENCE AND IT'S ETHICS AND IT'S
ALL OF THE ABOVE.
THE HUMAN BEING SHOULD NOT BE
COMPETING WITH THE COMPUTER SO
LET'S NOT JUST TEACH PEOPLE HOW
TO BE LIKE A COMPUTER.
LET'S TEACH THEM HOW TO
INTEGRATE WITH THE COMPUTER HOW
TO PARTNER WITH THE COMPUTER BUT
HOW TO DIFFERENTIATE FROM THE
COMPUTER.
AND PART OF WHAT MAKES ME
DIFFERENT FROM A COMPUTER IS
THAT I DO HAVE.
THE EMOTING SKILLS THE EMPATHY
SKILLS THE IDEATION SKILLS THE
IMAGINATION SKILLS
THE THE SKILLS TO RELATE BASED
ON SHARED HUMAN EXPERIENCE THAT
GOES BACK MILLIONS OF YEARS OF
EVOLUTION.
THAT MACHINE STONE HALF.
AND WE NEED TO FRANKLY ALSO HELP
HUMANS AND THESE YOUNG CHILDREN
IN PARTICULAR. HOW TO EXERCISE
THAT MUSCLE?
NOT BE LIKE THE MACHINE TO
UNDERSTAND THE MACHINE TO
INTERPRET THE MACHINE TO USE THE
MACHINE. BUT FRANKLY TO BE THEY
HUMAN AND THAT PARTNERSHIP.
AND NOT TO BE JUST LIKE ANOTHER
MACHINE.
AND I WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU THAT
WE AREN'T GOOD ENOUGH.
JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE HUMAN
DOESN'T MEAN YOU'RE GOOD AT
BEING HUMAN.
RIGHT OR ELSE WE WOULDN'T HAVE
THAT MANY PSYCHOLOGISTS AND
LAWYERS RUNNING AROUND. AYE AND
SO WE WE WE NEED TO GET BETTER
AT THIS AND. THERE IS NO REASON
WHY WE CAN'T TEACH TRUCK
DRIVERS.
TO.
HAVE A MORE PEOPLE CENTRIC JOB
SO FOR THE TIME THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE SITTING IN THE TRUCK
WITH THE HANDS OFF THE WHEEL.
OR WHEN THEY ARRIVE AT THE
CUSTOMER SITE.
WHEN THEY TAKE THE TRUCK OVER
FROM SOMEBODY ELSE.
OR WHEN THEY'RE COMMUNICATING
IN TRAFFIC MAYBE TAKING OVER
TRUCKS AND INNER CITY TRAFFIC.
YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
UPSCALING WE CAN DO ON JUST THE
HUMAN AND SOCIAL SIDE.
RIGHT THERE FRANKLY ALL OF US
COULD USE A BIT MORE OF.
AND SO I THINK I THINK THERE IS
A LOT THAT WE CAN DO THERE.
ON THAT SKILL COMBINATION.
IF WE WE THINK EDUCATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MATCHA NEXT
SO LET'S GO TO A SERAPH LOCKS
WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
SARAH FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WE REPRESENT TWO
MILLION UNION MEMBERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA.
ALMOST EVERY SINGLE ONE OF WHICH
HAS BEEN TOUCHED BY TECHNOLOGY
OR ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE IN
SOME WAY ALREADY.
WHETHER IT'S CHANGES FROM.
REGULAR PHONES TO CELLPHONES
WHETHER IT'S CHANGES IN THE
MOVIE INDUSTRY WE'VE DEALT WITH
THESE KIND OF ISSUES.
AND I WANTED TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THAT THE
PARTICIPANTS HERE TODAY FOR
TACKLING SUCH.
A HUGE ISSUE.
THAT REALLY IS GOING TO TOUCH
ALL OF US IN SO MANY WAYS.
AND ESPECIALLY IN IN THE
WORKPLACE
AND AS I WAS TRYING TO THINK OF.
MY COMMENTS TODAY ON POLICY ON
THE CHALLENGES ON THE
OPPORTUNITIES IT SUCH A HUGE
TOPIC.
AND THE FUTURE. SEEMS VERY
UNKNOWN THERE'S MANY DIFFERENT
VISIONS OF IT WHETHER IT'S GOING
TO BE A ROBOT APOCALYPSE WAR
THERE'S MORE THE TECHNO
OPTIMISTS.
IT'S IT'S VERY HARD TO PREDICT
AND SO.
I WAS REALLY STRUCK WHEN MISTER
OBERNOLTE RAISE THE ISSUE OF
THEIR PRODUCTS.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT GOING BACK
IN HISTORY ACTUALLY HOLD SOME
VERY IMPORTANT LESSONS FOR US
TODAY.
BECAUSE I WOULD SAY THAT THAT
WAS A PUBLIC POLICY FAILED.
AND WE SHOULD LEARN FROM THE
MISTAKES THAT WERE MADE THAT.
SO THE LUDDITES EVEN THOUGH
THEY'VE GOTTEN A BAD RAP AT
BEING ANTI TECH TECHNOLOGY WERE
NOT THEY WERE SKILLED WEAVERS
THEY WERE ARTISANS.
THEY HAD GOOD PAYING JOBS AND
BEFORE BASICALLY THE INDUSTRIAL
REVOLUTION AND WHAT HAPPENED IS
GARMENT MAKERS BROUGHT IN THE
MACHINE LIAM.
WHICH IS PROBABLY THE EQUIVALENT
OF ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE.
IN AT THAT TIME.
AND THIS WAS SOMETHING WHERE
THEY COULD BE SILLY DE SKILL THE
WORKFORCE AND THE COULD PRODUCE
A LOT MORE GOODSA LOT MORE
TROUSERS AND MAKE A LOT MORE
MONEY.
AND PAY OF A LOT LESS
AND BASICALLY WHAT THE LUDDITES
SIDE IS.
WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO CONTROL
HOW THE LEAVES ARE USED WE THINK
THE LOOMS COULD BE USED TO MAKE
US MORE PRODUCTIVE TO MAKE WORK
SAFER WE DEPLORE MORE PEOPLE AND
SAID THEY THEY SAID WE HAVE
CERTAIN DEMANDS.
SLOW DOWN THE DEPLOYMENT OF THE
TECHNOLOGY CONSULT WITH US
ASK US WERE SKILLED WORKERS WE
MIGHT HAVE SOME IDEAS ON HOW
THIS COULD.
IT'S TECHNOLOGY COULD BE USED
BETTER WE NEED TO HAVE A WAY TO
MITIGATE THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS
WE NEED TO HAVE A SOCIAL SAFETY
NET WE NEED TO HAVE A TRANSITION
PLAN.
WE NEED ALL OF THIS AND SO THEY
WENT TO THE EMPLOYERS AND ASKED
FOR THIS AND. THE EMPLOYERS
BASICALLY SAID NO.
WE ARE GOING TO FIRE YOU ALL
WERE GOING TO BRING IN LOWER
SKILLED WORKERS THEY'RE GONNA BE
PAID LAST THEY'RE GONNA WORK
FASTER AND WE'RE GOING TO TURN
OUT WHAT WAS ACTUALLY NOT AS
GOOD OF A PRODUCT.
AND WHEN THEY'RE BASICALLY
WASN'T IMPASSE IN THEIR
DISCUSSIONS THE LUDDITES FINALLY
CAME TO THE POINT WHERE THEY
WERE GOING TO SMASH THE MACHINES
AND THE BRITISH GOVERNMENT CAME
IN. AND. BASICALLY PUT DOWN
THEIR UPRISING
BUT WHAT WAS THE CORE FOR THE
LIGHT AIDS WAS THAT THEY WEREN'T
ANTI TECHNOLOGY.
THEY WANTED TO HAVE A VOICE IN
THE WAY THAT TECHNOLOGY WAS
DEVELOPED.
THE WAIT WAS DEPLOYED IN THE
WORK FORCE AND THE WAY. THE
DISTRIBUTION OF.
FRUITS OF THAT THE WAY THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE BENEFITS OF
THAT TECHNOLOGY WERE
DISTRIBUTED.
MAYBE SO I WANTED TO SHARE OF
IT.
AND THEY FELT LIKE THEY AND
SOCIETY SHOULD HAVE A SHARE OF
IT.
DOT REBELLION WAS PUT DOWN AND
THEN WE MOVED ON TO THE
INDUSTRIAL REVOLUTION.
AND I THINK RIGHT NOW. THAT'S A
GOOD LESSON FOR US BECAUSE WE'RE
AT THE POINT WHERE WE ARE FACING
HUGE TECHNOLOGICAL CHANGES.
AND WE HAVE A CHOICE TO MAKE
BECAUSE TECHNOLOGY ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE WHATEVER IT IS IT'S
BASICALLY NEUTRAL.
IT'S NOT INHERENTLY GOOD ARE
INHERENTLY BAD.
AND IN FACT AS THE LABOR
MOVEMENT WE ACTUALLY THINK THAT
TECHNOLOGY ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AUTOMATION.
HAS ENORMOUS POTENTIAL WE THINK
IT HAS GREAT POTENTIAL TO MAKE
WORK SAFER TO MAKE IT MORE
INTERESTING TO UP SKILL WORKERS.
TO BASICALLY CREATE MORE WORK
FOR EVERYBODY.
AND TWO FOR THOSE BENEFITS TO
ACCRUE TO SOCIETY. UP TO HAVE A
BETTER DISTRIBUTION OF THE
WEALTH SO WE CAN DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT AND INCOME INEQUALITY
AND WADE STAGNATION AND THE
CONCENTRATION OF WEALTH IN THE
HANDS OF THE FEW. SO WE THINK
THOUGH THAT POTENTIAL IS THERE
BUT I REALLY DEPENDS ON
DECISIONS THAT ARE MADE NOW.
BECAUSE WHAT WE THINK WOULD BE A
MISTAKE IS TO STEP BACK AND DO
NOTHING AND HAVE TECHNOLOGY
BASICALLY RECREATE THE TRENDS
WE'RE SEEING NOW WHICH IS
TOWARDS GREATER INCOME
INEQUALITY. AND CONCENTRATION OF
WEALTH IN THE HANDS OF THE.
.
AND SO WORK ALREADY KIND OF
SEEING HIMSELF THAT IN THAT THE
WAY TECHNOLOGY IS BEING DEPLOYED
TODAY I THINK DODD TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE GIG
ECONOMY.
AND HOW AT THE USE OF APPS ARE
ARE BASICALLY ALLOWING FOR
ARMIES OF INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS TO BE DEPLOYED IT
MAKES IT MORE CONVENIENT FOR THE
CONSUMER. BUT IN SOME CASES LIKE
YOU OF UBER DRIVERS THEIR MAKING
THREE DOLLARS AND THIRTY SEVEN
CENTS AN HOUR.
YOU OF COURSE HAVE COMPANIES
LIKE POST MAY IT'S WHICH SOUNDS
LIKE THEY'RE REALLY DOING THE
RIGHT THING AND HAVE WORKERS
THAT ARE WELL PAID AND THEY'RE
THINKING ABOUT THEM.
BUT THAT'S THAT'S NOT A
GUARANTEE THAT'S REALLY UP TO
EVERY COMPANY TO MAKE THAT THAT
DECISION.
YOU ALSO SEE IT IN THE USE OF
ALGORITHMS.
.
THESE WE'VE SEEN THESE M. TO BE
USED IN SCHEDULING YOU MIGHT.
YOU KNOW STARBUCKS GIAMBI JUICE
WALMART THEY ALL DO THIS JUST IN
TIME SCHEDULING WHERE THEY
BASICALLY TAKEN ALGORITHMS AND
THEY PROGRAM THEM WITH. WET AS
CUSTOMER DEMANDS HIGH WHEN'S IT
GONNA BE SUNNY SO PEOPLE COME IN
FOR THE JOB WOULD USE ONCE AGAIN
BE RAINY SO THEY COME IN FOR
THEIR LOTS A. AND SO THEY
BASICALLY PUT ALL OF THESE.
.
THEORY OF VARIABLES I DON'T OF
ATTACK TERM INTO THIS ALGORITHM
SO THEY COME UP WITH PERFECT
SCHEDULING.
BUT THE SCHEDULING IS PERFECT
FOR THE COMPANY
IT MAKES WORKERS COME MEN FOR
THE TWO HOURS WHEN THEIR BUSIEST
AND INTO SENDS THEM.
THAT'S GREAT FOR THE COMPANY
THEY'RE DRIVING DOWN LABOR COSTS
BUT IS NOT GREAT FOR THE WORKER
WHO HAS TO TRAVEL AN HOUR FOR
THEIR TWO HOUR SHIFT AT MINIMUM
WAGE.
BUT THAT ALGORITHM THAT SAME
ALGORITHM COULD BE USED TO SAY
OH YOU'RE WORKER YOU OF CHILD
CARE YOU'RE ANOTHER WORKER WHO'S
TRYING TO HAVE A SECOND JOB
YOU'RE GOING TO SCHOOL WE'RE
GONNA FIGURE OUT THE WAY TO USE
THAT ALGORITHM. TO MAKE WORK
ACTUALLY BETTER DEBT MAKE
SCHEDULES WORK SO THAT YOU KNOW
A MOM CAN TAKE CARE FOR CHILDREN
OR TAKE A KID TO WORK.
ALL OF THAT ALGORITHMS RELIEF IS
NEUTRAL IT'S JUST THAT THE
COMPANIES HAVE DECIDED TO USE
IT.
TO BECOME MORE PROFITABLE WHICH
IS WHAT THEIR MISSION IS VERSES
IN THE INTERESTS OF. THEIR
WORKERS.
AND SO WE REALLY FEEL LIKE IT IS
AT THAT POINT WHERE WE NEED
POLICYMAKERS TO STEP BEN.
AND TO SAY.
ALRIGHT.
WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW THIS
TECHNOLOGY IS GOING TO BE
DEPLOYED NOT JUST NARROWLY FOR
SHAREHOLDERS OF A COMPANY AND
THAT'S.
WHAT COMPANIES ARE SUPPOSED TO
DO THEY HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
THEIR SHAREHOLDERS BUT HOW ARE
WE GOING TO SEE THAT THIS
TECHNOLOGY IS? DEPLOYED ON.
A BROADER LEVEL FOR THE GOOD OF
SOCIETY.
AND SO ONE OF THE SUGGESTIONS
THAT WE WOULD HAVE.
IN KIND OF THAT THE MACRO ON
MOVING FORWARD AS A
RECOMMENDATION IN TERMS OF
POLICY.
IS THAT.
POLICY MAKERS
PULL TOGETHER THE STAKEHOLDERS
WHICH INCLUDE PEOPLE AND
TECHNOLOGY ACADEMICS I WOULD SAY
REPRESENTATIVES OF WORKERS AND
UNIONS CONSUMERS.
.
AND SAY WE NEED TO COME UP WITH.
A COMPREHENSIVE POLICY AND
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK.
AND THIS FRAMEWORK NEEDS TO
FIGURE OUT.
WHAT KIND OF TECHNOLOGIES NEED
TO BE DEVELOPED SO AT THE POINT
OF DEVELOPMENT SO THAT IT CAN
BENEFIT SOCIETY?
HOWARD THOSE TECHNOLOGIES GOING
TO BE DEPLOYED.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO MITIGATE
SOME OF THAT THE NEGATIVE
IMPACTS OF THEM?
M. AND HOW ARE WE GOING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE BENEFITS OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES ARE DISTRIBUTED IN
A WAY THAT MAKES SOCIETY. MORE
JUST AND EQUITABLE.
VERSES REPLICATING THE
INJUSTICES OF THE PAST IN THE
JUSTICES UP TODAY.
AND TECHNOLOGY I THINK AS A TOOL
THAT CAN GET US THERE BECAUSE
THERE'S GREAT POTENTIAL BUT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO TAKE.
ACTION.
AND VERY KIND OF.
I THINK PROACTIVE PREEMPTIVE AND
BIG ACTION THIS IS A TIME FOR
BIG IDEAS BECAUSE. IT'S AS IF
WE'RE ON THE CUSP OF THE
INDUSTRIAL REVOLUTION BUT WE
KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN. AND
SO WE CAN MAKE CHOICES TO
MINIMIZE THE DISRUPTION.
.
AND SO I THINK.
THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS THAT I
WANT TO TOUCH ON THAT'S KIND IN
THE BROAD FRAME AND I THINK
THERE'S THERE'S ROOM TO. TO A
JEW ADDRESS A LOT OF ISSUES IN
THAT OF COURSE WE'RE PRETTY
FOCUSED ON THE WORKPLACE ISSUES.
BUT WE KNOW THAT IT TOUCHES.
OUR MEMBERS AND MANY OTHER
ASPECTS OF THEIR LIVES AS WELL.
.
BUT I WANT TO TOUCH ON A COUPLE
ISSUES WITH IN THAT.
.
BECAUSE.
WE'RE NOT SEEING. THE ROBOT
APOCALYPSE HAPPENING WE'RE
SEEING A MUCH MORE KIND OF
SUBTLE DEPLOYMENT OF OF
TECHNOLOGY WHERE IT WHETHER IT'S
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE.
OR WHETHER IT'S THE AUTOMATION
OF PARTS OF JOBS OF TASKS WHICH
WAS VERY STRIKING IN THE KINSEY
REPORT THAT I THINK THE
COMMITTEE GOT. WAS THAT.
STEEP PERCENT OF ALL OCCUPATIONS
BY TWENTY THIRTY.
WILL HAVE AT LEAST THIRTY
PERCENT OF THEIR TASKS
THAT WILL BE AUTOMATED.
WHICH MEANS THAT IT'S NOT GONNA
BE A ROBOT THAT COMES AND
REPLACES IT IT'S GOING TO BE THE
SUBTLE SHIFTS IN THE WORKPLACE.
THAT COULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR UPSCALING.
BUT ALSO HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DE SKILLED WORKERS TO PAY THEM
LAST AND TO REALLY DRIVE DOWN.
WAGES AND CONDITIONS SO THE
THING THAT I THINK WOULD BE
REALLY IMPORTANT IS WE CAN'T
JUST LOOK AT NET JOB CREATION.
LIKE WE AUTOMATED ONE JOB BUT WE
CREATED ANOTHER JOB SO THAT'S
FINE WE NEED TO REALLY LOOK AT
THE QUALITY OF JOBS.
WE SEE THIS WHEN YOU. GET RID
OF A UPS TRACKING DR JOB OR YOU
GET RID OF IT AUTOMATES II
TRUCKERS JOB AND THEN THE GO BE
AN AMAZON GIVE WORKER.
YOU'RE GONNA TAKE A GOOD UNION
JOB AND ALL OF A SUDDEN IT'S A
LOW WAGE TEMPORARY PART TIME
SEASONAL JOB
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
REBUILD OUR MIDDLE CLASS WITH
THAT'S WE HAVE TO PAY ATTENTION
TO JOB QUALITY.
AND NOT JUST JOB CREATION.
THAT'S A BIG PIECE.
THE SAFETY NET I DON'T KNOW
MISS PART IS I DON'T OF THE
SAFETY NET HAS BEEN.
ADDRESSED.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT PART I KNOW
THAT THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT UNIVERSAL
BASIC INCOME AND PORTABLE
BENEFITS.
.
I DO THINK WE NEED TO BE VERY
CAREFUL ABOUT THAT BECAUSE WE
ALREADY HAVE A SAFETY NET IT'S
DESIGNED FOR WHEN PEOPLEARE OUT
OF WORK IT IS ALREADY FRAYING
AND IT IS ALREADY UNDER ATTACK.
BASICALLY AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE SAFETY
NET WE ALWAYS HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT WHO'S GONNA PAY FOR IT AND
WHO'S GONNA MAKE SURE IT'S IN
THERE.
AND SO WITH UNIVERSAL BASIC IN
INCOME IT'S A GREAT IDEA BUT HOW
ARE WE GONNA FIND IT.
AND HOW WE GONNA MAKE SURE THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT HELPS
PEOPLE TRANSITION TO WORK
BECAUSE WE REALLY THINK THAT
THERE IS VALUE IN WORK AND
THERE'S DIGNITY AND WORK.
SO THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PIECE.
.
AND RICH RETRAINING I THINK
PROFESSOR BROUGHT ME GREAT
POINTS IT'S WE NEED TO HAVE A
JOB MATCHING.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT IF
THERE'S ANY TRAINING OR
RETRAINING WERE PUTTING PEOPLE
INTO A JOB AND WE'RE PUTTING
PEOPLE INTO A HIGH QUALITY JOB.
YOU NOT GONNA TAKE A UNION TRUCK
DRIVER A UNION. A CHECKER AT A
SUPERMARKET A UNION GRIP ON A ON
A. YOU KNOW A FILM SAT. AND SAY.
OKAY NOW WE'RE GONNA PUT YOU
INTO BEING A DISHWASHER OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT THAT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT HELPING WITH ECONOMIC
GROWTH
SO THAT I THINK IS IT A BIG
PIECES WELL AND I THINK WHAT WE
CAN IN YOUR PROGRAM.
WORK WISH WHICH YES YES IT'S
VERY SIMILAR ARGUE WITH
INDIFFERENCE TO PROGRAMS WE HAVE
EARN WHILE YOU LEARN.
I THINK THE SAME THING IS IS
REALLY POSSIBLE HEARING
TECHNOLOGY I THINK ENABLES THAT
AND SO THAT WILL BE A BIG A BIG
PIECE OF IT IS MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE VERY AWARE OF THAT
TRANSITION.
AND THEN I'M ALSO YOU KNOW WHAT
I BECOME TAKE A LESSON FROM THE
CLIMATE CHANGE.
A CREW AND ACTIVISTS IS ADOPTION
HOW ARE WE GOING TO ADAPT AND I
THINK WE'RE GONNA NEED SOME
REALLY BIG IDEAS M. BECAUSE.
WE MAY HAVE A POINT WHERE
TECHNOLOGY BEASTLY SAYS THAT WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE FEWER JOBS.
WE JUST.
IT MAY HAPPEN BUT THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT WE NECESSARILY NEED
FEWER WORKERS.
THAT IF WE LOOK AT JOBS AND
TASKS AS SEPARATE FROM THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE OUR MEMBERS AND
WHO ARE YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO CARE FOR THEM.
THERE ARE WAYS TO DO IT AND WE
HAVE EXAMPLES AND ONE IS.
YOU KNOW THE WORK WEEK THAN
KINSEY STUDY ALSO SAID THAT
THERE HAS BEEN SINCE NINETEEN
HUNDRED THERE'S BEEN A FIFTY
PERCENT DECREASE IN THE HOURS
THAT WORKERS WORK.
I LIKE TO SAY THAT IS BECAUSE OF
THE LABOR MOVEMENT WE BROUGHT
YOU THE WEEKEND.
YOU'RE WELCOME AND THE FORTY
HOUR WEEK BUT MAYBE IT'S TIME
FOR US TO SAY. MAYBE NOW WE NEED
TO GO TO A TWENTY EIGHT HOUR
WEEK.
AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT
WORKERS WORK FEWER HOURS.
FOR THE SAME WAGE WHICH MEANS
YOU HAVE MORE HOURS AVAILABLE
FOR MORE WORKERS.
SO WE'RE PUTTING MORE PEOPLE TO
WORK.
AT THE SAME WAGES BECAUSE
THEY'RE WORKING FEWER HOURS.
AND.
WERE ABLE THAT IS ONE WAY TO
SHARE THE BENEFITS IN THIS IS.
MADE SOME OF THE BIG CRAZY BUT
IN GERMANY.
THERE WAS A UNION THAT JUST
NEGOTIATED THIS IT'S GONNA BE
BASICALLY AFFECT FOUR MILLION
GERMAN WORKERS.
IT'S A STEEL COMPANY AND
THEY'VE NEGOTIATED A TWENTY
EIGHT HOUR WORK WEEK.
AT SIMILAR WAGES AND THEY'VE
DONE THIS FOR OTHER REASONS BUT
ONE OF IT WAS TO ADAPT TO WHAT
IS SEEN AS A MORE FLEXIBLE.
WORK FORCE AND YOU KNOW WE'RE
ENDING THAT THAT KIND OF
TRADITIONAL MODEL WHERE PEOPLE
STAY AT A JOB FOR THEIR ENTIRE
LIVES IN THERE'S MORE
FLEXIBILITY AND ALL OF THAT.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT IT HAS TO
BE A GIG ECONOMY.
WE CAN MAKE THESE BE GOOD JOBS
THAT ARE GOOD JOBS FOR MORE
PEOPLE.
WITHOUT HAVING TO LOWER JOB
QUALITY SO I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
SEE.
TECHNOLOGY IS A TOOL IT'S A TOOL
THAT IT IS IN OUR HANDS THAT WE
CAN BUILD A BETTER FUTURE WITH.
AND I THINK THIS COMMITTEE FOR
STARTING THIS THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A NEXT LET'S
GO TO A SUMMIT ACCORDING.
WELCOME.
CHAIR MEMBERS.
MAMIE SMITH THE CORBIN I
REPRESENT AS YOU KNOW A NUMBER
OF CLIENTS IN THE CONSUMER
PRIVACY AND PROTECTION SPACE
INCLUDING ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION PRIVACY RIGHTS
CLEARINGHOUSE AND.
COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION AND AND
WHAT'S COMPELLING ABOUT THIS
SUBJECT IS.
MUCH LIKE THOSE WHO'VE SPOKEN
BEFORE ME THERE'S NOT ONE AREA
WHERE A AYE DOESN'T.
HAVE SOME SORT OF IMPLICATION
WHERE IT DOESN'T TOUCH
ALL ON ONE OF THE ISSUE AREAS
FOR THE CLIENTS THAT WE
REPRESENT.
THE ABILITY OF A AYE SYSTEMS TO
TAKE JUST A BIG U. S. VAST
AMOUNTS OF DATA AND TRANSFORM
THEM INTO SOMETHING INSIGHTFUL
TO TAKE THEM AND TURN THEM INTO
KNOWLEDGE AND TO DRIVE SOLUTIONS
IS.
SIGNIFICANT IT'S WERE REALLY AT
AN UNSURPASSED MOMENT IN
HISTORY.
THEY CAN BE USED TO TREAT
DISEASETHE STATIC CAN BE USED
PREDICT THE WEATHER TO MANAGE
THE GLOBAL ECONOMY TO MISS
FLOCKS POINT. AND LIKE ALL OF
THE POWERFUL TOOLS OUT THERE.
GREAT CARE MUST BE TAKEN IN THE
DEVELOPMENT DEPLOYMENT AND
REGULATION OF A AYE AND
SIMILARLY INNOVATIVE TOOLS.
CITADELLE SPEAK FIRST ABOUT SOME
OF THE POTENTIAL HARMS AND THAT
THAT COULD EXIST IN THE CURRENT
AND FUTURE LANDSCAPE AS WELL AS
PROVIDE SOME SUGGESTIONS FOR
AREAS WHERE. THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY MIGHT CONSIDER PUBLIC
POLICY SOLUTIONS.
ALREADY CONSUMERS INTERACT WITH
A AYE ON A. DAILY BASIS.
CHILDREN IN PARTICULAR.
DISS A LITTLE BIT TROUBLESOME
AND AND THEY MAY NOT EVEN BE
AWARE CUSTOMER SERVERS HUMAN
RESOURCES COUNSELING FUNCTIONS
ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE BEING
FARMED OUT TO A AYE ASSISTANCE
AND BOX.
SOME OF THESE INTERFACES ARE
ONLY TO BECOME MORE POPULAR IN
ESSENTIAL AREAS LIKE EDUCATION
AND HEALTHCARE ON WHERE YOU HAVE
EVEN MORE SENSITIVE INFORMATION
THAT'S BEING COLLECTED.
AND AND ALL ALONG THE WAY
SHIFTING THE LANDSCAPE OF LABOR
MARKET IN HUMAN INTERACTIONS.
AND PEOPLE TO LET THEIR GUARD
DOWN WHEN THEY'RE TALKING ONLINE
EVEN MORE SO WHEN THEY'RE
TALKING TO BOTS OR A AYE
PERSONAL ASSISTANCE
SOME OF THESE ARE EVEN DESIGNED
TO HEAR AND RESPOND TO A
CONSUMERS. AT INNER MOST
SECRETS.
WHICH PEOPLE OFTEN DO SHARE YET
THE SYSTEMS ARE UNDER NO
OBLIGATION TO DECLARE THEIR NON
HUMAN NATURE AND UNDER FEWER
OBLIGATIONS NOT TO USE THIS
INTIMATE INSIGHT GLEANED FROM
THESE COMMUNICATIONS FOR OTHER
PURPOSES.
IT IS PARTICULARLY TROUBLESOME.
EARLIER MISTER GROWTH SPOKE
ELOQUENTLY ABOUT THE DEGREE OF
INTIMACY BETWEEN INDIVIDUALS AND
TECHNOLOGY AND THEN SUBSEQUENTLY
AS A RESULT OF THAT BETWEEN
INDIVIDUALS AND COMPANIES AND
THAT'S SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGED
WITH THE INCREASING USE OF A
AYE.
SO THE LEVEL OF INFORMATION THAT
CAN BE AGGREGATED THE DEGREE OF
INTIMATE KNOWLEDGE THAT WILL BE
KNOWN ABOUT INDIVIDUALS THIS
LIFE PATTERN DATA. IS IN MANY
WAYS ON PROTECTED BY OUTDATED
EXISTING LAWS REGARDING PRIVACY
SECURITY AND EVEN HUMAN
RESEARCH.
THIS RAISES A VERY SIGNIFICANT
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW THIS
INTIMATE DATA MIGHT BE USED BY
CORPORATIONS OR GOVERNMENTS WHAT
PROTECTIONS DO EXIST WHAT SHOULD
EXIST AND WHAT RIGHTS INDIVIDUAL
SHOULD HOP TO THEIR OWN
INFORMATION.
MR GROWTH ALSO MENTIONED IN HIS
OPENING STATEMENTS THAT MUCH OF
THE CONCERN ABOUT SORT OF THE
SUPER HUMAN POWER OF A AYE THAT
IS THEORIZED IN HOLLYWOOD. IS
LIKELY DECADES AWAY HE ALSO
MENTIONED THAT CHINA IS THE BIG
KID ON THE BLOCK.
AND YOU KNOW THERE ACCORDING TO
A RECENT ARTICLE IN SCIENTIFIC
AMERICAN THEY ACTUALLY HAVE
PLANS TO USE DEEP LEARNING
ALGORITHMS SO THAT THE STATE CAN
DEVELOP A CITIZENS SCORE. SO IN
ESSENCE TAKING THE ONLINE
ACTIVITIES OF CITIZENS OF CHINA
TO DETERMINE THEIR LOYALTY THEIR
COMPLIANCE TO. THE STATE FLAWS
IN TO MAKE DETERMINATIONS ABOUT
THEIR.
LENT ABILITY AND WHETHER
THEY'RE SUITABLE TO TRAVEL OUT
OF THE COUNTRY FOR EXAMPLE SO IF
YOUR FANS OF THE SHOW BLACK
MIRROR YOU MAY RECOGNIZE THE
SIMILARITIES BETWEEN A
PARTICULAR EPISODE. AND IT'S
ACTUALLY USE IN THE REAL WORLD
AND QUICKLY REALIZE THAT NOT ALL
THE VARIOUS USES OF A GUY ARE
THAT FAR OFF IN THE MINDS OF
HOLLYWOOD PRODUCERS.
I AM WHEN YOU COUPLE THE
CONSTANT MONITORING NOW POSSIBLE
THROUGH THE COMPLEX NETWORK OF
THE INTERNET OF THINGS AND WITH
OTHER SORT OF ADDICTIVE AND
BEHAVIOR ALTERING TECHNOLOGIES
THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN PLAY.
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED TO CHANGE
PEOPLE'S OPINIONS AND BEHAVIOR
AND THESE ARE FUTURE
TECHNOLOGIES THESE ARE
TECHNOLOGIES RIGHT NOW. THE
RESULTING SYSTEM IS ONE THAT
TENDS TOWARDS COMPLETE CONTROL
AND PUTS THE CIVIL LIBERTIES OF
INDIVIDUALS AT RISK.
ADVANCES IN COGNITIVE
LINGUISTICS NEUROSCIENCE
AGGRESSIVE DATA COLLECTION
PRACTICES ALL OF THESE COUPLED
WITH A AYE TOOLS OR COMPONENTS
FOR SYSTEMS THAT CAN.
TRULY CHANGE THE WAY THAT PEOPLE
MAKE DECISIONS THE WAY THEY
BEHAVE.
NOT ONLY IN THEIR PERSONAL LIVES
BUT IN ELECTIONS AS WELL. AND
THERE'S A QUESTION AS TO WHETHER
EXISTING LAWS REGARDING THINGS
LIKE TRUTH IN ADVERTISING AND
AVOIDING DECEPTIVE OR UNFAIR
ADVERTISING PRACTICES. FALL
SHORT IN ADDRESSING THE TYPES OF
COMPLEX ALGORITHMS AND
STRATEGIES THAT ARE BEING USED.
TO DRIVE CONSUMER BEHAVIOR AND
INTERACTIONS
SO THEN WE HAVE TO ASK WHAT HOPE
DO UNINFORMED CONSUMERS HAVE IN
RESISTING CAREFULLY TARGETED
DIGITAL MESSAGING THAT USES
TRIGGERING WORDS INTENTIONALLY
TO INFLUENCE THEIR JUDGMENT AND
BEHAVIORS.
MANY OF YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR
WITH THE CONCEPT OF PRIVACY BY
DESIGN.
IT'S IT'S CERTAINLY ONE WE'VE
ADVOCATED FOR HERE AT THE STATE
LEVEL AND IT'S A FORM OF SYSTEMS
ENGINEERING AND WHICH.
PRIVACY IS TAKE INTO ACCOUNT IN
THE ENTIRETY OF THE DESIGN AND
ENGINEERING PROF.
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT'S
CALLED A VALUE SENSITIVE DESIGNS
SO IT MEANS THAT HUMAN VALUES
ARE TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT THROUGH
THE ENTIRE DESIGN PROCESS AND IS
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
CONSIDER THAT CONCEPT OF VALUE
SENSITIVE DESIGN. AS WERE
THINKING ABOUT REGULATING A AYE
AND SIMILAR TECHNOLOGIES.
I'M.
I'VE TESTIFIED BEFORE ABOUT THE
CODE OF FAIR INFORMATION
PRACTICES OF THE FIPS WHICH WERE
DEVELOPED BY OUR OWN FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN THE SEVENTIES.
THAT RECOGNIZE THE VAST
IMPLICATIONS THAT DATA
COLLECTION CAN HAVE ON
INDIVIDUAL PRIVACY SECURITY AND
CIVIL LIBERTIES. AND THE STATE A
FEW THINGS
PERSONAL DATA.
RECORD KEEPING SYSTEMS WHOSE
EXISTENCE IS KEPT SECRET SHOULD
NOT EXIST
ARE THERE SHOULD BE WAYS FOR
PEOPLE TO FIND OUT WHAT
INFORMATION ABOUT THEN IS
RECORDED AND HOW IT'S USED.
THERE SHOULD BE WAYS FOR PEOPLE
TO PREVENT INFORMATION ABOUT
THEMSELVES THAT WAS OBTAINED FOR
ONE PURPOSE FROM BEING USED FOR
AN ENTIRELY DIFFERENT PERSON
PURPOSE EXCUSE ME WITHOUT THAT
INDIVIDUALS CAN SENT. OUT THERE
MUST BE A WAY FOR A PERSON TO
CORRECT ERRONEOUS OR INCORRECT
INFORMATION ABOUT THEMSELVES.
AND AND THEN ANY ORGANIZATION
CREATING MAINTAINING. USING
DISSEMINATING RECORDS OF
IDENTIFIABLE PERSONAL DATA THAT
SHOULD ASSURE THE RELIABILITY OF
THAT DATA FOR ITS INTENDED USE
AND TAKE.
CAUTIONS TO PROTECT AGAINST
MISUSE.
I'M AS DATA BECOMES INCREASINGLY
PROLIFIC AND AFFORDABLE FOR
COMPANIES OF ALL SIZES AND TYPES
TO COLLECT AN AGGREGATE THESE
TYPES OF PRACTICES ARE EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT. YET IN MANY CASES THE
GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN VERY SLOW TO
CATCH UP EVEN ON. ENSURING THAT
THESE PRACTICES ARE IN PLACE FOR
CURRENT TECHNOLOGIES SO FAR AS
LEGISLATION IS CONCERNED WERE
WAY BEHIND AND WRAPPING HER ARMS
AROUND THIS IN FACT MOST
RECENTLY. WE'VE SEEN OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ACTUALLY REPEAL
EXISTING CONSUMER PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS.
THROUGH BROADBAND PRIVACY AND
AND THAT NEUTRALITY MOST
RECENTLY WERE ACTUALLY GOING IN
THE WRONG DIRECTION.
.
AND SO BY FAILING TO PROPERLY
ADDRESS THE CREATION OF REALLY
SIGNIFICANT LONGITUDINAL OVER
LIFETIME PATTERNS OF THE EVA.
WITHOUT THE CONSENT OR EVEN
KNOWLEDGE OF CONSUMERS.
WE PUT OURSELVES IN A VERY
CHALLENGING AND POTENTIALLY
DETRIMENTAL SITUATION AND AS A
AYE BECOMES MORE FREQUENTLY
USED.
TO DRIVE DECISION MAKING.
AND I'M.
SO.
THAT SAID IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN IBM READ A WHITE PAPER
ON THE SUBJECT TO WHICH THEY
SIDE.
TO GREAT WHITE PAPER AND SEND
IT TO. BREAK TO SOCIETAL
BENEFITS OF A AYE SYSTEMS WE
WILL FIRST NEED TO TRUST IT.
BUT THAT BUILDING TRUST ALSO
REQUIRES A SYSTEM OF BEST
PRACTICES THAT CAN HELP GUIDE
THE THIEF AN ETHICAL MANAGEMENT
OF A AYE SYSTEMS INCLUDING
ALIGNMENT WITH SOCIAL NORMS AND
VALUES. ALGORITHMIC
RESPONSIBILITY.
COMPLIANCE WITH EXISTING
LEGISLATION AND POLICY ASSURANCE
OF INTEGRITY OF DATA ALGORITHMS
AND SYSTEMS AND PROTECTION OF
PRIVACY AND PERSONAL
INFORMATION.
AND ON THIS SUBJECT EIGHT I
ACTUALLY AGREE VERY MUCH WITH
IBM I'M SO WITHOUT SOME
SUGGESTIONS FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION IN POLICY MAKING
THAT GO BEYOND JUST WHAT'S IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF
SHAREHOLDERS AND ENTREPRENEURS.
AND COULD POTENTIALLY ENSURE
THAT AS POLICY MAKERS YOU'RE
DOING WHAT YOU'RE ELECTED TO DO
WHICH IS TO PROTECT THE BEST
INTERESTS OF THEIR CONSTITUENTS.
.
FIRST CONSIDER UPDATING PRIVACY
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION LAWS TO
ENSURE ADEQUATE PROTECTION IN
LIGHT OF NEW TECHNOLOGIES ON
THAT INCLUDES PROVIDING
CONSUMERS WITH EASILY DIGESTIBLE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT. IS
COLLECTED ABOUT THEM HOW IT'S
USED AYE AND THEIR RIGHTS TO
PROTECT THAT PERSONAL
INFORMATION FROM UNAUTHORIZED
USE.
REQUIRE CLEAR CONSPICUOUS AND
EASILY DIGESTIBLE DISCLOSURES TO
CONSUMERS ABOUT HOW AND WHEN A I
USE USE TO COMMUNICATE AND
INTERACT WITH THEM.
IN SHORT PROTECTIONS EXIST FOR
TRUTH IN ADVERTISING INCLUDING
POLITICAL ADVERTISING THAT TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT THE BEHAVIOUR
ALTERING NATURE OF A AYE SYSTEMS
COUPLED WITH NUDGING
TECHNOLOGIES REDUCE.
ETHICS BY DESIGN.
ENSURING THAT BUSINESSES DO NOT
KNOWINGLY ENGAGE IN A MANNER
THAT WOULD BE DETRIMENTAL TO
SOCIETY AND ENSURING THAT THE
SAME STANDARDS OF ETHICAL
BUSINESS CONDUCT ALSO GUIDE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A AYE SYSTEMS.
I'M COMPANIES SHOULD HAVE IN
PLACE GUIDELINES THAT GOVERN THE
ETHICAL MANAGEMENT OF THEIR
OPERATIONS.
AND SYSTEMS THAT ENSURE
COMPLIANCE.
I KNOW I GET NEXT ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY AND A AYE
ALGORITHMS AND SYSTEM SO THAT
MEANS AT A MINIMUM THAT THE
ALGORITHMS FOUNDATIONAL TO THE
SYSTEMS SHOULD BE AS TRANSPARENT
AS POSSIBLE. WHICH MEANS THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO EXPLAIN THEIR
BEHAVIOR TO PEOPLE IN TERMS THAT
THEY CAN UNDERSTAND. ABOUT WHAT
THEY DO HOW AND WHY SO HOW DO
THEY INTERPRET AN INPUT WHY DID
THEY RECOMMEND A PARTICULAR
ALPINE. AND WITH THIS
TRANSPARENCY WE CAN CROWD
SOURCED SOME ACCOUNTABILITY
AROUND.
.
POTENTIAL BIAS IN SYSTEMS SO
THAT THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE TO LEARN AND BE BETTER
THAN THE MACHINE TO BE BETTER
PEOPLE AND TO LEVERAGE THESE
TECHNOLOGIES INSTEAD OF BEING
LEVERAGED. BY THE TECHNOLOGY.
CONSIDER REQUIRING APPROPRIATE
VERIFICATION AND VALIDATION
TESTING PRIOR TO THE DEPLOYMENT
OF A AYE TECHNOLOGIES THIS IS
VERY SIMILAR IN CONCEPT TO
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT WE DON'T DO
ENOUGH OF IN TERMS OF PRIVACY
AND SECURITY. FOR I OR T. AND
OTHER DEVICES THE IDEA THAT
BEFORE YOU JUST RELEASE THESE
DEVICES AND THE SYSTEMS ON THE
GENERAL PUBLIC AND IN ESSENCE BE
TO TASK ON YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
THAT THERE SHOULD BE SOME
ASSURANCES THAT THEY'VE
UNDERGONE PROPER VALIDATION AND
VERIFICATION TESTING.
AND WHEN THE SYSTEMS DO FAIL
WHO'S LIABLE FOR THAT
I HAVE WHEN THERE IS HARM AND
AND HOW WOULD WE EVEN KNOWING SO
JUST SOME QUESTIONS TO PONDER
AND THEN. FINALLY AND THIS IS A
POINT THAT THAT HAS BEEN MADE TO
SOME DEGREE BUT I THINK WORTH
CAMP PUNCTUATING.
MY COMMENTS WITH IS THAT WE
HAVE TO LOOK OUT FOR OUR
CHILDREN WERE LITERALLY BETA
TESTING NEW TECHNOLOGIES ON
THEM.
AND THESE ARE TECHNOLOGIES THAT
ARE DESIGNED TO BE ADDICTIVE.
BUT NOT NECESSARILY DIRECTING
PEOPLE TOWARDS SUBSTANCE THAT IS
A QUALITY AND BUT JUST QUANTITY
STAY ON THE PLATFORM STAY ON THE
PLATFORM. AND STUDIES SHOW THAT
KIDS ARE.
INCREASINGLY ANXIOUS WHEN THEIR
SMARTPHONES ARE TAKEN AWAY THAT
THERE'S POTENTIALLY DAMAGE I
THAT CAN OCCUR IN TERMS OF THE
GRAY MATTER IN THEIR BRAINS.
POTENTIALLY DAMAGE RELATED TO.
OBESITY SLEEPLESSNESS ANXIETY
FEELINGS OF WORTHLESSNESS THESE
ARE ALL THINGS FOR WHICH WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYWHERE NEAR ENOUGH
RESEARCH.
AND YET ONCE AGAIN BE IT FROM
PUSH AND NUDGING TECHNOLOGIES TO
CONCERT SMARTPHONE USE I THINK
THE MOST RECENT START I SAW WAS
THAT WE TOUCH OUR FUNDS ABOUT.
THREE THOUSAND TIMES A DAY.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH JUST TO EDUCATE
KIDS AND PROVIDE CURRICULUM
AROUND DIGITAL CITIZENSHIP WE
HAVE TO ACTUALLY PUT SOME
BOUNDARIES AROUND WHAT KIDS HAVE
BEFORE THEM IN TERMS OF
TECHNOLOGY PLATFORMS.
AND HOW THEY'RE INTERACTING
WITH THEM BECAUSE NO AMOUNT OF
TEACHING A NOMADIC CURRICULUM
CAN GET IN FRONT OF THREE
THOUSAND TOUCHES THE DAY THAT
ARE DESIGNED TO ACTUALLY KEEP
YOU COMING BACK.
SO I WOULD I WOULD PUNCTUATE
THAT IT FOR BOTH THIS ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM OF TECHNOLOGIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUT OF
FINALLY LETS GO TO A MISTER DINO
ROW WHO IS THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY AND
LITIGATION WITH ADOBE. WELCOME
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
.
THANK YOU TURNS OUT AND I
MEMBERS COMMITTEE. I HAVE KEPT
HEANEY SPEAK.
.
I KNOW THAT IN A IN A MINUTE
HER.
SECONDS MAYBE BECAUSE OF THE
TIME.
.
SHOW YOU SOME MY I WOULD SAY
POSITIVE EXAMPLES OF HOW WE'RE
USING A AYE IN OUR PRODUCTS I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO.
MAYBE RE ESTABLISH THE VALUE OF
A AYE AND IT'S IT'S BENEFICIAL
EFFECTS.
AND SUSAN HOW ADOBE USES A ITES
CRITICAL TO ADOBE. I'M YOU KNOW
DOUBLE FROM PHOTOSHOP AN ACROBAT
AND.
.
ILLUSTRATOR AND THESE ARE TOOLS
THAT PROFESSIONAL USE EVERYDAY
TO DO THEIR JOB.
AND WHEN WE TALK ABOUT A AYE WE
WANT TO TALK AT W. ONCE TALK
ABOUT HOW THIS HELPS THEM DO
THEIR JOB BETTER.
IN A IN A POSITIVE WAY SO WE WE
LOOK AT IT AS.
HEARTS YOU LEADING HERE BUT WE
HAVE TO SORT OF BUSINESSES THAT
WE FOCUS ON CREATIVITY WHICH IS
YOUR PHOTO SHOP. AND EXPERIENCES
WHICH IS.
BOY WE ARE ANALYTICS BUSINESS
WE PROVIDE.
SERVICES DAY RETAILERS AND E.
TAILERS TO ANALYZE THE BILLIONS
OF TRANSACTIONS I COME ACROSS
WEBSITE PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS
IS OF THE TWO BUSINESSES THAT
WERE. SORT OF FOCUSING ON BOTH
OF THEM YOU SAY I.
AND SO FOR EXAMPLE THIS IS THAT
A TECHNOLOGY IN IN IN OUR
PLAYERS ADVOCATE OF CLOUD
PRODUCT. OF YOUR CREATIVE
PROFESSIONAL RIGHT NOW AND YOU
HAVE A MARKETING CAMPAIGN
INSOMUCH AS I WON CITY SCAPE YOU
GO OUT YOU SET YOUR CAMERA YOU
TAKE THIS PICTURE. IS BEAUTIFUL
YOU COME BACK TO THE MARKETING
CLIENT AND THEY SAY WHAT'S GREAT
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT WE REALLY WANT
TO SUNSET.
SORRY GO OFTEN RE SHOOTING SO
YOU HAVE TO GO OFTEN RESHOOT IT
AND THAT TAKES NOTED THEY TWO
DAYS WEEKS WHATEVER IT IS TO GET
THE SENSE THAT. WE CAN DO WITH
WITH. OUR ABILITY TO ANALYZE
MILLIONS OF PICTURES IS TO
UNDERSTAND.
WHAT A SENSE THAT IS YOU KNOW
MORE YOU GET THAT WORD FROM THE
PROFESSIONAL? WE UNDERSTAND WHAT
IT MEANS WE CAN GIVE YOU THIS
PICTURE YOUR ORIGINAL PICTURE.
HAD A SUNSET AND DOESN'T JUST
PUT THIS GUY ON IT THAT'S THE
COLORS THE ENTIRE. BUILDING SIT
IN IN JEST.
IN JUST TEN SECONDS
TO CREATE A PROFESSIONAL CAN
RESPOND TO THE MARKETING
CLIENTS.
REQUEST AND GIVE THEM WHAT THEY
WANT.
I'M SO THAT TAKES A LOT OF.
DRUDGERY OUT OF YOUR JOB IF
YAKKING JUST WANTED TRYING TO
THIS IN PHOTOSHOP IT WOULD TAKE
YOU WEEKS IF YOU DIDN'T WANT TO
RESHOOT IT.
SOME AND THIS MAY BE ON LOCATION
WE HAVE TO FLY BACK ON OCCASION
THIS ENABLES PRODUCTIVITY THIS
THE EFFICIENCY THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. NOW YOU MAY HAVE
A VERY FINICKY MARKETING PERSON
THEY SAY YOU KNOW I. NEVER MY WE
WANTED SOMETHING SNOW WE'RE
SNOWBLOWER AND THIS HAPPENS ALL
THE TIME AND THEN THEY SAY OKAY
WELL YOU KNOW WE CAN JUST TAKE
THIS PICTURE.
USE OUR A AYE AND WE CAN GIVE
YOU SOMETHING THAT LOOKS LIKE
THIS.
AND IT'S STILL THE SAME PICTURE
YOU CAN TURN THIS AROUND IN
MINUTES NOT WEEKS.
AND IT'S STILL TO CREATE A
PROFESSIONAL THE PERSON
DESIGNING THE PICTURE WHOSE HAS
THE CONTROL OF THIS.
THEY'RE STILL USING THEIR SKILL
THEY'RE STILL USING THEIR
INTELLIGENCE AND THEIR JOB JUST
GOT A LOT EASIER AND THE
MARKETING CALPINE HE'S HAPPIER
TO.
THEY GET THEIR JOB TURNED AROUND
MUCH FASTER.
THIS ALSO WORKS PURSE FOR A FOR
A CONSUMER PRODUCTS YOU MAY HAVE
A FIX YOUR HOUSE YOU MAY SAY I
WANT TO LOOK LIKE MANGO. AND WE
HAVE THIS.
THIS A AYE THE UNDERSTAND STYLE
AND THAT'S THE IMPORTANT THING
IS THINK ABOUT A AYE AYES THE
VALUE IT GIVES YOU IS NOT JUST
IT I WANT MORE READ. IT CAN
THINK ABSTRACT CONCEPTS LIKE
STYLE AND SIT IN THE STYLE OF
MANGO I WANT MY HOUSE I WANT MY
HOUSE TO LOOK LIKE THIS.
AS YOU CAN APPLY THAT.
STYLE TO.
I A NORMAL PICTURE JUST THE
REGULAR CONSUMER USING OUR
PRODUCTS
AND THAT IS ONLY POSSIBLE FROM
MAY AYE UNDERSTANDING WHAT STYLE
IS RUNNING THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF DATA. POINTS INTO
OUR SYSTEM DIFFERENT KINDS OF
PAINTINGS.
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT STYLE IS.
THAT LAST EXAMPLE ON THE
CREATIVE SIDE.
SO IT'S KIND.
AND SO THE OTHER.
.
THE THING WE CAN DO IS WE CAN
TALK ABOUT.
.
I MOTIONS.
AND SO WE WE SHOW YOU A PICTURE
YOU MAY HAVE A PICTURE.
OF YOUR KIDS ANDERSON THEY SEEM
HAPPY AND YOU HAVE DOZENS OF
THOSE AND MAYBE HAVE EVEN MORE
OF THEM WERE CRYING. AND YOU MAY
SAY I WANT ALL THE HAPPY ONES
I'M A I CAN CAN BE TRAINED
UNDERSTAND EMOTION I CAN TAKE A
CONCEPT LIKE HAPPY. AND BRING
BACK A SET OF HAPPY PICTURES WE
CAN EVEN EARLY IN THE PROTOTYPE
IN OUR LIVES RIGHT NOW WE'VE A
SLIDER.
WE GOT THE GLOOMY SLIDER AND OF
THE AND YOU SLIDE ALL THE RIGHT
AND YOU GET BACK ALL THE GLOOM
USE PICTURES AND UNDERSTANDS A
GLOOMY IS INSIDE ALL MALE LEFT
IS ALL THE FROM THE BRAKES GUYS
AND BEACH SCENES RIGHTS HAPPY
RIGHT. AND YOU JUST MOVE THE
SLIDER BACK AND FORTH AND YOU
CAN IT CAN UNDERSTAND THE
EMOTION. THAT YOU'RE SEEKING
THAT THAT'S THE MAGIC OF WHAT A
IDEAS.
ON THAT EXPERIENCE SIDE JUST TO
GIVE AN EXAMPLE.
WHAT WE DO WHAT WE USE IT FOR
HERE NOT AS NOT AS I SEXY
UNFORTUNATELY?
IS WE ALLOW. ME SEIZE OR COALS
OF WHEREAS AN ONLINE SAY WE CAN
PREDICT WHAT THE COST WHAT A
CUSTOMER WHO'S IN RIGHT TO THE
WEBSITE.
IS GOING TO DO ONE WEBSITE ARE
THEY GOING TO BY THE NECK AND
THE BY THEY IN A BROWSER THAT
CAN COME BACK AND WE CAN THEN
LET YOU TARGET YOUR EXPERIENCE
FOR ME SEIZE. SOMETHING TO THAT
PERSON BASED ON OUR ANALYSIS. OF
THE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO'VE
COME BEFORE AND UNDERSTANDING
WHAT THEY WERE DOING IN THAT WE
GENERALIZE THAT CONCEPT AS WE
KNOW WHAT THE OUTCOMES ARE
BEFOREHAND.
WE CAN ALSO ANALYZE YOUR UP TO
PEAS IN THIS IS JUST THIS ATTY
GOES FOR GOVERNMENTS AS WELL WE
CAN TELL YOU. YOU KNOW BASED ON
OUR ANALYSIS OF THE DATA YOU
KNOW WHAT PART OF THE WEB PAGE
GONNA DRIVE CUSTOMER PHONE CALLS
BECAUSE IT'S CONFUSING OR
PARTICULATE. DRIVE EMAIL SIGN
UPS
BECAUSE IT'S ACTUALLY THE PART
IS MOST ATTRACTIVE TO JUST DO
THE ANALYSIS OF THIS DATA WERE
ABLE TO GIVE YOU SERVICES. AND
YOU COULD NEVER EVEN HAVE BEFORE
AND WOULD ALSO TAKE THE REGULAR
PROFESSIONAL.
HOURS AND HOURS SO THIS IS SIR
WHAT ADOBE'S DOING.
IN IN TERMS OF IT'S A AYE AND
I'M IN A LOT OF COMPANIES LIKE
US AND SO USING A AYE TO. TO TO
ASSIST THE PROFESSION ON SO WHEN
I AYE HERE SO I'LL OBVIOUSLY IS
LOTS OF CONCERNS ABOUT.
JOB LOSS
BUT THIS IS THIS IS ABOUT JOB
ENHANCEMENT IS A LOT OF
EVERYONE'S JOB RIGHT NOW THAT'S
FAIRLY TEDIOUS IN ROUTINE AND WE
CAN TAKE THAT AWAY A I CAN TAKE
THAT AWAY.
A AYE WORKS BEST WHEN THERE'S
MILLIONS OF. VERY SIMILAR DATA
THAT YOU CAN ANALYZE IT DOESN'T
REALLY WORK FOR.
SERVE UNIQUE THINGS THAT YOU DO
EVERY DAY SO THE IDEA OF THE A I
JUST AN HOUR IS JUST CAN REPLACE
WHAT. A REGULAR PROFESSIONAL IS
DOING.
OR SOMETHING THAT IS
SOPHISTICATED REQUIRES HUMAN
INSIGHT IT'S IT'S ACTUALLY NOT
POSSIBLE AND THEY NEED
REPETITIVE DATA. TO UNDERSTAND
AND GENERALIZE WHAT IS GOING ON
AND SO.
ADOBE AND AND AND OTHER
COUNTRIES THE IN THE TECH
INDUSTRY WE LOOK AT THIS AS A AS
AS AS A WAY TO.
TO EVEN LOWER BARRIERS OF ENTRY
SO SO MAYBE YOU'RE NOT THE MOST
CREATIVE PERSON IN THE WORLD.
BUT BECAUSE WE'VE MADE OUR TOOLS
SO MUCH EASIER TO USE SOMEONE IS
GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET INTO THE
BUSINESS OF CREATING AD
CAMPAIGNS THAT MAYBE THEY
COULDN'T BEFORE.
THERE'S ACTUALLY AN OPPORTUNITY
TO LOWER THE BARRIER TO ENTRY
DID SOME THE MORE SOPHISTICATED
COMPUTER TOOLS AND ALLOW. THESE
JOBS WE HAVE AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE THE SKILLS AND YOU
DON'T ACTUALLY MAYBE NEED A
MASTER'S IN COMPUTER SCIENCE.
TO UNDERSTAND HOW TO HOW TO
CREATE THESE DATA CAMPAIGNS
ANYMORE IF YOU AUTOMATE THE MOST
TEDIOUS AND DIFFICULT PART OF IT
SO I. I WANNA MAKE SURE EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS IS POSITIVE PART OF
THIS THERE'S THERE'S.
THE THE PROGRESS OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY.
IS GOING TO CREATE MORE IN MY
OPINION MORE JOBS THAN WE WERE
GOING TO LOSE AND.
WHEN WE LOOK BACK A YEAR PRE
INTERNET AND WE LOOK BACK PRE
SMARTPHONE YOU IT'S REALLY HARD
TO IMAGINE HOW IT CHANGED OUR
LIVES IN THE OBVIOUS USE HIM
NEGATIVE THINGS. BUT JUST SO
MANY MORE POSITIVE THINGS THE
REASON WHY SOMEONE TOUCHES UPON
THREE THOUSAND TIMES A DAY.
THERE SOME POSITIVITY
ASSOCIATED WITH IT.
AND I'M A AYE TEN YEARS FROM NOW
WE'RE GONNA LOOK BACK WE'RE
GONNA WONDER HOW WE GET ALONG
WITH. ME HE'S GONNA MAKE
EVERYONE'S LIVES IN CERTAIN WAYS
SO MUCH BETTER AND YOU'RE GONNA
SAY I DON'T EVEN UNDERSTAND WHY
I WAS PUSHING THEM BACK IN CLEAN
AROUND MAKES NO SENSE TO ME
RIGHT. THERE'S EXAM YOU SO MUCH
THAT WE VALUE WE GET OF THIS AND
SO WE WHAT I WANT TO CAUTION
AGAINST.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT WHAT WE CAN
DO AND I THINK THERE'S SOME
THINGS WE CAN DO HERE.
THIS THE CALIFORNIA CAN DO
OTHER STATES OF TRIED TO DO.
BUT THERE'S ALSO I WANT
THROUGHOUT THE CAUTION THAT WE
WERE BURNED EARLY DAYS AND. NONE
OF US KNOW HOW THIS IS GOING TO
AND OR WERE THE STUFF FOR
SHOWING YOU SOME THAT STEPS IN
OUR PRODUCTS SOME OF THAT'S.
JUST PROTOTYPES.
MOST OF THE THINGS I'VE HERE
PEOPLE CAN BE CONCERNED ABOUT
WERE STILL YEARS AND YEARS OUR
WAY OF SEEING US EVEN VIABLE.
AND SO.
I I WOULDN'T WANT TO.
START CREATING POLICY NOW THAT
SORT OF CRASHES
POTENTIAL THAT WE HAVE.
THERE'S GIVE ME PLENTY OF TIME
TO SIR WATCHED AS THIS GOES AND
SAY OKAY THIS. THIS THIS IS
PROBABLY TOO FAR WE MAKE THE
STATE NEEDS TO STEP IN AND AND
REGULATE THIS ASPECT. BUT I'M
BORED I DON'T THINK WE'RE THERE
YET I I REALLY MY CAUTION IS
LET'S NOT.
LET'S NOT I'M LET'S NOT STEP TOO
FAR.
THERE'S SOME DIFFERENT SOME
QUESTIONS ARMED BIAS OR A AND
DISCRIMINATION AND THAT'S A
CONCERN OF THE W. WE HAVE A
COUNCIL ADOBE THAT'S FOCUSED ON
DATA ETHICS.
AND AND.
LIKE OTHER TECH COMPANIES AND
SAID THIS GROUP IS IS ANALYZE IT
WHERE ARE THE BEST PRACTICES FOR
DESIGNING A AYE HOW DO WE
ELIMINATE BIAS YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
SEARCH WE HAVE A STOCK
PHOTOGRAPHY SITE. WE SEARCH FOR
LAWYER ARE YOU ONLY GONNA
CAUCASIAN MALES BACK ARE YOU
GETTING DIVERSITY RIGHT.
KEY TO THAT.
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE THE KEY
TO A AYE BEING NOW I'M.
BEING UNBIASED AND NON
DISCRIMINATORY. IS DATA.
THE MORE DATA WE HAVE THE MORE
MUTUAL THE A I WILL BE SO WHEN
WHEN THE GOVERNMENT THINKS ABOUT
REGULATION ON DATA. IF WE'RE.
MAKING IT MORE DIFFICULT TO GET
DATA.
THEN IT IS MORE LIKELY THAT A
AYE SYSTEMS WILL BE BY.
TO THE BEST THING WE CAN DO TO
MAKE A AYE AYES UNBIASED USED
ENSURE THAT THEY CAN GET TRAINED
ON THE BROADEST. SET OF DATA
THAT THERE'S THAT'S OUT THERE SO
WHEN I WINDOW BE GOES AND LOOKS
AT DATA WE'RE NOT LOOKING FOR
PERSONAL INFORMATION. WE'RE
LOOKING FOR LIKE THE COLOR THE
SKY THE COLOR YOUR HAIR.
SIZE YOUR NOSE TO STRUCTURE
THEIR DOCUMENT WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A PDF ACROBAT
PRODUCT RIGHT THE STRUCTURING OR
THE PARAGRAPHS UNDER TITLES LIKE
WE'RE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE
ASPECTS OF IT.
WE REALLY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
PERSONAL INFORMATION SO I THINK
THERE'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
PRIVACY DISCUSSION TO BE HAD.
BUT WERE TALKING MY A I
SPECIFICALLY AND AND AND AND MAY
BE SUBJECT OF THIS HEARING.
THE A I NEEDS TO GENERAL
INFORMATION WE NEED LOTS AND
LOTS OF INFORMATION AS GENERAL
WE JUST WEEK. KNOWING WHO YOU
ARE IS IRRELEVANT TO TRAINING A
AYE. UNLESS I WAS TRYING TO
TRINITY I TO FIGURE OUT WHO YOU
WERE IN WHICH CASE IS VERY
RELEVANT RIGHT.
AND I SAY THAT I SAY THAT IS A
JOKE BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND THAT YOU
OFFER A LOT OF THE BAD EXAMPLES
OF OF BIAS AND DISCRIMINATION
AND AND AND AND STATE MAYBE.
STATE OVERREGULATION.
THIS MAY BE SHOCKING EVER IN
HERE BUT THAT ALREADY EXIST
TODAY RIGHT ON THE BLACK WOMAN
GETTING STOPPED BY THE POLICE.
ALREADY HAPPENS TODAY RIGHT THE
DISCRIMINATION IN THE BIAS THAT
EXISTS TODAY IT IN AN A. EYES IS
IS A RESULT OF SYSTEMIC BIAS
THAT'S ALREADY PRESENT RIGHT.
THAT IF A HOUSING OFFICIAL
CREATING A AYE AND SAYS I'M ONLY
GONNA GIVE OUT LOANS TO CERTAIN
PEOPLE'S RACE BECAUSE OF THEIR
PROFILE. AND THAT YEAH I LEARNED
THAT BECAUSE OF THE DATA IT WAS
FIVE.
RIGHT AND SO.
WE NEED THAT MEANS REALLY SMART
ABOUT THE INSTITUTIONS WEB
DISCRIMINATION MATTERS
ESPECIALLY FOR THE STATE'S.
AND WE ALREADY ARE.
AWARE OF THAT WE ARE TO HAVE
LAWS.
IN THOSE INDUSTRIES TO ENSURE
THAT THERE IS NOT DISCRIMINATION
NAKED DISPROPORTIONATE AFFECT
SOMEONE TRYING TO GET A LOAN
TRYING TO RENT A HOUSE. AND SO
THE PLACES WHERE WE'VE ALREADY
FELT THE NEED TO REGULATE ARE
PROBABLY PLACES WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO GO IN AND MAKE SURE THAT
THE DATA SAID STARTING TRAINED.
EYES THAT ARE MAKING DECISIONS
ARE DIVERSE
YOU MAY HAVE TO PUT YOUR THUMB
ON THE SCALE AND SAY LET'S MAKE
SURE WE OVER CORRECT HERE
BECAUSE IF YOU JUST TAKE THE
REGULAR DATA WE MEAN UP WITH
BIAS RESULTS. BUT I THINK WE ARE
DO YOU KNOW WHERE THOSE
INDUSTRIES ARE IT'S NOT EVERY
INDUSTRY.
IF THIS IF CHINA WANTS TO GO
AHEAD AND AND MINOR ITS PEOPLE
IT'S ALREADY MONITORING ITS
PEOPLE.
IT'S ALREADY DOING THAT RIGHT
NOW A EYES A TOOL IT'S GOING TO
MAKE IT BETTER AT IT. BUT AGAIN
A EYES TO TOOL.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO STOP CHINA
FROM MONITORING ITS PEOPLE IF
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT TO DO IN
AND AND HAVE THESE PROFILES
RIGHT SO AGAIN SOME OF THIS IS
THE MOTIVATION OF THE ACTOR. AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THE MOTIVATION THE ACCURATE WE
HAVE ALL THIS TIME AND AS WITH
THE OTHER IS IN PLACE AND VERY
MAJOR ROLE BECAUSE THE D. BIASES
COULD BE INCORPORATED INTO THE
OF THE THE WAY THAT THE
ALGORITHM IS.
CONSTRUCTED OR A BEING WRITTEN
RIGHT IS IN THAT PART OF THE.
EQUATION AS WELL RIGHT AND I
THINK I'M JUST A OUTSIDE OF
ELECTRONS IN YOUR UNDERGRAD AND.
CAN A PATENT LAWYER WITH LAW
SCHOOL ANYWAY.
.
SO THERE'S NO ALGORITHMS I JUST
MIGHT THROW THAT OUT THERE.
WHAT WITH THE WAY THAT?
A AND I THINK SOME OUR
PANELISTS BEFORE.
CORRECTLY DESCRIBED AS THE WAY
I WORKS IS ASSISTANCE FEEDBACK
LOOP THERE'S IS A MODEL OF.
FILTER WILL CALL IN THE STATE
CONTENDS IT'S LIKE YOUR BRAIN
IT'S NO THAT COMPLICATED. AND
WE JUST PUT A BUNCH OF DATA AND
WE SAY HERE'S BUT THE CATS
CATS CATS CATS CATS AND THEN IT
SAYS OKAY I CAN RECOGNIZE CATS.
WE PUT SOME DOGS AND CATS AND
DOGS TO GET THAT AND THEN THE
MAGIC OF A AYE IS YOU THROW
HORSE AND THERE'S AGO IT'S NOT
GONNA DIE THINGS OF COURSE.
RIGHT SO STE EIGHTEEN FIGURES
OUT SOMETHING YOU DIDN'T TRAIN
THAT'S WHAT MAKES A AYE.
DIFFERENT THAN AN ALGORITHM
ALGORITHM CAN ONLY RESPOND
EXACTLY TO WHAT YOU TRAINED IN
NONE.
SO THAT THROUGH THE BIAS ISN'T
IN CONSTRUCTING THE MODEL.
THE BIASES IN THE DATA NINE SO
IF IF I FEED IN A AYE AND ALL I
GET IS CATS.
IT LOOKS OF A DOG IN NEW THE SAY
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS YOU
KNOW SO I SAY. YOU KNOW JUST DID
TO GIVE MY LENDING EXAMPLE OF I
SAY THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUCCESSFULLY CREDIT WHERE THE
ARE YOU KNOW WHITE MALES WHO ARE
OVER FIFTY.
AND AFTER AMERICAN PERSON
TWENTY FIVE TRY SUPPLY THEY'RE
GONNA SAY NO RIGHT YOU CAN SEE
ALL THE DATA TELLS ME THAT THE
ONLY PEOPLE WHO OR GOOD CREDIT
RISK ARE THESE OTHER PEOPLE
RIGHT AND SO IT'S ABOUT THE
DATA.
IS ACTUALLY NOT ABOUT HOW YOU
CREATED THE A AYE IT'S ABOUT THE
DATA YOU FED THE A AYE AYE
THAT'S WHY HE SAID YOU KNOW THE
BROADER THAT THE DATABASES THAT
THAT MORE ACCURATE ISN'T THE
MORE JUST NOT DISCRIMINATORY THE
THE THE IMPACT WILL BE.
ABSOLUTELY AND I ALSO SAID YOU
KNOW FOR CANDOR RIGHT THERE SOME
PLACES WERE BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN
SYSTEMIC BIAS. YOU'RE NOT GONNA
HAVE THAT DATA RIGHT YOU'RE NOT
GONNA GET THE MAGIC THAT DATA UP
ABOUT PEOPLE HAVING GREAT CREDIT
SCORES WHO WERE OR MINORITIES
BECAUSE.
YOU KNOW SYSTEMICALLY MAYBE THEY
HAVE BEEN DISENFRANCHISED THEY
DON'T HAVE GREAT CREDIT SCORES
AS YOU'RE NOT GONNA HAVE A DAY
AND THAT'S WHERE I THINK TODAY
JUST LIKE YOU ARE DOING TODAY.
YOU HAVE TO PUT YOUR THUMBS
GALLONS AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
OUTCOMES ARE ARE ON OUR UNBIASED
THE EASIEST WAY TO DO THAT.
THE SIMPLEST WAY AYE UNLIKE SOME
THE THINGS EFFORT IS TESTING YOU
CAN TEST THESE ALGORITHMS YOU
CAN TEST THE A AYE YOU CAN THROW
IN.
CANDIDATES AND THEN SEE WHAT
YOU'RE GETTING BACK
AND SAY OKAY I THINK THIS THING
HAS OF SYSTEMIC BIAS IN IT
BECAUSE THE DATA IT'S IT'S BEEN
FED IS IS IS ERRONEOUS.
BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUT
THAT'S A LOT OF INFORMATION AND
TODAY.
IF THE INFORMATION OVERLOAD BUT.
I'VE BEEN TAKING NOTES OF
FRANTICALLY AND TENS IS I'M
GONNA HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE
TAPE AND WATCH EVERY EVERYONE OF
YOUR PRESENTATIONS AND IN ON
JUST THAT. I'M A MORE SENSE OUT
OF IT SO I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR.
INTO FORTUNATELY OR
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS ONLY THE
BEGINNING I THINK BECAUSE I'M
HOPEFUL THAT. THIS IS ONLY THE
BEGINNING OF A DIALOGUE THAT'S
GONNA NOW CONTINUE ON AND I HOPE
THAT YOU ALL OF YOU WILL BE PART
OF THAT DISCUSSION AS WELL AS WE
GO. SO.
WE DO WE ARE BUT I DID WANT TO
ASK ONE MORE QUESTION AND THAT
IS I THINK THREE OF THE
PRESENTERS THEM THEY MADE
MENTION OF THE WORD ETHICS AND I
THINK THAT. KIND THAT
UNDERSCORES THE IMPORTANCE OF
ETHICS THAT.
AS PART OF THE EQUATION SO MY
QUESTION IS WHAT IS THE BEST
APPROACH TO TO INCORPORATE THAT.
DE DE ETHICS A PIECE INTO THE
EQUATION A WHETHER IT IS SO YOU
KNOW SHOULD WE PUT IT AS PART OF
THE COMPUTER SCIENCE A PROGRAM
OR SHOULD WE MAKE IT PART OF
THAT THE TRAINING FOR WORKERS
AND AND VARIOUS COMPANIES AND
THE LIKE AND WHAT IS THE. I MEAN
IS THERE ONE.
EASY THERE'S NO EASY WAY BUT
BUT WHAT WOULD BE. WHAT WE WOULD
BE SOME IDEAL APPROACHES SAID IT
TO INCORPORATE ETHICS INTO THE
EQUATION?
ANYONE.
OH I'LL GIVE IT A SHOT JR.
MOST INTERNET COMPANIES THAT I
SPEAK WITH HAVE THEIR OWN ETHICS
PANELS OKAY OF S. OF OUTSIDE
EXPERTS NOW THESE ARE PEOPLE
COMPENSATED BY THE DIGITAL
COMPANIES.
I THINK THAT'S A GOOD START AND
I THINK I WANT TO APPLAUD THE
LIKES OF GOOGLE AND OTHERS FOR
DOING THAT. I DO BELIEVE THAT WE
HAVE TO HAVE AN INDEPENDENT
WATCHDOG. AND WE NEED TO HAVE AN
INDEPENDENT PANEL OF EXPERTS
THAT.
ISN'T DIALOGUE WITH THOSE
PANELS AND THIS COULD BE.
FRANKLY CONFIDENTIAL BECAUSE
YOU KNOW THERE IS THE RISK OF
AND I'M A BUSINESS PROFESSOR SO
ALL BE VERY OPEN IN MY OWN BIAS
COMPANIES LIKE ADOBE AND OTHERS
WILL LOSE COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE.
IF.
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
ALGORITHMS A STRUCTURED OR HOW
THE APPLICATION WORKS IF THAT
WERE TO LEAK.
AND THAT NEEDS TO BE GUARDED
BECAUSE THAT. THOSE ARE THE
COMPANIES THAT EMPLOY A
CALIFORNIANS.
AND HAVE IMPACT ECONOMIC IMPACT
ABROAD BUT THERE DOES NEED TO BE
SOME KIND OF INDEPENDENT BODY
THAT.
DOES BEST PRACTICE SHARING IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE HEAVY HANDED
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE REGULATORY
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE PUNITIVE. BUT
IT DOES NEED TO GOVERN IN TERMS
OF OVERSIGHT UNDERSTANDING
WHAT'S GOING ON. AND SOME KIND
OF CONFIDENTIAL DIALOGUE BEHIND
THE SCENES THESE COULD BE
ROTATING EXPERTS THAT ARE SWORN
TO SECRECY CONFIDENTIALITY
AGREEMENTS WHATEVER IT MAY BE.
BUT I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S NEEDED
I THINK ALL OF OUR PANELISTS AT
THIS THAT'S WHAT NEEDED WHAT'S
NEEDED TO INSTILL TRUST TRUST IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT CURRENCY. AND
I I HAVE TO TELL YOU MOST OF THE
PEOPLE THAT I COUNSEL WHETHER
THESE ARE EXECUTIVES IN MY
CONSULTING BUSINESS OUR STUDENTS
AND AND AND GRADUATE SCHOOL.
THEY THEY UNDERSTAND THAT A WE
ARE TO. A CUSTOMER THAT DOESN'T
TRUST YOU IS NOT A GOOD
CUSTOMER.
AND SO YOU WANT TO TRUST AND YOU
DON'T WANT THE PUBLIC BACKLASH
SO I THINK WE'RE ALL MOTIVATED
TO WORK ON THIS TOGETHER. AND I
WILL ALSO SAY THAT THAT DOES NOT
HAVE TO.
THAT DOES NOT HAVE TO.
PUT A DENT INTO OUR WORK GOING
TO ECONOMIC GROWTH.
I I I I WORK A LOT WITH
ENTREPRENEURS ENTREPRENEURSHIP
IS ABOUT LIVING WITH AND ACTING
WITHIN IN FINDING SOLUTIONS
WITHIN CONSTRAINTS.
AND SOME OF THESE ETHICAL
FRAMEWORKS WILL BE SOMEWHAT
CONSTRAINING AND THAT'S OKAY WE
WILL WE WILL WORK WITH SOLUTIONS
WITHIN THOSE CONSTRAINTS.
OR THE IDEA THAT.
IT WE WILL SACRIFICE ECONOMIC
GROWTH BECAUSE OF SOME ETHICS
CONSTRAINTS.
IS RIDICULOUS.
AS THERE'S PLENTY OF GOOD
BUSINESS TO BE HAD WHILE BEING
ETHICAL.
AND I THINK WE CAN AGREE TO ON
THAT SO THAT'S MY RECOMMENDATION
AND I WOULD ADD TO IT JUST ONE
POINT THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN. AND
AND WE DISCUSSED IT A LITTLE BIT
YOU KNOW. IN PREVIOUS
CONVERSATIONS BUT THERE'S A
SIMILAR MODEL THERE'S ALREADY A
LITTLE BIT OF A PROXY THERE IN
THAT WE DO HAVE AN ETHICAL
STANDARDS FOR RESEARCH FOR HUMAN
SUBJECTS.
WE DO HAVE STANDARDS FOR
INSTITUTIONAL REVIEW BOARDS BUT
THEY'RE A LITTLE BIT ADJACENT
RIGHT BECAUSE WHEN WE ARE
TALKING IN THOSE SITUATIONS
ABOUT RESEARCH THAT'S DONE BY
EDUCATIONAL HEALTH CARE
INSTITUTIONS AND RAT. SORT OF
THIS UNPRECEDENTED TIME WHERE
INDIVIDUALS ENTREPRENEURS
COMPANIES REALLY CAN ACCESS EVEN
MORE INFORMATION AND DO MORE
SUBSTANTIVE RESEARCH THAT IS
REALLY COVERED BY. THOSE
STANDARDS AND SO I THINK LOOKING
AT A SYSTEM THAT WAS ALREADY
DEVELOPED TO PROTECT PEOPLE AND
SEEING HOW CAN WE.
OVERLAY THOSE TYPE OF THINGS AS
A PROXY IN THESE CONVERSATIONS
AND YOU KNOW WHETHER IT'S
WHETHER IT'S ON THIS SUBJECT
WHETHER FRANKLY IT'S ON THE
NATIONAL DISCUSSION AROUND.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT THERE'S
THERE'S OFTEN A PROBLEM WITH THE
FOX GUARDING THE HEN HOUSE AND
SO EVEN WHERE THERE'S A DESIRE
TO PROMOTE TRUST AND WHERE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO PRESERVE. TRUST OF
THE PUBLIC SO THAT A COMPANY
DOES NOT LOSE.
FRANKLY MONEY RIGHT CHAIR.
AND SOMETIMES THAT PERVERTS
ITSELF IN A MANNER IN WHICH
PEOPLE COMPANIES TO SHAREHOLDERS
ARE FREE TO DISCLOSE INFORMATION
THAT COULD BE DAMAGING RATHER
THAN ADDRESS PROACTIVELY THE
PROBLEM. AND SO.
YOU KNOW I I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU
TO LOOK AT WATERS MODELS LIKE.
DIRE BE WHAT OUR MODELS LIKE
HUMAN RESEARCH LAWS THAT CAN
APPLY HERE IN TERMS OF ETHICAL
STANDARDS AND WHERE SOME SORT OF
OUTSIDE ACCOUNTABILITY THAT'S
NOT JUST SUBJECT DECLINE
ATTORNEY PRIVILEGES OF WHOEVER'S
BEEN HIRED BY. A PARTICULAR
COMPANY TO ADVISE THEM ON THEIR
ETHICAL STANDARDS.
GOD. I GRAY SUGGESTIONS THAT
WITHOUT THE O. INITIAL COMMENTS
RIGHT OUT YEAH ONE ONE FINAL
COMMENT SILLY THERE'S A BRIDGE
WE NEED TO STRIKE HERE AND WE
FRAME THIS EMPLOYMENT PROBLEM AS
WELL AND AND I THINK.
MISS FLOCKS.
SAID.
SOMETHING TO THE EFFECT OF HOW.
WE ARE NOT NECESSARILY LIVING
IN A WORLD WHERE EVERYBODY IS
HAPPY WITH THEIR JOBS.
IN EFFECT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
STATISTICS.
OF FORTY FIFTY SIXTY EIGHTY
PERCENT DEPENDING ON THE POLL
THAT YOU LOOK AT OF PEOPLE AND
THEY ARE UNHAPPY IN THEIR
CURRENT JOBS.
WHY THAT WHY IS THAT THE CASE IS
IT BECAUSE OF SOMETHING MISTER
RAUH MENTIONED WHICH IS THAT
IT'S TO DRUDGERY?
WHY NOT HAND THE DRUDGERY TO A
AYE?
AND LET THE HUMANS DEAL WITH
WHAT REALLY FULFILL SOME WHAT
REALLY MAKES AND CREATIVE AND
WHAT KEEPS THEM. YOU KNOW IT IT
STIMULATED ON THE JOB
SO I THINK THAT TO ME IS THE BIG
PROMISE OF A AYE RIGHT TO READ
DO THE CURRENT STATE OF ECONOMIC
AFFAIRS IS STILL VERY MUCH A
TERRORIST SYSTEM IN MANY PLACES.
WHERE PEOPLE ARE VERY MUCH
PACKAGED AND CATEGORIZED AND HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE STILL PUNCHING
IN THE CLOCK?
IS THAT REALLY THE BEST WE CAN
DO AS HUMANS.
THANK YOU VERY GOTTA ON THAT
NOTE THEY ARE. I WANNA THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR FOR BEING HERE AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS
AND ARE. IN FACT I I DON'T KNOW
IF THEY'RE ANY OF THE OTHER
PRESENTERS ARE STILL HERE BUT I
WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY.
FOR ATTENDING AYE I KNOW SOME
OF YOU TRAVEL FROM AFAR SO.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR BEING
HERE AND I THINKWE STILL HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT SO I'M GONNA
DISMISS SOME GOOD EXCUSE ARE YOU
PRESENTERS AND THANK YOU AGAIN
AND TO OPEN IT UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR THE NEXT FEW MINUTES
I'VE THERE'S ANY. PUBLIC
COMMENTS.
HOW FEEL FREE TO COME ON UP
ABOUT? AND THAT TO SPEAK IN
FRONT OF THE IN FRONT OF MY.
THANKS THANKS THANKS MUCH.
WELCOME.
I AS PARIS A FEW STATEMENTS
CHAIR SO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS ALEX. ALEX I'M AN
ENTREPRENEUR AND I WORK.
WITH MANY NEW EXISTING
TECHNOLOGIES.
PARTICULARLY IN THE PHOTOGRAPHER
ANGEL SERVICE OR FINANCIAL
TECHNOLOGY FIELD. TENTEC FLASH
TECHNOLOGY.
A I OR MACHINE LEARNING HAS MANY
APPLICATIONS IN THE FINANCIAL
SERVICES FIELD.
AND WITH YOUR PERMISSION I WOULD
LIKE TO SHARE MY EXPERIENCES.
AND OPINIONS REGARDING THIS
HEARING.
I'LL JUST BRIEFLY BRIEFLY YES
SIR.
OKAY.
SO.
CALLING A I A I IS LITTLE BROAD
APPROVED CALL IT MACHINE
LEARNING. FOR SPECIFIC PURPOSES
AND OTHER PURPOSES CHOIR AT THE
THINKS.
ONE OF THE APPLICATIONS OF THE
AYE THAT'S WE'VE SEEN THE FRENCH
WORD WORLD OUR UNDERWRITING OR
CREDIT DECISIONS.
DEFAULT RATES CAN BE PUSHED DOWN
SIGNIFICANTLY WITH APPLICATIONS
OF ALGORITHMS
ALTHOUGH REGULATORS HAVE
REQUIRED FINTECH OR FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION CHAU EXACT RIGHT
HERE CRITERIA WATERFALL OR
BUSINESS PROCESS.
THAT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THOSE
DECISIONS.
KIND OF.
YOU KNOW HANDCUFFING SOME OF
THE.
APPLICATIONS OF A AYE IN THAT
SPACE.
NOT INCLUSIVE AND MANY MILLIONS
OF DIFFERENT OPERATIONS RESULT
NO CLEAR PATH TO DECISIONS
AUTOMATICALLY DISQUALIFYING THAT
WAS APPLICATIONS THAT AFFECT
CONSUMERS. OR PROTECTED CLASSES
IN UNDERWRITING DECISIONS ARE
CREDIT DECISIONS.
AND THEN.
LASTLY HOW CAN CITY CALIFORNIA
BECOME MORE INNOVATIVE.
MAYBE APPLY CHAT BOT FOR
FREQUENTLY ASKED QUESTIONS
ACROSS ACROSS ALL DEPARTMENTS.
AND APPLYING IT CONCEPT OF
DESIGN THINKING.
TAKING THE APPROACH OF CITIZEN.
OR START RESIDENT AND WORKING
BACKWARDS ON HOW TO. BEST APPLY
RESOURCES.
AND THEN.
.
ONE YOU KNOW.
A POTENTIAL APPLICATION AT A AYE
OR MACHINE LEARNING WOULD BE.
WROTE.
DIDN'T.
A REAL TIME.
IMPACT FORECASTS AND BACK
CASTING.
OF OUT OF BUDGET ALLOCATIONS AND
THE BENEFITS THEY BRING TO
SOCIETY LIKE REAL TIME LIKE YOU.
LOOK IT UP AND SEE.
SCORE.
AND THEN HOW CAN CALIFORNIA
TRAIN RESIDENTS WHO ARE
VULNERABLE TAKE TECHNOLOGY.
ADVANCEMENTS.
ESPECIALLY LOOKING AT THE FACT
THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE BEING.
REPLACED ARE TECHNICALLY
LAGGARDS IN TRAINING OR TRAINING
THEMSELVES ARE APPLYING
THEMSELVES.
SO HOW DO YOU ENCOURAGE THAT
LIKE HAVE YOU HEARD PEOPLE WHO
ARE ACTIVELY NOT PARTICIPATING
IN IT TRAINING THEMSELVES.
AND SO LAST THEY'LL SAY.
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR SHARING
PERSONAL DATA ARE NOT SHARING
PERSONAL DATA IS ALREADY IN
PLACE IN EXCESS THERE'S
COMPANIES ARE DEVELOPING THAT.
AND POLICE POWERS NEED TO BE.
BALANCE WOULD PUBLIC NEEDS.
AND.
THAT'S IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILLIAM PUT
PROCEED AT THAT. OTHER IN
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
FROM A PUBLIC SEEING NONE.
THE MEETING IS ADJOURNED. THANK
YOU